foreign
I have to press go live not only in OBS
but on YouTube hey everyone
good morning
uh right can everyone hear me is my
voice okay let's do a voice press
yes hello and good morning everyone uh
yeah as I said
before
before I was live anyway uh I'm gonna be
on for a whole day happy one million
everyone thank you for being here so
yeah uh this is like the this is like a
pretty calm time in terms of streaming
so I'm not expecting
too many people
uh but uh yeah now it's like the dead of
the night in the US and now it's
Saturday morning in Europe so whatever
uh
yes two Lieutenant exactly uh let me see
if I can [ __ ]
pop out the chat yeah
uh yeah
I'm trying to find like a not awkward
way of of uh
yeah because if I like the chat is now
popped out but it just [ __ ]
disappears
uh yeah you know what just have the chat
on screen okay
for now uh I should probably integrate
this into OBS at some point I got my
little party hat too by the way for the
1 million occasion and I thought in the
morning we're gonna go through some news
articles first
if you wanted to cover something by the
way feel free to DM it to me on Discord
so uh do not send links to YouTube chat
but uh I would say yeah basically just
message me at Discord I'll see it anyway
um
so we can start I think by reviewing the
program
basically so today like now we start and
I'm gonna be on until evening uh
European time so it's like 10 hours or
so
I think I'm gonna be streaming today and
um I'm gonna have at 14 so in six hours
five and a half hours I'm gonna have a
crowd on
then not just bikes and then Ellen
Fisher and then RM Transit that's Reese
and then I'm gonna have a debate at 5
p.m Central European Time that's in uh
uh five and a half hours
five no that's uh well that's 17. oh God
it's it's morning anyway uh six and a
half and then I'm gonna have Dylan burns
on uh and then we're gonna end with that
oh a Super Chat uh Happy Millennium Subs
May there be more glorious dunking of
the elongated muskrat thank you very
kind of you thank you for donation and
thank you for being here and Owen Jones
says for it party time it's previous
person who the previous Super Chat I
cannot z741xp
and then a symbol I should probably
remember but I don't I actually study
Japanese but
I know I should refresh that probably
anyway
uh yeah so we can actually start with I
think a quick review of the situation in
Ukraine and then we're gonna do the same
thing with with guests well mostly Dylan
and uh but then again things do change
throughout the day so it should be fun
plus people come and go
Etc uh yeah and by the way if you have
any
um I also have a q a session so if you
have any questions uh do not hesitate to
uh ask them either DM them to me on
Discord or but like the surest way of of
getting your questions
answer this is a Super Chat
so I'm gonna when I see a super chat
with a question I'm gonna note it down
uh
yeah so let's
um
let us take a look at the
um
[Music]
[ __ ] I should first probably figure out
how
no I mean there's no there's no like you
know s uh
whatever anyway so the chat goes away
from it
[Music]
and we're going to start with
the our Ukraine update and I'm gonna
shrink myself here a little bit
there we go uh so
here we have the map of Ukraine uh one
of the big developments currently is the
sole of that area
which is uh here like where the where
the yellow yellow green blue [ __ ]
uh should have slept more when the uh
where the blue
AK symbol is
um right so here what's happening was is
uh Russians have been pushing through
this area here's I think this salt mine
in this area and Wagner has been
Wagner's diversary group has been like
basically going at it like [ __ ]
zombies
uh in like waves the overwhelm The
Defenders and they did
um to some extent but the what's very
important about Soledad is that
ukrainians are doing a fighting Retreat
there so
uh you know people if you see any Russia
stands going like who are you great you
get owned whatever like and that's and
that's not how it works and also
um
also solidarity is I mean it sucks that
they lost it but it's I mean
strategically it's
it's not that important like the slovian
scramators axis would be it like if the
Russians have that then they have the uh
the Don best or the Don escoblast
because lewansko blast is gone pretty
much or no actually is going to be gone
soon but
um yeah so this is tactically kind of
questionable but at least at any rate
it's not worth
uh the casualties that the Russians are
have
you know committed there or like all the
people who have died their Russian
scripted there anyway and um what
ukrainians seem to be doing currently is
that like Russians
are like trying to break through defense
lines with their faces so ukrainians are
just like iterating them down and the
question is who gets it treated first uh
or more severely I think it's of course
Russia because Ukraine is getting better
and better equipment than there more and
more people whereas Russia is having
trouble on both fronts they will not run
out though
like this is this is a myth um in war
that like oh yeah this this site is
gonna run out now this site is going to
[ __ ]
um they're gonna run out of ammo they're
gonna run out of them no no no no
there's always a a steady supply of both
uh only
you know if something
uh so okay if someone says that Russia
is running out of artillery ammunition
sure they might be but they will not run
out period
uh they might experience shortages
because
uh they use more than they produce but
they always produce some and same with
Manpower there's as far as we're
concerned as far as this far is
concerned this war is concerned we're
going to have
um
we're gonna have Russian troops on the
ground always like Russia will not run
out
um so when Russia expends too many
artillery Amos
or ammunition uh too much they some
people will say oh yeah uh it's Russia
is going to run out no Russia will just
scale down uh output
or rather well by output I mean I mean
uh the actual shooting of the rounds so
that production can catch up and so the
two levels will like always follow each
other
yeah same with Manpower but of course
there is a Breaking Point uh but we are
not there yet absolutely not I think
this war is going to go on for at least
half a year
possibly more Putin has indicated that
that he's in this for the long run
okay and also we have
the
equipment loss reports which I'm usually
fond of uh this this is my Twitter
account by the way I use it purely for
lurking I do not post anything so I mean
feel free to follow but like it's it's
for it's for notes I'm afraid so these
are these are the ukradian losses added
on the 13th
uh it's 12 t72 brm1k
mtlb Shield MSL Shield what's an MSL
Shield actually
is it like a is it a western uh
yes it's it's a
it's an MSL sh one second let me just
open a picture yeah so this is the MSL
Shield it's an Italian uh I guess
armored uh
uh armored vehicle uh yeah they lost one
rip BTR 80 I mean for those uh obsolete
goes up to uh those are Ukrainian armor
Jeeps oh they lost The Hobbit sir but
they have like 150 and some trucks
so this is the Ukrainian Ukrainian
losses have been like gravitating
between
12 20 that sort of thing like so that's
the usual and here we have apparently a
30-day average
uh with Russia is getting a ratio yeah
um
yeah so for for the longest the average
has been like what is this a 30 day
average
uh
[Music]
average loss of a uh of lost equipment
uh there might be some like statistical
anomaly here oh yeah wait yeah around
New Year's there was like a decline
for multiple days but I think this this
is like this is more indicative
so ukrainians are losing like 10 ish
pieces like 10 to 15 things per day and
Russians are like 15 to 20. yeah
and the ratio
yeah is uh yeah it's usually like two to
three
here it was more even like this this was
more attritional Warfare here but yeah
these statistics I mean you can nicely
uh see the
uh averages yeah see on the fifth of
January Ukraine only lost like five
things but here I have the
Russian oh people are already following
me well thanks guys but you you don't
have to you know it's it's just uh it's
just a lurking account
um
so we got 29 Russian losses I added on
the 13th of January
I got d72s a t80 a t90s I think the t90s
is the is the export version
of the
let's see Army technology t90s
blah blah
okay so the t90s
main battle tank is the main battle tank
middle Texas population
[Music]
1992
[Music]
in February 2001 the Indian army signed
um yeah so I think they're talking about
1890 the t90s
yeah it's um
one second I'll restore the YouTube chat
for me
yeah so the t90s
is the is the um
that is the um export
version
yeah I'm seeing lots of experts yeah so
anyway yeah 40 49 years thanks to the
armed forces the Uganda
uh
uh and um yeah oh now I'm also looking
at the
hmm
chat oh yeah YouTube YouTube YouTube
this I I almost like I want to read the
comment of like Russia destroyed four
Bradley's you know the
vehicles that aren't even deployed the
Russian Ministry of Defense uh has
already stated that they destroyed four
Bradleys even though they are not I mean
they may not even be in the country
but I also almost read it out as like
YouTube destroyed for Bradley's yeah
dude [ __ ] YouTube
anyway and
um
let's see
so the t7 d72b t72 B3 that's the
renovated and like the overhauled
version
t80s mtlb those are pieces of [ __ ] mtlbs
are these uh
uh essentially apcs like armored
personnel carriers It's actually an
amphibious
personal carrier and it's
and it's dog [ __ ] like this is [ __ ] bad
poop obsolete old
I mean the the only thing about it is
that it's amphibious once again and it
sometimes amphibious you know and that
it moves
but otherwise it's like it's pretty [ __ ]
yeah
I also destroyed four Bradley's uh Blue
Kirby so you know who didn't
uh
yeah and so btrd bmd2 and only every
yeah bmps are getting wrecked and bmds
so BMP bmds these are like they're like
the mtlbs that I just showed you just
like
I don't know it's uh
just like obsolete [ __ ] and but
Russia is like
mountains of this like mountains of
these old pieces of [ __ ] so they can
just bring them out but they're gonna
get worse and worse while Ukraine is
getting better and better stuff Augusta
got destroyed which is oh that's
actually a good looking vehicle
uh too bad it's used by a fascist Empire
currently engaged in a genocide
um
I mean it's such a shame but those are
those are actually pretty good vehicles
like these are the Russian Gus stickers
Ukraine already has a few
like they just
stole some
uh not stole but like took basically
uh
hello
okay The Good the YouTube chat
disappeared for a moment okay
so uh comma's Boon crane truck okay so
utility vehicles as well akatsia was
destroyed uh to Mr s's these are like of
course self-propelled guns uh the zoo
park counter better radar complex I love
that name
um
also orland is a drone also truck truck
truck so that's like a seven eight nine
ten
uh 10 trucks were destroyed
yeah so Ukraine wrecking Russia as usual
um I would say the most important from
these like what what I would look for
but what I always look for
on these lists is like it's new stuff
like t90s it's actually captured I
didn't even say that
so Ukraine has a T90 that's actually
pretty good uh t90s are not as good as
As
Abrams and stuff but like for Ukraine
it's great
um
so stuff to look for modern tanks and
trucks that's very important like if
Ukraine is wrecking a bunch of trucks
like here a third of these losses are
just trucks that's good because that's
wrecking Russian Logistics that means
ukrainians are very much active in
degrading directions and also of course
look for
helicopters planes Etc like these are
the high value targets the rest like
these bmps bmds [ __ ] mtlbs like these
are just like trash mobs essentially
um
oh we got a Super Chat uh Eric thank you
for the five Turkish lira uh hello Mr
Kovach you have a huge scale of
gradually transforming useless project
into useful ones thank you uh you might
see me must be referring to
the um
YouTube short that I put out uh yeah I
was just testing diva thank you I was
just testing the algorithm with that so
uh
yeah but it seems to be working out uh
pretty well uh one second let me I'm
gonna move OBS to the other screen just
in case it doesn't bother us
um okay and um
what else did I have
uh let's see
okay we can also go through the
institute for the study of War update on
Ukraine which is actually pretty good
like this the isw
is something you should follow and
actually
uh something else someone else you
should follow
I'm gonna give you some
uh
some pages you can follow with regards
to Ukraine or trusted pages so the isw
is one
we should follow them at the study of
War
also there's a very good account it's
ocean OS end East
like this guy is is doing it pretty
[ __ ] well and the other thing the
other
the other page I want you to subscribe
to
[Music]
uh
and the other person will subscribe
follow is uh this dude Death Moon he's
also like uh he's also very competent
and he has like some very good maps
I don't want to open these because they
usually
contain Russians dying and I don't want
my stream to be
cut but actually actually uh instead of
isw we can go through the Death Mode
updates because well perhaps both of
them
from the he has he does daily updates he
has his map actually his maps are better
than the than the live UI map so
uh
he always links them and my God like
don't don't so don't follow idiots like
that Chuck fire [ __ ] like oh God
that dude is is uh I mean it's just like
tabloid press complete head empty smooth
brain dumbass
uh
yeah oh wait actually I have two supers
uh
Darcy Stewart Russell he forgot about me
no Darcy I'd never I would never forget
about you are you kidding me thank you
for the donation I forgot about you come
on
uh Peter Lawler missed a bunch of super
chats no I didn't
um
oh yeah I did [ __ ] okay
um
oh [ __ ] super chats Jesus they're coming
in like insane
[ __ ] dude or like they did Darcy I did
not forget about you now I'm so sorry I
did not I did not see your previous just
thank you for the 799 your Australian
dollars did you see that uh
Gonzalo leader live stream that laser
Pig was on it was a disaster I have not
seen that I'm not familiar with this but
uh I am eventually it might get to me I
usually I don't I don't um
I don't uh follow drama or YouTube or
stuff like that but uh
yeah I'll check it out so
let's see uh code howler the audio is
echoing is there an echo
and I don't
um is there an echo really because on my
end super stuff like that but I'm
replaying the Stream
foreign
there is only one
audio input on my end
and it works well
uh Peter Lawler uh your super chats
congrats on 1 million mate well deserved
what's been a memorable uh what's been
what's been memorable the highlighted
and what's been a memorable challenging
creating content
um good question I'm gonna note this
down
this is for the q a
wouldn't want to
um
[Music]
let's not get stun locked too much
I'll be answering your question during
the
um
yeah cold howler sorry I had two windows
open oh yeah okay so that's why I was
echoing I was wondering so Toronto
Transit Channel what kind of tree would
you be
wow I would be
um hmm
you know what
q a section
uh let's see
okay [ __ ] I mean YouTube Super Chat is
such [ __ ]
because
like I or like I don't know is is there
like a list
a [ __ ] super chats that I can review
somewhere because otherwise it's just
like me scrolling up and down
the [ __ ]
thing
I don't know anyway
it's fine uh I'm gonna I have the I have
the chat open now yeah because if I pop
out the chat and I move it around then
the chat like [ __ ] deletes itself
like it she like wipes the previous uh
content in it and I don't I lose the
little Super Chat bubbles
due to be such [ __ ] man anyway and it's
anyway
[Music]
um
anyway
um we can we can
you know I'll keep an eye like I'll see
the colors when there's a super chat so
don't worry I won't miss anymore so the
F1 update uh let's see the January 13th
update uh
basically the um
that's the 12th update I think actually
we should look at it well it's fine so
we got a shelling map so as you can see
the fight is going on around swatovia
and here this is the solidar area here
not so much this is where we don't
expect the next big Ukrainian push
you know we'll see and hotkey is yeah I
mean Russians are just like you know
making
life worse for ukrainians because [ __ ]
you
uh wait one sec xdn says what YouTube
Studio live control room events
okay uh I mean I'm in the live control
room but like
where the [ __ ] are the events all right
one sec uh
I Got a Brand New
I'm gonna I Got a Brand New
mechanical keyboard
that's what you're hearing
um
events
um yeah um
[ __ ] dude anyway
yeah I'll figure this out later it's why
we won't need
chat anyway so Gone Big says it was one
of my mods actually thank you for the
donation and oh Adam congratulations on
hitting a million subscribers today it
is the second day of presidential
election in czechia how do you think who
do you think is the best candidate and
who uh you think will win oh yeah okay
I'm gonna I'm gonna actually answer this
now because it's interesting so today
you Czech Republic today about the Czech
Republic is having in their presidential
election the president and the Czech
Republic is more
ceremonial where the prime minister is
the is the um
is the um
leader like the defective leader of the
country and but like the president still
has influence over the country and has
to sign laws so they do have influence
like political influence and the
currently the
the uh actually do we have like a poll
of polls
on Politico for the check election yes
there we go
uh if I can
check latest balls okay so we're gonna
quickly cover this
and
the check residential election currently
the so the guy you do not want
the guy you do not want is this babish
he is
a [ __ ] crazy person
uh he's basically like a a more
calculating
check Donald Trump or he's he's a less
he's a less fundamentalist but like less
crazy version of uh what's his name Ron
descentes the the the the the the the
uh the under control Trump
and as far as I know there's others like
this heel share guys like this crazy
person I think he got like uh endorsed
by the check for right party
yesterday the the Quasi Nancy party and
we get Pavel uh I think are the two best
choices they're both I think decent
uh and yeah I think personally think
Pavel will win uh one sec just go press
it I just want a picture of barbell
presidents
he will be um butchering the declination
president volbe volbe volbear is a Volvo
is the is the is election so
anyway
um
okay here here I have a
compilation
a better one there we go so this is a
these are the people
um I'm sure I can you can put it up here
so
um this one is
and this one is Babel I think he'll win
what we'll see in the second round and
this this [ __ ] is babish he's
he's like the local Trump he's like this
big brain businessman you know got
busted on like five you find
embezzlements
etc etc uh yeah
he's like he's like reactionary and I
don't know which one of these two is I
think this might be the one that it got
endorsed by the fall right I don't know
like it's it's these two like these two
are I mean yeah nerdova had some exy
comments about like
trans people but like it's I mean it's
it's European politics so it wasn't that
bad right
I think apparently there's like chemical
castration
still in the Czech Republic of like
trans people apparently I'm not
following it I just overheard like Czech
Twitter
like the check
um
the check left this Twitter sphere
making noise about this but like
apparently
apparently uh like she was asked like
are you in favor of
are you in favor of
um
of abolishing it and and she was like
well if the law
but you know uh whatever
um but like I think bubble supposedly uh
someone can actually someone could
actually fact check me on this but like
Papa supposedly
um like was like yeah let's let's not
guess three people so you know whatever
Bubba used to be like this big NATO
General uh by the way
so let's use those are residentials uh
oh uh super chats one second uh tuxedo
football for the win since you talk you
know five euros thank you very much uh
since you talk a lot about public
transportation and housing I'm surprised
Vienna doesn't get mentioned more since
they do generally well in those yes uh
austrate strangely one of my blind spots
but I mean I you know I've been to
Vienna many times I I should actually
talk about it I do want to go to zeistot
at some point that zeistat is the
[Music]
dot
it's this brand new District being built
uh
here we go so this is Vienna's it's like
a brand new residential area mid-rise
Parks Lake new metro line actually the
metro line was built first and then the
whole thing got built around it very
pedestrian friendly whatever so it's
like this is very climate friendly Green
roofs as you can see it's very nice
uh yeah and I will I think go there and
just look around
I should also meet Kraut there because
Kraut lives in Vienna
[Music]
oh gombeek the four right is right
candidate this is the chair collection
still is bashta oh yeah okay okay okay
uh okay uh he'll share his Progressive
liberal okay that's fine
Okay so
trains rides or their trains rights both
uh thank you Alex vera for your 20 Euro
Super Chat uh
by the way can you hear me properly uh
good morning to you James uh can you
hear me properly when I turn my head
like this when I talk to the chat
trains rights or their Trends rights
both
uh yeah it should be yeah okay
anyway uh so
let's okay let's let's wrap first the
Ukraine updates up and then we can also
oh I get some other topics as well Jesus
[ __ ] Christ so
um
blah blah blah
one second the my debate partner is
messaging me
um
[Music]
yes anyway yeah I just mentioned that
like the debate is like six and a half
hours and then like the guy
wrote to me saying that you know
to check in with the time because
apparently uh it was like a different
time whatever so
um
I'll I'll ex quickly accept some DMs
message deleted why are people like I
got like three chats with like
messages okay whatever
um
so
uh okay so the laser pick drama
um
no hey whoa I've been I've been invaded
I've been I've been invaded everyone
so meet
Spud this is Spud
my favorite cat who is the
actually he's the police officer of
uh
the felines in the house
because if he sees
any other cats misbehave he just goes
there and like just like slaps the [ __ ]
out of them
is a very
fresh looking Kitty
he's a
very smart looking very well actually
like all I cuts are pretty pretty
intelligent so
yeah touch the mic do you want to stream
huh dude
all right Spud it's time for you to be
on your Merry way just don't knock
things over uh
yeah some super chats one sec they're
rolling in
I'll try to keep up um though I'm gonna
at some point I'm gonna start uh doing
some VR I will not be able to see your
Super Chips but I'm gonna scroll back
and hopefully it'll be visible so uh
queer gay as Folk 400 I believe rupees
thank you very much congratulations Adam
for reaching 1 million subs thank you
and Tommy Rigo as well uh the five
Austria Australian Austrian dollars
we're not there yet uh thank you very
much no message though
and
High Spud from Jack ninja 5 well he says
hi back
um
okay yeah we're gonna we're gonna play
Half-Life Alex on the VR and we're gonna
do a little urbanism tour in City 17 one
of our finest remaining Urban centers
um
yeah so that's okay uh we're gonna let's
let's go through this this thread
quickly and then we're gonna then I also
have like some minor cultural [ __ ]
and then we can actually start so
and we're gonna
um so this is the northern front in
Ukraine just real quick because nothing
is changing currently uh the big thing
is gonna be
uh here cremina this thing right here
this area uh ukrainians are edging
pretty close here and if they get
criminal then they can they the
ukrainians sort of cut this supply line
and Russians will be [ __ ] more [ __ ]
than usual anyway here in several times
so that's what's going on there
um the weather is going to be milder so
we will once again not see any major uh
soup movements I would say the ground
will unfreeze itself there's gonna be
rain
yeah and uh let's see
yes what is this area
this is the aftermath still of the heart
give Invasion like the hurricane counter
attack so there's not not much going on
Russians beating their heads against the
wall
uh
here as well several days
static front here ukrainians are inching
for criminal but pretty much that's it
um one sext you got two supers
the kits are going wild over here
uh so testy Trekkie come down to
Australia we need your urban planning
expertise oh uh well I'm afraid of like
yeah
I'm afraid of Austrian fauna but like
yeah I guess I can go there and like
ride spiders or something
uh yeah but thank you
for invitation any stupid chat Bob Bob
12 30 10 uh think uh thanks for all all
your vids thankful for you hydrogen
hydrogen fuel cells yes or no
um
I I'm I I'm afraid I don't know enough
about hydrogen fuel cells at present to
give you an informed answer
I'm not ready to answer that yet but
I mean it's
as long as you
uh
I mean it's better than fossil so you
know uh though I'm not I'm not that
certain if that's uh
that's such a
if that's the way forward strictly
speaking uh David espoo 10 euros think
congrats someone with a subsidely can't
stay for the whole stream but hope it
goes well well thank you and it I'm sure
it will yeah uh feel free to feel free
to come in and out whenever you want
this I'm gonna be on for the whole day
pretty much
so uh obviously like we're spanning
multiple time zones so yeah come and go
feel free and you can just rewatch the
whole thing when it's all said and done
so
let's see
no change in Soledad and back mode so
this is the hot area so this is bakmut
which Russia is trying to take
um
and uh oh Darcy Stewart Russell is back
with a 7.99 Austrian dollars Beware of
the drop spares
I am unaware of the drops bears but I
promise you I will be wary of them
and uh
uh yeah so actually here in the bakute
area like the Russians would take
Russians wouldn't to take Buck Moto
actually I'm gonna open deathman's map
over here
because it's pretty good
um it's actually it's actually some high
quality Maps so we should actually
[Music]
um
if if you see
how do you [ __ ]
uh yeah anyway so if you
[Music]
um
want to look at something then
um look at this I would say
so uh the main area as you can see like
these are offensives that are being
stopped blue little barrier means it got
stopped
um
solo there is now pretty much taken
these are approximate like these are
Kitty
it's bad I'm streaming
thank you
um so we here we have the front lines
and uh
these are all approximated based on
um
solo there is now pretty much taken
based on those are opened anyway so uh
solo that is now taken and the big prize
over here would be buckmut right here so
if Russians managed to take this city
then that would be very unepic but I
don't think they'll be able to take it
because I mean this city is now a
fortress but for
freak's sake
anyway I'll I'll just think anyway he's
he's trying to destroy the the the
curtain over there
anyway
um so if Russians take buckmut then they
would this would like as you can see
like it's pretty I think it's a small
place it's a very significant uh for
fortification for ukrainians but it's
insignificant in terms of strategy and
chromatos can slovenians would be the
prize right so the Russians are after
this
or these uh because donetsko blast is
kind of like
this so if they if they take these two
cities then they're pretty much oh
they're almost done of course a large
part of the donbass
actually not not as large I think here's
the Border somewhere
anyway but like uh slovenians would be
necessary for
for uh Russia to actually take over the
donbass or at least to have any claim of
taking it over uh Super Chat slipped me
by a testy Trekkie drop bears are a
carnivorous relative of koalas I see a
smaller but stronger General uh it
carrier but will attack humans sometimes
by dropping out of the tree hence the
name ah okay so this is the incredibly
deadly Australian fauna
yeah that's uh yeah I mean I would
expect nothing less from Australia
you know and then the drop that the drop
bear would would uh drop on you but it
gets strangled by like a 20 meter long
snake
which then gets eaten by a human-sized
tarantula
uh yeah well just Jesus thank you for
the
MX dollars what's what's that 25 but
thank you very much actually there's so
many new currencies I see
some in the YouTube chat sometimes like
when I stream that's rarely
uh
but um
I don't
don't
um it's pesos
would that be pezzo anyway but it
doesn't matter thank you
um
someone like
sends me a super and it's like XYZ
dollar I'm like uh okay thanks
um Balthazar two to eight ten twenty
dollars it's been amazing seeing your
seeing your rides ever since the wash
bump TM yeah here's 100 million subs
thank you oh yeah wash bumps me uh
a little bit well quite significantly
and then or was it before after the
Dubai video anyway I think before so I
think wash if I remember correctly bumps
me when I was like small and then the
Dubai video game is like from that point
on I just like you know shoot a shot out
uh easy man trying to check rounds
recommend you uh and chat a book how
propaganda works it's about how
demagoguery poses a threat to democracy
very relevant in modern times and will
teach you to spot and differentiate
propaganda okay
so it's the help propaganda Works book
the suggestion is
given
okay so so this to this thing I've been
going through for the last hour now
let's finish it uh shelling locations
where were we
um
here
um okay so there's nothing else
basically so this this would be the this
would be the
uh
yeah and this would be the whole
situation currently Ukrainian that much
and I think we can skip the isw because
because we are all like that uh yeah
also there was a some hullabaloo
about uh there's also Ukraine related
there is a hullabaloo because there's
the Miss Universe
uh happening in I think the US
and there was a Miss Ukraine on the Miss
Universe and she came in it's actually a
pretty nice costume like dressed as this
[ __ ] like battle Angel like it's the
it's the key of coat of arms basically
so it's like a play on that and she
looks this costume looks pretty [ __ ]
dope like this like uh
oh yeah the new Mercy skin looks pretty
dope
um but the coat of arms this refers to
is
this it's the key of coat of arms uh
yeah
as medieval drawings look super Dopey
anyway but anyway so in this so this is
like a pretty it's a pretty good costume
and but people got super [ __ ] upset
because
um
because
um
they [ __ ] they're like well by people
I mean [ __ ] tankies and these like
retards but um
but um
holy [ __ ] dude people are like huh you
create I thought Ukraine is at War who
paid for this who oh how can you afford
the costume how how do you and it's like
uh that's not how water works first off
second then there was this whole idea
that like huh actually look at it it's
you the U.S taxpayer text me you paid
for this do you consent do you consent
to paying to the to paying for the
Ukrainian Miss Universe Ladies costume
as a ux taxpayer first off you didn't
pay for it but still that's the level of
discourse now
no these [ __ ] idiots
they would they would just like latch on
to any [ __ ] opportunity to
just like you know [ __ ] talking great
stuff like that
it's pretty insane
um but I mean this is the level of
discourse like how could the Ukrainian
contestant show up in a nice costume at
the [ __ ] Miss Universe competition
when there is war in Ukraine you look
look at this costume U.S taxpayer
because you paid for it you know uh I'm
doing a filthy Frank impersonation here
holy [ __ ] yeah but like but if you look
at the other [ __ ] contestants
that the Ukrainian costume was actually
pretty [ __ ] like chill like laid back
like this was I don't know
some Brazil maybe I don't know I don't
know which countries belongs to but like
look at this like it's just costumes
like this
and um
yeah like this holy [ __ ] this looks
awesome
uh
yeah she's just she's a stand user
and this was the US this looks Dope by
the way I really like the stars but like
uh yeah and
there's some others
I hope this is Brazil and not Bitcoin oh
God
I would not think it's Bitcoin
especially now
um and you know dresses like this this
also [ __ ] dope
and by the way I'm I do keep track of
the supers they are not getting lost
don't worry I'm gonna read the material
wound
so feel free to send them this one I
think this one is my favorite holy [ __ ]
this looks awesome uh with this whole
little installation this like
uh with with this like this indigenous I
think South American maybe I I have no
idea uh but uh
with this [ __ ] like this [ __ ]
attire
uh and the pose itself too like this is
very nice and then and so
and so [ __ ]
so you have costumes like these and then
they miss Ukraine
is pretty chill it's pretty laid back
right it's pretty like you know little
tread gone [ __ ] battle Mercy right
Mercy is the OverWatch character Google
herp and um yeah so
and people are actually like [ __ ]
screeching about this uh that like ah
you're gonna how can how can you crane
afford this dress went went oh [ __ ]
War yeah meanwhile there's like other
dresses look like [ __ ] this
uh so but people were actually
screeching about this but like this is
actually when people do this when people
um try to say that like oh yeah dude how
come how come you crane does like you
can afford like nice things when there's
a war
in Ukraine like how come how come
zealands get a photo shoot in [ __ ]
where was it I don't know like the
presidential uh the Ukraine presidential
I don't know building like how come Zen
us get a photo shoot with his wife
when there's war in the country like no
that's it's uh it's it's uh [ __ ]
stupid like all these people who bring
this up they are all doing so uh those
who bring it up not those who like
regurgitate not all of them some people
are generally just like Oh I thought I
thought there was I I was just grilling
here I was in my garden I was just I was
just I just wanted to Grail and then I
saw that Ukraine did a nice thing and I
thought there was war how come you know
war is not a nice thing you know they
completely ignore me you know
disaffected I uh head empty whatever it
takes
but there are other people who are uh
actually are malicious in this in this
aspect who are like who are using every
uh who are using basically every
opportunity to attack Ukraine on
anything they can because otherwise they
don't have like they don't have like a
hold on Ukraine right if that makes
sense to you so
so
um yeah because
I mean that's that's the only thing they
can attack Ukraine on I guess
um
yes but before I uh but by the way this
this costume looks pretty [ __ ]
awesome
um and I Ukraine should only make these
from now on every Ukrainian woman should
look like this [ __ ] you so uh thank you
is there is not [ __ ] you the viewer
you're great uh some supers I missed
real quick and then I think slowly we
can move on to VR actually
uh let's see what do you think about
Doha compared to Dubai is Qatar playing
its cards better
um
yeah you know what I'm gonna uh this is
like a short answer I'm not gonna say
this for the Q a
um
cats are going wild
um Doha it's m marginally better I mean
it's there's the way as far as I know
like I have not done much research into
Doha I looked it up at one point there's
it's better than Dubai but like I mean
you were talking about like corrupt
Middle Eastern obsidious monarchies so
you know as far as that goes it's
whatever it's fine
finer
than
whatever the [ __ ] Dubai is doing so um
kitties
I'm trying to stream Jesus
let's see
livestream currency Pop Quiz Edition
congratulations well deserved in trains
are the solution well thank you and
thank you for the 50 Swedish crowns yeah
see I knew that one
uh I must have that costume yeah me too
I know right I I assume this is Jack
Ninja
uh I assume you're talking about this
but it's [ __ ] awesome dude
uh yeah did I miss anything else there I
think there's one super I missed uh [ __ ]
dude I need to figure out
I need to figure out the the like I need
to see where the where my super chats
are
uh are displayed in a list I have not
figured that out yet because I don't
stream
uh but I should get up get down to that
um let's see I think the last Super uh
yeah no that was the last one anyway so
if
[Music]
no no okay you know what one sec
[Music]
yeah I found her
there she is she's the perpetrator
that's it
you're you're done what do you have to
say for yourself huh
why are you destroying the house
she has no response
she has no response she has nothing to
say for herself
she is just
happy to be here
she's very active and she shouldn't be
well actually she should be she's a cat
um
anyway the cats yeah they they are
pretty [ __ ]
active today they keep opening my
drawers I keep running around bothering
the curtain everything uh anyway I hope
they don't uh I hope I don't like kick
them or something accidentally when
playing VR like step on them uh anyway
uh papaya Tango Tango thank you for the
uh
pln that's Polish
is it pln okay you know what I'm gonna
look up the [ __ ] currencies every
time I get a yeah that's the Polish look
uh if you'll play games please play
forts my favorite game and I wonder how
you'd uh doing this one I don't have
forts but I'm going to uh check it out
thank you
uh now now I think I'm not going to buy
and download it but
no kitty
you're out of control this is insane I'm
working
okay
so let's see uh what's your take on
lukashenko did you follow the two okay
uh Alex D thank you for the bill Russian
better version I believe uh currency
um I'm going to save your question for
the Q a and then you can re-watch it but
the Q a is going to be of course time
stamped
and uh you can re-watch it if you miss
it because it's going to come later I
think after the video at some point okay
um this [ __ ] YouTube chat dude holy
[ __ ]
um
anyway YouTube is is not making my life
easier so Jack ninja thank you once
again for the five Australian dollars
Kitty is charged with crime against the
household yes
yes
she's getting the pet penalty
I buried her
stop
come to my drawer oh my God anyway
silentism 10 R dollars
I'm now going to Google Brazilian real
okay uh thanks for the Bro the Brazilian
Reals do you agree to the claim that
hydropower isn't green because the
flooded area especially when they when
they are forests would release carbon
dioxide through the decay of organic
matter comparable to Coal plants
um I'm gonna I'm gonna answer this real
quick not through the um
not uh not the Q a I think Hydro is
better like Hydro is actually neat uh of
course regret like some in some areas uh
forests do get wiped out but like you
can just like cut down the forest
beforehand or something so it's not like
the whole thing is gonna like Decay
underwater
I should ideally cut down things and
then
yeah to get to fighting behind me uh
things now but like Hydro I'm in favor
of hydro it's it's uh I mean it's very
green it's very stable it's it's neat
um anyway
yeah the r dollars yeah anyway it's all
dollars in euros like I don't know
uh to me so uh I think we can actually
I'm gonna close these
and
I think you can transition into the VR
uh
Parts we're gonna look around in
Half-Life Alex and for that I'm going to
uh let's I'm going to have to test
things out a bit everything should be
set up uh correctly
[Music]
so I got my controls I have a valve
index so it should be so uh one second
I'm gonna set up the VR
I'm going to
uh let's see
I'm going to be playing like there oh hi
Kitty
and um
okay
so give me a moment
I'm going to be talking to you through
the VR headset so I'm going to bring it
over here and then we should be able to
hear each other through that
you cannot hear me through the VR yet
right
I don't know why
uh let's see
I'm going to set it up
let's see
it should should be working though I
don't know uh [ __ ] dude
okay this this might need some
foreign
to the audio as well right okay I muted
it
dude life is hard uh
life is very very hard
uh when it comes to VR playing yesterday
I [ __ ] tested it and it worked today
now it doesn't want to we'll just give
me a second I'll figure it out okay
oh two supers I'm gonna quickly read
these out Lucas Nunes 10 euros hey Adam
you're one of my favorite YouTubers
thank you this is uh just a small token
of my appreciation but for all the great
content you bring thanks oh thank you
for the donation I'm glad you like my
stuff uh
hi Adam uh 10 US Dollars hi Adam if you
don't get on a train in this VR you'll
regret it well you just wait I just need
to figure out
uh how to or maybe I'm gonna set maybe
I'm gonna set my microphone to like to
like uh
long range that's style like a
sub-optimal solution but like hey uh
that's what we have to work with and
that's what we have to work with you
know
um
but like [ __ ] man anyway uh one sec I
need to oh bring it over here so I got
like the VR
uh I'm just gonna remove it
re-edit so it's an audio input capture
uh
it's a VR and then the digital audio
interface valve
hmd mic
and it's at last time like when I did
this it worked actually so you know
um
yeah so anyway if it if it doesn't want
to work then
there's another one it's just this
anyway if it doesn't want to um
if it no I don't want to insert [ __ ]
ads thank you YouTube
um if it's if it doesn't want to work
I'm just gonna like move my mic
microphone a bit because I'm going to be
playing right next to it anyway and
we're gonna do the good old
um
we're gonna do the good old uh
the classic
when I talk into the microphone instead
of the VR
um or wait maybe this um
do we have to set the [ __ ] thing on
the
do they have to set the thing
let's see microphone access microphone
access is on
okay
um
and yeah [ __ ] OBS anyone anyway
um
Let's uh let's check something okay
but it actually just as a precaution I'm
going to move the mic stand
so that if the VR really doesn't want to
cooperate then I'm just going to have
the microphone right there anyway so
that we can hear each other
one second I'm gonna mute it so you
don't go deaf
and actually I need to untangle some
wires in the back one second technical
difficulties
okay this everything was super Dusty
back there but okay it's uh
rip
it's just
the bottom part of the microphone that
you attached to the
the bottom part of the microwave
attached to the table
just a sec
and
[Music]
okay he's gonna
slap it in
[Music]
I hope you didn't go deaf from that
um
okay
it's a
it's a
desperate solution but
hey I mean
I'm gonna mute it again so you don't get
bothered too much
okay the mic is now the mic is now
stabilized so it should be okay we
should be fine
um okay so uh so hang bear with me for a
moment I'm gonna start uh I'll try to
I'll try to do the um try to set up the
VR if nothing else we're gonna just like
you know
um
if nothing else you're gonna just like
listen to me through the microphone
right
so one moment
if you should still be able to hear me
and
I'm gonna just like uh
move the mic here oh my God kitties
[ __ ] up there one second
they've spread some soil there on the
floor
they dug out one of my plants
great timing
okay
so uh how well
Let's test some settings okay
um
actually no I should Google
I should Google the mic the yeti mic
settings
and
let's see
because I don't think we're getting the
[ __ ] VR
uh
microphone
so we have
omnidirectional
so this
so now it should okay so when I so when
I talk like this how well wait one
second I'm going to talk like this and
then I'm gonna listen to it on stream
and see how well it's Audible
so there's no there's no sound
can you not hear me right now
okay is there
okay so can you okay okay it's good okay
because like if I replay the Stream
on YouTube it's muted anyway it's it's
uh
oh yeah oh wait yeah I'm an idiot yeah
I'm sorry yeah I'm sorry this is like
this is like morning brain yeah the VR
headset is the output now so I'm not
hearing anything I'm hearing I should be
hearing my voice through the
through the VR mic
oh my [ __ ] God okay
so one sec
that's what you do only directional and
I'm gonna turn
the camera around yeah this is the mic
stand over here
rip VR mic
I'm such a boomer dude uh right
and we're ready for our adventure
foreign
wow
okay
one sec
so the problem currently is that the VR
headset is having this artifact thing
I've no [ __ ] idea what's going on now
but uh I'm gonna re-plug it hopefully it
doesn't crash the stream one sec
okay it was a connection error
okay uh so I'm gonna do a test
so
so can you hear me now properly let me
know now please
there's the floor
so guys can you hear me now
uh let me know in the chat
is the audio fine
do I look alright
I mean obviously I do
stand like this
is that fine
let me get some feedback
I go
okay now the echo is gone right
so yeah okay because the VR okay the
[ __ ] VR mic did not activate uh on
its own so now you should be hearing me
properly no Echo
is that correct
there's still echo oh [ __ ]
okay so it's so it's all good now good
all right so
and I mean I'm framed purple no I'm not
framed properly
all right and I'm gonna shrink myself
there we go
actually can you see here you should be
able to see
okay
so I'm framed properly
like this
all right people let's
then start an adventure let's start our
urbanism Adventure
starting your game uh
from
entanglement we're going to do normal
difficulty
developer commentary of weapon hand
right movement blink yeah
yes
so I'm excited to do an urban planning
trip of City 17.
while we're loading I'm also going to
check on the chat guys if something
doesn't work let me know
okay but everybody okay so everything is
I'm not in the center of the shot though
uh
maybe like this
yeah the cat house is also in the way a
bit
I moved it here
okay so now it should be better
yeah let's let's not miss the game
that's me
that's me
I'm on reconnaissance I'm a 19 year old
female
that's a good looking city right here
actually I should
before we continue on I'm going to
decrease the volume
there we go Combat music
wouldn't you wouldn't want to like yell
over the game there you go
so wow what a what a nice city and what
a nice Tower by hour
benefactors
that he was such a [ __ ] trip when I
first played Half-Life Alex because uh
because uh I played Half-Life 2 and I
and I'm really fond of it right and then
to see like the whole world in 3D in VR
it was actually quite
thrilling okay for before we continue
I'm gonna do a quick chat checkup
uh with VR by the way my
you don't hear the game at all so no
sound in the game I'm gonna [ __ ] kill
myself one second
I'm sorry I'm sorry for swearing but
this is
oh yeah because the desktop audio is off
Okay so
so which desktop audio
hmm
is there something here like if I
uh no this is not the correct desktop
audio
okay now
yes cursor I know
okay so now
I want to do another chat checkup
so now you're hearing the game
listen to it a bit
there is desktop audio currently
is that correct so can you hear the game
still no sound
come in come in hello
no sound
foreign
because I have two uh ads
this I'm currently on index hmd2n video
okay now you should be able to hear it
okay now uh
technical difficulties
so now you hear stuff right yes good
okay so the problem
the problem was that the
the VMware output also needs to be
Injustice the VR output also the VR
output sound it's not doesn't go through
desktop it also needs to go through OBS
like separately anyway now it's all
solved now we're in the game
you can hear it I'm actually going to up
the volume for you a bit so you will not
Master right on 50th should be fine
anyway and if this if the stream crashes
uh yeah word of advice only do VR
streams with like an assistant okay
because
uh
so here we see a very nice and
obviously walkable City there is a
car down there two cars three four but
well see there's no
yeah the parking spaces are actually uh
like the the space management is
actually quite Fair it seems also it
helps that the cars themselves like
human society has pretty much collapsed
already and so cars cannot be maintained
because there's no supply chain to
maintain them
oh there's a site hey not just bikes
what's up
hey Jason
Emoji no stop
anyway
um
okay so and there's no issues so far Etc
okay good I'm just gonna check the chat
if something crashes you know I'm in VR
I cannot see it uh
oh this is fun
wait see if I can find it
one sec
yes
anyway this is this is the mysterious
soundtrack from Half-Life 2 in the
street battle uh section you actually
can listen to it and it's here on this
on this radio
we have
oh we have some social programs going on
gelatinated calorie paste egg flavor hmm
we get some
Koga
and uh wait still not I'm still not
satisfied
uh
at all the all the other volumes need to
go up to the maximum
and the master volume like this
so we can hear stuff better
hey is this creepy ass music is playing
and here's a bottle of beer
so good I like VR Tech
and you can we
yeah
everything you can everything can be
touched the texture is actually very
very high as
this however cannot be sprayed
I'm afraid all right let's move on as
you can see it's a very nice and
walkable City it is under occupation by
an extraterrestrial Force so
is in the process of genociding the
natives humans
though it's like a small like a calm
genocide oh hey Jason you're back not
just bikes over there and yeah but like
if you ask tankies actually
about what's happening here it's it's
just like you know Earth was full of
like Nazis or something and this is like
a peace operation humans should just
like you know give up uh yes and this is
you can see a a
in the back
like a Soviet apartment building because
we are in the baltics so this is
actually Eastern Europe
so you can see like uh
you know there's like this central
European uh
central European um
uh building style I guess
hell yeah
oh hey pigeon
all right before we take this call
okay
no complaints so far uh so let's go
let's take this phone call
Alex
oh hey Eli it's good
it's Goodman is normal same for the
combine Patrols how's it going in the
stockyard
welcome
they're never gonna miss it
yourself
don't get greedy guys we're not made of
time here one minute and I'm out
guaranteed
oh also as part of the combine moving
supplies into the quarantine Zone that
place has been deserted for years hmm
that is all it's very odd what what well
we'll look into it when we get back
get back out to Safe House baby we'll be
there soon it looks like what is it
Russell would you
terrific rip am I centered up for the
battery and the camera
take a quick look yeah it's it looks
good but anyway I I shouldn't be
shouldn't yell on VR because like the
mic is actually quite sensitive so you
guys all can hear me all right let's
begin our wonderful Journey
these textures man
it's a little Greenhouse that we're in
currently
oh I
I should get my should bring my coffee
with me I guess
um
yeah
this like Half-Life Alex is actually the
future of
so far anyway the future of VR games
because
I mean just look at it right
other VR games
yes yes I know
other VR games uh do not come close to
this Fidelity and if you use the valve
index actually the the headset
I mean you can of course play Half-Life
Alex with other VR sets but this this is
Peak we are this is absolutely
um
like like look at this like you can even
see the the dirt and everything on the
on the grease on the mug
uh yeah
anyway
um
with Jesus okay didn't mean to break
that word
okay I didn't I didn't realize you could
oops okay so before I've destroyed the
whole area
um
just look at these plugs as well so
these are actually European Standard
plugs it seems though they're of course
they're older
yeah hmm
anyway there will be trains though I
really deeply appreciate that
[Music]
foreign I'm trying to move my head in a
way that you guys don't get nauseous
because
in this
because in the game like basically with
VR I am your camera
so I don't want to like you know spaz
out
yeah
yeah but just this is this is actually
very very
nice I wish I wish we had like Half-Life
2 for a VR if valve remade it if they're
not making count five three anyway
well then you know whatever [ __ ] him no
no actually no no don't don't [ __ ] them
they're great company I really like them
so
oh yes and here is a little biter you
can actually use these in Half-Life one
and in Black Mesa as a
coffee
uh
it's too blurry
I'm sick
I cannot really oh sort I see uh
Vichy sort
oops
there we go here we go
there we go kitty
well isn't this fun
Zen life forms there's a chart of a
serial being built of the Citadel that
is if I said a cereal
and look at the carpet
this is so nice
like this it's so good looking in terms
of texture
anyway before I get to get it away
when I first played three Half-Life Alex
I
I thought I had to do something with
this camera but actually no
or we get a fedrus pro AHS
but it's empty hmm
VHS tapes we deserve to be we deserved
to be invaded and just this attic area
like you can spend half an hour in each
area in VR and just
be just just be looking around
let's
proceed with our journey
beautiful elevator actually one of my
relatives
lives in Budapest their house has an
elevator like this like very similar to
this it's super fun
yeah just just don't play VR with like
continuous movement because you're gonna
you're gonna throw up
hey
good yeah they got there yeah I'm over 1
million subscribers
[Music]
yeah so it's pretty much uh so for those
of you don't know of course like Earth
is under like military occupation these
are humans
in the in the uh
suits I guess but essentially they're
well the colloquial term used in
Half-Life is that their brains are
sucked out or like they don't remember
anything who they were Etc they get
assimilated
uh
break chant check
also I was I was actually not facing you
guys
um
I'm playing Half-Life Alex okay
um
oh good so no campaigns I take it as
I take it as
everything is working fine
combine for safety oh yeah it's the
combine
the or so they call themselves
we get a missing cat
likes chasing bugs like eating bugs
doesn't answer your name we found return
to Sarah
please maybe you should
spend more time worrying about all the
missing people yes I love these little
World building bits
hmm and you can
hmm
what should I what should I
okay you know what if someone if someone
sends in a super chat in the next 30
seconds I'm going to write it here on
the on the window with this you can you
can
you can write stuff
you got you got 30 seconds if no one
sends in anything
I'm going to just leave the area but
if the timer go Starts Now
in the meantime I'm gonna
in after 30 seconds I'm just going to
look around like a look at the super
[ __ ] look at the chat if there's a super
and in the meantime just gonna look
around here oh my God look at this
texture
just look at this like this this
it's so real
so realistic I I've played through Alex
two times already I can not get enough
of this here
rebar concrete visible
this looks awesome
and yeah
you can actually start the washing
machines
well this is not safe
let's
test the physics a bit
yeah I like the source engine
so is there super
yeah a whole bunch of supers Jesus
Christ okay uh
guys you're giving me too much to write
Daisy was here Winer I guess you
Super Chat
desk guys it's it's okay [ __ ] dude I had
no idea it would get this
okay
I'm going to write one thing because
then we're gonna be here for like
for like an hour okay
okay two things
let's see what was the one
Daisy was here
it's here
and the other one I'm gonna write is
I
love
Elon
musk hell yeah
this is this is a truly dystopian world
thank you for your contributions
uh wait let me just reorient myself
actually I should yeah so I'm facing the
camera
thank you for all the supers
okay I was expecting like you know one
person to
I was expecting like you know one person
to to send the super and instead I got
flooded
I tried to keep my position
what is it
Yeah I broke 1 million yeah
[ __ ]
so anyway the combine seems to be pretty
agitated then I have reached 1 million
subscribers
hmm
damn dude
yeah one thing about Half-Life and the
half-life Universe was that um
was that like the reason why it was so
groundbreaking Half-Life one a nice Bike
by the way is that is that uh when you
walked through the maps in Half-Life the
the
um
the world around you was dynamic in the
sense that stuff happened around you and
you could just like you could just like
observe from your perspective or not or
you can just move on but uh the whole
idea was that uh
wow I haven't even noticed this
hey
holy [ __ ] it's so good
um
that like we you walk around and you can
you can you can just like observe the
world around you and the world does
things on its own so things are
happening and because previously like
before Half-Life one
you know in games like quake and doom
and whatever it was just like here's
here's a big complex level there's a
bunch of monsters Go and Kill uh and
also also of course uh
what also helped
was that uh like Half-Life when I had an
actual story because I mean if you play
Doom
the game like Doom one like what's the
story boo the demons are coming and now
you're gonna kill them okay
um
and half iPhone actually had like a
coherent complex story which is
interesting to this day like it's I mean
it's a story it's like a regular-ass
good story
uh second uh uh
oh yeah it's the same in Russian yeah
zakrito
is closed
yeah well people were having some
fun over here I guess
and what I really really appreciate is
that if you listen
the advisor voice in the back dislike
female voice this echoing like attention
prediction team this is the exact same
from half-life 2.
so what I really don't like is when
games you know the new game comes out
and it then they get like remade and
like uh the sound design gets redone and
then suddenly you know the voices you're
used to and these sound effects are like
now different but everyone acts like
they're the same and here they're
actually very consistent with that so
but here we have a very historical it
appears like 19th century maybe 20th
century
um
little back alley neighborhood it's very
walkable there's no cars here except for
that one
there is one parking spot the spaces are
obviously there's bollards
um and the spaces are very well
delineated this is a very
this is a very
um
human-centric area
now I know you cannot ride a bicycle
here because I tried
but otherwise as you can see
the bicycle actually works
and you can you can pedal
though
there's no chain on it which is a shame
hey not just bikes yeah what do you
think of my ride
so whoop no no no anyway is there like a
yeah okay so I have to give some minus
points to this area because there's no
like I cannot put my bicycle anywhere
um
I'm just gonna blink here okay so I'm I
guess I'm just gonna use this place
as my bike rack for my
obviously Dutch bicycle it's it's orange
can I actually okay yes
oh my God
uh it's so nice and you can actually
we whoa
wait does it move or did I just move did
I just drag it no no I just dragged it
with my hand okay so I have to give some
this is a very nice walkable area but I
have to give it some minus points
because
um well lack of bike parking I mean come
on guys it's it should be at least two
thousand
twenty oh okay kitty kitty kitty I
haven't even noticed that and the lady
sitting up there
see oh my God if you stick around
Half-Life Alexa this is this is all new
to me
uh not have five Felix but the things
that are happening around us this is all
new
oh my God
if you stand around in an area
and look
you can see so many new things
because it's just like really well done
yeah there she is with the pigeons there
and with these alien sounds in the back
Citadel up there
so nice
one moment chat check
if everything is going well
okay no complaints
oh I had a very cursed idea by the way I
am
I'm ashamed to admit but I had an idea
of what if
what if you went through
what if you played
Half-Life Alex
role playing
as John Arbuckle
from Garfield
yeah see there's the Garfield Glock
just
go through the game
role playing against John Arbuckle and
like record yourself wow Garfield
Garfield
Garfield the combine got OD we gotta get
him out
anyway
I'm I'm entertaining myself
and Dropship
and it was carrying
it was indeed carrying the battery
that
Alex's father just talked about
from this vantage point though we can
actually observe the cityscape a little
bit
so this is the old town obviously so
this is over of course we are in the old
town do check out the roofs very nicely
detailed uh this sea this city seems to
have gotten City 17 seems there seems to
have gotten the same treatment as many
Eastern block cities
um
so Soviets apartment blocks and
Department residential complexes were
built into the city fabric
and
yeah like without much regard for the
for the original like the natural City
uh cityscape and the city fabric uh
which is unfortunate but I mean hey
that's that's uh
that's uh the situation but on the top
side the the the apartments have
produced a lot of uh affordable housing
uh for a lot of people who would
otherwise be relegated to sort of uh
comfortless homes or essentially or
especially Shanty towns like one of one
of the like major Comic block complexes
outside Budapest for example there used
to be like a Big Shanty Town
um
in its place so people can say oh you
know they look ugly and whatever but
yeah dude [ __ ]
looks worse
can I can I actually take a look at the
street there
Tangled Up In The Wire
no I'm not tall enough dude if only I
was like five meters tall I would I
would be able to see it
okay let's go through
into the elevator
let's get elevated
oops
oops wait wait I just I just lit here
wait wait wait don't shoot
anyone
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I think if you don't put your hands up
there they're going to actually shoot
you
like I wouldn't put it past the valve I
could always put my hands off so I can
progress with the story
[Music]
time to get entangled
where are you taking me
where's my father
hello
I'm not where's my
brother tell her to stop moving around
back there
I'm not going to make a an American
police joke oops
rip
[Music]
hmm
yeah smoke it
well
they tried
hello hello
good day
sir
hello
oops
Alex you're there you've got to get
moving Russell I've been in an accident
I know I caused him so technically not
an accident you've got to get moving
wait wait where's Dad he's fine follow
the Drone there's two people looking at
you even in the back super nice
yeah
so that's okay sit it all in front of
you
oh drip
me well yes I had no way of knowing who
was in which fan so yes the result was
that I saved you do we know where
they're taking him criminal holding
and
over Prospect but I'm already working on
a plan to get him back you're close to
my lab keep following the Drone we'll
figure out what to do obviously it's to
believe this economy work as well yeah
uh
let's move I guess oh no
oh no
no
what happens here it's a tragedy ooh can
we actually reassemble the bike
it would be unbelievable if we could
so
no no no unfortunately the hitbox that
like the model
the model physics box doesn't
let you slide it in there's like there's
like this big block mesh wise oh well I
was going to leave it here so that the
owner can
hmm
oh there's nothing here
oh two Choppers
these [ __ ] Hunter Choppers are such a
pain in the ass
well thankfully you're not you're not
going to find one in Alex
hey just look at this is Persona so nice
Birds Choppers
genocidal Empire
comic blocks this is a tanky's paradise
dude
and whatever it is they're gonna kill
anybody who sword and anybody who knows
anybody who saw it
us and your dad Russell just hang on I'm
almost there
yeah so
oops
ah
discussion
like these little trucks they weren't in
half-life 2.
yeah so yeah but just actually I think
funny observation I just made that uh
yeah this is a tanki's paradise this
game you know you're an Easter block
Eastern Bloc comic blocks and there's a
and there's a big
you know fascist Empire or genocide in
the natives so I mean this is what they
like obviously oh hey lady or person
what are you oh hey dude
onlookers
it's very Dynamic oh it's a
it's a
Marvel of engineering this one
are you experiencing like texture
tearing by the way because I'm I am a
bit
it doesn't matter
yeah I think I think I don't know
the VR never does this one like it's
normally around maybe it's like obser
whatever we'll survive
uh let me reorient myself so that you
can see me
yeah but this is actually a very nice
little pocket park well too bad with the
whole you know wire thing rammed through
it
but uh otherwise this is very nice
um
clearly this is this was built
respecting the original
uh City structure and even though oh we
have a bull art here but I I don't think
this is movable no it's static
but this for example is
is interactable we
yeah okay the physics engine is smart
enough
can you can climb on the slide
yes
wow that was incredible uh
and here next to us there's this teeny
tiny Road see these little narrow roads
actually slow traffic down significantly
Japan has these so this is why in Japan
you don't see as many bike lanes because
well why would you right because states
are so narrow to begin with that cars do
not speed and mixed traffic can safely
commits
oh hello
[Music]
sure yeah I'll be there in a minute
wow hello okay
oh a bus stop
well it should be pretty difficult to
navigate here at the bus so I suppose
this was a minibus service there's many
in many places in Eastern Europe uh like
the let's developed Eastern Europe
anyway oh yeah and uh there's even I
think an overpass there some Tower
houses though this this area seems to be
yes very much
uh this area was built irrespective of
the
original
cityscape
um
yeah well
God it looks nice
yeah so it's time to progress with the
plot
hello
God the texture is so nice
please stand by
this room
so nicely done
actually let's sit down
right
you need to physically sit down
oops
wow I'm a
I'm a tall sitter
let me re-center myself so you can see
me
okay
actually I'm gonna be commenting
commenting a bit less now because I need
to save my voice I'm gonna be on for the
whole day okay let's wait
wait
Russell
they've got Dad I know
this this is bad you're gonna find out
what he knows and then yeah they're
gonna kill him oh God
but the good news is we've got something
they don't which is my plan to give them
back great let's hear it now pretty soon
they're going to realize that your dad
is not going to talk and when that
happens it's off to have his brain
sucked out rather potentially maybe not
though I mean they could just I don't
know if you can hear it but cats are
screaming right well what they will do
is take them by train from here okay
wait
I want you to witness this
what I have to deal with
there's a there's a Mortal Combat
ongoing behind me
well not now because now I'm paying
attention to them
anyway
like this
and
when I'm sorry can we not have the yes
and also a chat checkup I want to check
up on you guys how is everyone doing
yeah
those those kitties those
little Goobers
you know
all right
we can continue
to turn the camera a bit more okay
uh still I'm still not centered
Okay so
ready to roll out
this is Eli to Nova proceed and if he
gets on that train hell yeah right you
should not necessarily grab something
okay that's you I thought you said us
well one of us me will have to stay here
for this plan to work all right fair
enough just outside there's a second
train that also leads out of City 17
through the quarantine Zone okay both
trains intersect here at Fairview
Junction you take your train get there
before his train and hack into the
controls that'll let me take over the
system train comes to a halt you deal
with the combine situation and we'll get
your dad back sounds good where's the
train I'm teaching hell yeah out the
back through the yard it's
decommissioned but I think I can hack
into its controls
oh and get yourself a pair of rustles on
the way out
wrestles the gloves Alex you know the
gravity gloves I have a few sets through
there you can calibrate them out by the
shed got it we can do this Alex
oh we also have the streamer lights that
we could do it because we're gonna do it
and oh yeah you can actually follow the
VR feed
there so if I was like a re if I wanted
to be like a dick to you guys
I would
just like set up the
hmm I mean I wish there was a way to I
wish there was a way to set up like a
H never mind it would be too complicated
to for you to follow the and it's not
even possible but anyway let's forget
what I said
um
what's in the fridge
ooh some wine
and a head crab
yeah forget the wine
I'm having the head crab
have crabs or
well for those of you who are not
familiar with half-life
head crabs are a little parasitic
beings I guess from
this area called Zen
and they
get on your head
they crawl on your head they take
control of your nervous system and they
start mutating you all the while they're
still alive
so when you're fighting zombies with the
headcrabs you have to shoot down the
headcrabs and then the person is dead
but while they are zombified they will
be charging at you still screaming for
help which is quite the experience
let's get some gloves going
hell yeah
well let's go
I like the color
there's no texture tearing anymore
that's good
all right you know how this goes there
should be a bunch of junk down there aim
at something with your hand open
excellent now make a set you're on it
great try again
just like that one more time
registered now flick your wrist to bring
it in just like that
perfect we're done oh oh wait I almost
forgot Alex up here I'm gonna need a gun
don't worry it's unloaded
it's unloaded now thank you
here you go
there you go
uh now we're ready to do some damage
to any and all who deserve it actually
there should be another clip here
somewhere now
because I believe I'm playing on a hard
so I will need the ammo anyway it
doesn't matter
let's
roll oh
look at this
look at this these are
soviet-era commuter trains
I've seen the front of these trains I
mean they're somewhat accurate model of
it but yeah these are like uh Soviet era
either ER 2 er9
stuff like that I don't I don't remember
the what the D solver I end is like
these are funny thing is like what I
think valve
screwed up I mean not to get like too
autistic over here but like
um
well they actually um
missed is that this this is all like
electrified right like this is like DC
electrified
at least I assume
um lines and
and they have diesels running around
still like the models of diesel though I
mean okay to be fair it's entirely
possible that in the ensuing well
apocalypse
uh in the meantime you know the
electrical grid collapsed and they just
put in some diesel trains instead of uh
instead of electric ones on the network
oh well
so let's see
um yeah I I don't I'm not familiar with
these specific like these uh markings
Riv hmm
anyway but but these are these are the
couplers like these are the Soviet
couplers
which rails
yeah at some point we'll even be able to
enter
all right
Alex
goodbye
obviously just to let you know I am
still here though I know
let me reorient myself
yes this is a very nice 3D map over here
ambulance passing
Hello Alex we might have a problem
probably nothing to worry about but
did the train stop
didn't it yeah what happened
I am when the combine shut down the
quarantine Zone they must have tightened
security which means yeah you're nowhere
near Fairview Junction you're just
outside the qz and this is as far as we
get by train
good I'll see if I can get you in some
other way Gabe Newell why have you
forsaken me
I asked the quarantine Zone
yeah dead zone yes I thought the
combines filled up with Q Z just what I
wanted to say
then I doubt it oh CE wow okay so this
is
um
this means that this area so we are in
the 90s
um actually I someone can actually look
this up like when did we get like when
did
when did countries oh yeah it's a dead
zombie by the way but once I just forget
about them for a moment so CE means that
the that the the the country is part of
the the European Industrial
I guess
custom zone or like this the industrial
Visa means that like the industrial
goods can are certified etc etc and uh
well this zombie is certainly not
certified but this means that um
yeah we're following a pretty um
consistent timeline here so
the European economic area did
really happen in this world Etc so this
is like our world pretty much until the
late 90s early 2000s yes and this by the
way while read it
for those of you don't know this is a
zombie or what's left of it anyway
so when the headcrab couples with your
head
what happens is
it's sort of
gets on your head maybe I can see some
color marks but not on this model I
guess yeah their face basically melted
but like the head crab kind of
couples on to your head like this
and it spreads some sort of like mutagen
through your body which causes
an elongation
in limbs
so your limbs turn into claws and your
bones basically start growing and you
also become
actually quite powerful and of course
the
of course the chest is ripped open I
somehow the healthcare feeds through
there so they're a rip up on your own
chest and you also
and so when zombies feed they like start
like
feeding stuff into that hole and somehow
I mean I guess through those mutagen
substances they had crab actually pumps
that up to itself though I don't know
how I don't know how this how the Zombie
World building will continue
uh head cramps like zombie-wise because
in opposing in opposing Force
which is a game there is no remake
Fourier opposing force was one of the
expansions for Half-Life one in opposing
Force there are zombies where they had
where the zombie is much more massive
much faster and much stronger but the
head crab is smaller so they had to grab
you sort of mutating into their body so
I don't know I've not seen
ah would you look at that prison and if
there's resin around here it should be a
combined fabricator keep an eye out we
might be able to upgrade your Firepower
a bit so basically uh
let's zero this lock
I don't know if it's oh hell rat I don't
know if it's Cannon though
the fact that zombies mutate
oh you're right
but like one thing I oh it noticed me
one thing I appreciate is that um
like in the half-life universe
in the half-life Universe
um Canon is not
so it's valid at the same time and not
so strictly adhered to at the same time
that makes sense so black Mesa for
example the half-life one remake uh
remade I think I can reroute this with
my multi-tool
it's a tool with multiple functions so
you know multi-tool
who am I going to sell it
online's not going to be here forever
you should be thinking about the future
Alex well how about I call it the Alex
yeah
there we go
so what I what was I what I was saying
before my character interrupted me I'm
after Gordon Freeman I'm still not used
to this but still
um
what I like about the half-life universe
is that oh by the way the stream still
on is everything okay
on a sec
yeah okay
no complaints people are still
yeah yeah okay so
um
the thing is what I really appreciate
look at these pipes by the way so nice
what I appreciate about half-life uh the
universe like how it's written
is because
um
is that
um
Kitty I I can hear a kiss go crazy
anyway so what I appreciate about the
half-life universe is that uh Canon
as in can the story Canon like you know
what what belongs to the universe what
doesn't Etc
it doesn't
um
it doesn't ruin the story
Alex
the barnacles
how nice they're so much better than
anything in Half-Life 2 by the way
um so basically when black Mesa came out
which is a half-life one fan remake
yeah it's a half-life one fan remake but
like very very competent like it's
that's that's that's that's actually
sold on Steam and I believe valve
actually signed off on that at like it's
[ __ ] awesome
is that right yeah well no
I interviewed a black Mesa they said try
again in a year
I don't need to tell you what happened
after that lucky break for me really
honestly it's a miracle you and your dad
got out of it
yeah so speak of the devil like me sir
um
yeah so it it [ __ ] you
so anyway uh black Mesa was a game
it was a game
black Mesa was a game as I said
oh more nice
um
and it was a PC game
oh hi
yeah well
you know
uh
actually with these models you can see
the little ingressions the headcrab
makes
her little uh the little
thingies like the little poles so it
like latches on onto you like this
around your face and just like whoop
yeah
anyway so um
so in Black me so they they added lots
of new little bits to the story right
like oh there's there's this little
event like there's an extra right here
there's that little event Etc oh and uh
the half-life Universe yo more
the NFL Universe can actually even more
can actually integrate
these into itself so there's no
contradictions
uh there are no plot holes
oh the toilet obviously
no
no items just looking res
yes
um so anyway
um
the I think the valve lead starter
writer said he doesn't believe in Canon
which I think is good
as the quarantine Zone entrance uh
because the game will not contradict
itself so that there won't be like these
like fan remakes where whatever there
won't be these like
[Music]
fan remakes where the where they make
where they do or say something that
contradicts the lore Etc
because I think intentionally like fans
complain about this that have like in
Half-Life you know
come out oh get out of there
ah
come on come on you've been hanging out
enough
so uh fans complain that like oh you
know there's not much we know about the
half-life Universe yeah that's by Design
somewhat
because
um
they don't want to tell you too much how
do I [ __ ] jump up there ah like this
because if they do then then they you
and arrive at like contradictions like
oh you know well you know we know this
about the universe well then the other
thing happened how come and by keeping
things a bit more vague
they actually
um
they actually leave lots of creative
space for creators for example like a
black Mesa
um
my HP is still full
and um
but this also leads to lots of like
stupid stupid stuff right
it's a nice little puzzle
this list also it's like stupid stuff
like the fan theories I've read about
like
now that I'm walking into the quarantine
Zone it just hit me
I don't know anything about the
quarantine Zone
from the Italian
day period that all ships were required
to be isolated before crew could go
ashore during the Black Death all right
cool
that's the control panel they've
probably scrambled the circus
considering no one would be dumb enough
to open the hatch it should be hard to
put back I just hit the mic
the problem is the guy the game is too
immersive so you keep bumping into
things because you think you're actually
there anyway
oh no Jerry
Stuart is that you
anyway
um
so
it's still alive even
and if you decrease the current
yeah it stops
but if you increase it
the level of detail is phenomenal
okay
nice
real infrastructure
have they started moving Dad yet I don't
think so which is good news because
we've still got time
it's great all bad news because I've
already killed them and you don't need
to move you just bury it
so are you seeing this wow
yeah so this is the biosphere from Zen
the Border world
which people at black Mesa discovered
spoilers by the way
anyway so it looks so nice so uh um
I've heard so many idiotic Half-Life fan
theories it's actually embarrassing
and it's like
so many I would say 90 of these like
Half-Life and universe fan theories can
be explained with like
you know like hmm why does this happen
you know why this why did this character
this what is did that character do that
you know and um
uh basically it can be explained with
like
valve has not figured it out yet so
you're like oh how come how come this
character had this object there it's
like I don't know valve doesn't know
either and as they go on with the story
as they create more uh Half-Life games
hopefully I mean they've created Alex
as they create more Half-Life games as
time goes on
hopefully they're going to uh
fill in the blanks right
so it's like it's kind of like in Star
Wars right how um
you know the Clone Wars people act like
the Clone Wars has always been this like
[ __ ] staple of the universe no no
like in the first ever Star Wars movie
when Luke meets Obi-Wan
uh
hey Russell I just found a loose syringe
of God knows what is this medicine
doesn't have a skull on crossbones on it
I don't see one
probably medicine do you hear that
oh yes a zombie
oh boy
yeah that's
that's the way we gotta go no shortcut
yeah
okay hello Mr Barnacle care to help me
yeah this is a zombie by the way for
those of you who are not familiar
yeah it's a
foreign
either or two as well
I'm getting hungry so you know that's
why my speech impediment is increasing
hell yeah let's roll come with me come
at me
top G top G
ceiling G
um
oops maybe for it
nom nom
you
okay
so anyway
what was I saying I talked I was talking
about like half-life
story no Star Wars yes
[ __ ] they keep interrupting me I miss
Half-Life too
thanks so uh in in Star Wars you know
people act like you know oh you know the
the cologne Wars it was all ah yes it
was always a plan to it was like George
Lucas's master plan and it's like no
George Lucas had no [ __ ] idea what he
wants to do with the Star Wars Universe
like the first Star Wars was such a
[ __ ] slog and not not the one that we
got released but the original right uh
before being cut into what we know as
the original for Star Wars
it used to be I've read a just like this
unwatchable bloated mess and then
someone came and cut it properly and
that became the first ever Star Wars the
original Star Wars and um
and that's how uh that began the Star
Wars craze
uh I'm just gonna skip these
rip
but like in the first Star Wars
they say when Luke meets Obi-Wan I'm
finally getting there you know
um
Obi-Wan mentions that he knows Anakin
from the Clone Wars yeah
yeah oh it's a station nice uh the
ridership seems low
and not quite
you know self-actualized anyway
um Obi-Wan says
with your father in The Clone Wars you
know and people act like oh you have to
call yes George Lucas had a plan no no
he [ __ ] didn't Clone Wars if you look
at the science fiction culture of the
era it's gonna be very very obvious that
uh
oops it's gonna be very obvious to you
oh hey
that uh
Clone Wars
God damn it
it's going to be very obvious to you
that the Clone Wars that the term just
like
sounds very science fictiony right so
George Lucas the only included it
because
uh who the Clone Wars you know like it
just it just it was like a bit it's like
a sound bite that that they that they uh
well I guess mentioned said and uh then
it got turned into a movie but I want to
drink bring your attention to this
it's actually a Commuter Train the seats
are
on the sides this is a wide gauge
actually this is actually quite Advanced
because well Advanced Soviet standards
wise because
uh
well
because
um
um
one second I'll be right with you
because uh it's like a through train
usually these like Soviet commuter
trains have these like door up on door
up on door
stop crying you're in a straight your
train station
all right
oh it's oh yeah it can shoot the [ __ ]
thing on it
f
so yeah
mm-hmm
oh fabricator
put something in it I want to see how
this thing works that's what I said will
it work on the Brussels no but it should
fix up that pistol nicely good thing too
I gave you one of my this account
thanks Russell well you know in case it
doesn't
tell you about myself if I die I am
again
but at my health is full so this antlion
larva did died in vain did die in rain
uh let's see
Do you have a
some more resin here perhaps
more Emerald that is
oops all right
oh man I just said like a girl Stone
what if like
with the way things are going now
it's only a matter of time before
something
before oh good
before something you actually like
becomes the victim of the cultural War
because now uh of course at least in
America everything is culture of War
[ __ ] imagine Half-Life the half-life
Universe becoming like cultural material
like yeah the the what would it even be
like Alex for example is
Alex for example is like half black half
asian so I can absolutely like some like
Med Gates [ __ ] I can I can
oh
it's uh passenger information I can
absolutely imagine like oh yeah the the
woke as general
Gordon Freeman doesn't say a word in the
game that's obviously because it's
female empowerment yeah whatever so I I
dread I dread the
I dread the day when that [ __ ] happens
but see uh proper passenger information
is very important and it's present here
there's even like screens actually
there's a lot of screens maybe even more
screens that there would need to be
though this station though is on the
short end like this is for like three
car trains so this doesn't make as much
sense
um
so I think yeah instead of this world
they should have put something else
because like now it's a
you know there's like what like
one second there's like
one two yeah it's like three car trains
Max
well
it's time to
attempt to clear the station the
station's closed I'm sorry
there we go
I see passenger
and it says yes
oh [ __ ] you
there we go
any item of value
ah
all right come up
oh you too okay
seriously
come on
[ __ ] hit that
oh wait did I
let's not waste ammo
and that one
oh
there we go yeah the reloading mechanism
is super good like you have to drop the
mag
you have to put it back in you to like
pull the uh
you know the top part back I
I do not know guns I'm sorry the bolt
you know the the thing
yeah I'm sorry I'm not
I don't speak no Burger
nice
see these strings have the have the
intermediary doors but that's not how
these
it's not how these usually work
thanks thank you you know for all your
talk about what a lesser gun this is
this thing isn't that bad
so anyway this this station makes
little sense otherwise design wise
because I mean it's a it's an FPS map
obviously but like uh
it's quite
quite short
so like you know I don't know I've not
seen stations
made for three car trains
before
and if you're building underground then
you obviously build according to
standard
um
makes me hungry
oh [ __ ] okay oh this actually scared me
okay
it's so real when the stuff jumps around
you it feels real it's very nice
yep there it is
probably only one of us
hmm
something you might notice in Alex that
when you play play through it like two
or three times then it becomes like too
easy
and it's unironically
but whatever
I guess it's like it's meant isn't like
an entry
oh it's meant there's like an
entry-level VR game
for people to get into the whole thing
not for the Epic VR Gamers out there
as we're loading chat check
is everything
yeah okay okay
no one uh
okay
no one's complaining that means the game
is fine
though at some point I'll I will take a
break
actually I might take a break now
and to drink something no
radio silence
probably fine how do you know that
that's the torture place
how they're going to torture him before
they get there so he's fine
logically speaking
oops
all right
let's get in
that there is a floppy disk we used to
store information on them with magnets
if you can believe it specifically two
micrometers magnetic iron oxide three
is barium ferrite 1.2 Russell
how do you know all this
you downloaded the entire internet
nice yeah yeah it is
all right
ah look we're back at my computer
all right I'm going to save up now and
we're going to
continue later
because
okay let me let me switch back to normal
microphone
starting to drink something
[Music]
so
I am
okay so now you can hear me again
switch back to normal mode
oh no this is this is bad you haven't
even noticed guys but there's a problem
on my end
see
there is
there is a major issue
you will not believe
my seat I've been unseated
I've been unseated and it's unbelievable
I I'm shocked
I'm shocked and terrified
how am I supposed to sit down like this
huh
I also got a lot of the noise
how am I supposed to sit like this Kitty
can you answer this question
am I muted
can you guys hear me
foreign
guys can you hear me am I muted
I'm mutors have I am unmuted
um
[ __ ] my
excess no I I am I am I'm muted oh
okay uh can you hear me now like OBS
says that I am streaming
okay good OBS says that I am uh like I
mean sound of streaming Kitty
Kitty how am I supposed to stream like
oh he she bought she brought her little
toy
yeah like this is her little toy which
is like this little plastic thing it's
like a zip tie like she got like uh she
got like a
wait like in front of the chair you can
see there's like a little zip tie that
she loves like she ignores the cat toys
and is like super effects super excited
about this one
Kitty
stop whining I'm streaming
there's a cat stream now Kitty how am I
supposed to stream like this huh
look at the audience what do you have to
say for yourself well not much
not much because you're a you're a
criminal
all right get it uh let me readjust the
camera okay you can see you can stay in
my lap but you will not because you want
the chair the other cats the other cats
stay in my lap usually not this one
she just like
she's a Adventurer yeah see if it's not
the chair
if it's not the chair she's not staying
because she's a diva
just do something hello
there we go
anyway
[Applause]
yeah so this is life with cats so yes
oh God that that's cursed idea still
so but you can hear me now right
taskbarianism oh no there's a meme
developing there's a meme developing in
in the in the YouTube chat no I I refuse
to acknowledge it anyway
so uh let's see
actually we can we can at some point
have the
uh the Q a stuff
okay how about we have it in like half
an hour
because
um
because
let's let me look at the schedule
um uh yeah and meanwhile we can I think
play some games I think I'm gonna have
wash on
um before 2PM So within the next three
hours and then at 2 pm
uh crowd will come on
and
um
so okay so today like currently this is
now it's 11 here so in three hours I'm
gonna have crowd
uh one hour later not just bikes and
then I think he'll be able to stay for
like half an hour max isn't on vacation
at uh in like four and a half hours I'm
gonna have Ellen Fisher on and then Rhys
like at RM Transit and then
um
once again it's 11 now so at 17 I'm
gonna have the debate and then Dylan
Burns comes on and then I'm gonna I
think end and this is going to be the
the
stream
um you know keep everything to English
so yeah
uh some person asked if they if they can
use like Hungarian no I prefer it
earlier I would prefer if you kept
things
all things
English
um by the way how the [ __ ] can I see
this uh one thing I'm gonna figure out
quickly
um
is how I can actually
[Music]
um
it's YouTube Studio
C list of super chats because it's super
annoying
manage your YouTube super chats and
stickers for live chat
if you purchase super chats and super
stickers
in YouTube Studio
you purchased me during the live stream
if you follow super chess sticker live
feed thank you
in the live control room I'm there
a good relevant stream oh go to the
viewer activity oh it's oh [ __ ] it's
separate I [ __ ] hate YouTube
oh no like we have
okay now I have the
so [ __ ]
so [ __ ] awkward like this whole
[ __ ]
uh
not again look there's a there's another
player
the way he's actually Elvis is actually
the mo the biggest but the most afraid
of the bunch
I'm gonna try to catch him one sec
come here kitty kitty no no no that was
a no
Elvis a Elvis Presley III is uh
or you know alien Elvis as I call him is
like the usually like the most scary of
them all
um okay anyway
I think we're going to
play some games how about that
um
and uh
yeah
actually I'm thinking yeah uh what I had
in mind actually is is uh I'm going to
do some surviving Mars as well that's
like a martian City Builder and one
anyway on on 1000 difficulty that should
be fun yeah they're oh
oh
damn like the the violence happening
behind me is unreal it's incredible and
Spud is just like looking at them
uh oh actually apocalypse apocalypse
apocalypse
all right
this is apocalypse
she is the most gentle docile Kitty
and yeah that's and her sister is over
there that's a
yeah
but this is apocalypse
being currently slapped
yeah but can you apocalypse how are you
doing
yeah she's a I think I think we're
suspecting uh she's like a at least semi
like Norwegian Forest catches but all
actually all of our kids are from a
shelter we have four in total
all right Kitty
no you want to go you want to go
all right
so here's what we're gonna do um
actually you know what I'm not going to
do the
uh am I gonna start gaming now but
because it's 11. so what we're gonna do
is
gets are going wild and what we're gonna
do as usual uh so here's the plan I'm
gonna read out some supers still
and um when we're done with that
um we're gonna take like a half an hour
break
uh
oh hey Altis uh thank you for the
compliment
um so wait let me just make you a mod
actually
so
so anyway
um
thing is
um what we're going to do now is I think
we can I'm gonna read out some supers
and also if you have any questions
um you can ask them now as well we're
gonna have like a little q a now and at
like at 11 30 so in like two this is
going to take 20 minutes maybe and so
from 11 now it's 11 10 here and uh from
11 to 30 till 12 I'm going to have a
lunch break
and uh we're that's that's gonna be like
a
H maybe I'll try to keep it short like
20 minutes or so 15 20 minute break and
then I'm gonna start and then we're
gonna do some um
uh no actually we're not gonna do
surviving Mars we're gonna do surviving
the aftermath because it's an
interesting game though it needs lots of
work
so we're gonna act it's like a city
Builder post-apocalyptic and afterwards
we're going to start having guests on
and everything okay so uh let me look go
through the list of supers
um
it's uh okay what did I leave off it is
YouTube is terrible
Okay so
where was I
um
yes okay so hi Adam if you don't get any
this is from that year ten dollars you
hire them if you don't get on a train
this VR you'll regret it uh well I did
so hell yeah uh wait let me just resize
myself a bit
uh yes and thank you for donation Mr
schnitzel first with the five Swiss
Francs here have some money thanks
uh five dollars
Etc taskbar
yeah did you guys see the taskbar too
much during gameplay because for me it
was like fully full screen like even on
my monitor uh imperator uh imperator zor
uh in 200 story pyramid archeology is
one kilometer tall 500 meter at base
containing all the functions of the city
under its massive roof that's the future
of housing oh yeah it's five Canadian
dollars thank you yes this was this was
the message that you that people wanted
me to write on the on the window in half
left leg is because you can scroll on
the window uh Anastasia Cohen uh 199
thank you
for your uh Super Chat and Jack ninja 10
Australian dollars Daisy was here yes I
wrote that on the on the wall in the end
aticos Russell two Canadian dollars
Winer I guess weiner
this is once again the wall scroll Zach
Gilbert's two US dollars I love Elon
Musk well I wrote that on the wall
uh Chris two daughters thank you for the
donation Allah starts later with the ten
dollars I love your videos you helped uh
birth in me a lot for City Planning I'm
glad to hear that
I'm happy to have done so uh Gustav with
the one British pounds thank you pound
uh Novak with two Euros remove the
Windows taskbar
did you see the windows taskbar because
for me it was
for me it was completely full screen so
I don't know what the [ __ ] happened uh
like I was looking at the screen it's on
my left screen and it was just like
normal full screen whatever
or maybe for a time it wasn't whatever
the main thing is that all of us
survived
um three two dollars the person named
three gave me two US Dollars have you
seen a Moon's video why I hate Elon Musk
um not yet I believe but I think I'll
I'll encounter it but I'll I'll check it
out
Alex Veer for the fine bureaus thank you
very much last time I asked you about
trains trans right you you only said
trains rights last time was your last
time was your 8r6 City skyline stream oh
yes well Trends right obviously uh
trains are Trends rights or humans
rights
human rights oh God I'm I'm suffering a
brain aneurysm live
and um
yes and uh basically
yeah I mean trans fats are human rights
I mean they're obviously uh
uh should be respected because like you
know duh like I mean I'm talking to you
I'm talking to a leftist left-leaning
audience I guess I don't have to explain
otherwise I'll be happy to explain oh
Jack ninja five thank you very much once
again 10 Australian Australian dollars
ready to name Adam something come from
well uh I was just like okay I'm Adam so
um
so uh yeah Adam
so that's like I don't know
uh what should be what should my name be
I don't know something
oh good got my name
so that's the that's the that was the
Epic story because like when I when I am
when I
um
when I started I mean of course I didn't
start with my current [ __ ] uh you
know Channel size I was just like yeah
I'm just gonna have a channel place
where I can do stuff yay Adam something
whatever like I had no [ __ ] idea that
this would be
um
and that this would be
um you know
this would blow up so much uh By the way
Eric
welcome uh to the concert here you can
join my channel uh like it's like kind
of like a patreon that isn't [ __ ] like
in YouTube
and um yeah it's pretty cool uh you can
just join up and get a nice little icon
next to you
um and thank you for the support of
course you're supporting me
um
so
thank you for 20 Turkish liras hope
you're having a good day well yes I am
obviously uh am I having my 1 million
stream and I am well streaming
uh Vin Zigman for for with the 25 polish
slots uh hiring from Poland we have
elections this year what to do with
people unwilling to engage in politics
to make them somehow interested in
politics
well that's a great question I would say
um so of course you can give them
platitudes like hey just because you
don't care about politics that doesn't
mean politics won't care about you you
know that with some people that works
but like yeah I guess I guess what you
have to
make people understand
is uh is that
politics is always a lesser of two evils
game and there will never be a political
candidate which will um
be which will take older boxes so you're
the political candidate that you vote
for will always be somehow
subbore if that makes sense
um you know for example in the Czech
Republic we now have the ODS who are
when it comes to City Planning they're
huge just like
you know huge pieces of [ __ ] worthless
Boomers car brain Etc but they but they
are pro-eo they are pro Euro and they
are not like crazy [ __ ]
populists like the espaded which is the
Boomer Nazi party and the honor which is
like they did the Trump party though
it's not as radical as Donald Trump uh
they did uh Donald Trump formation I
should say right let me Center myself
yeah so
you have to make them understand
that voting only happens once every four
or five years
and um and also that
so just have four to five years
for like have every every four or five
years have
10 minutes of your time dedicated to
put an x on a piece of paper this is all
that's required from you okay
every 45 years
every four to five years that is just 10
minutes of your time you go to a place
you take a piece of paper you put an X
next to a name and then you're done for
five or four years or whatever years
that's all that's necessary and you
absolutely can do that and you should do
that politics is always the illustrator
of two evils game vote for the party
which vote for the party which is the uh
well the best for you it will not be
perfect that's but that's fine you know
part of being an adult is is realizing
that like hey I cannot I cannot always
have everything I want you know uh this
uh you know back during the Bernie
Bernie Sanders craze you know some
people after Bernie lost they they
[ __ ] they they freaked the [ __ ] out
holy [ __ ] they were like
this Bernie Sanders doesn't win then
it's all [ __ ] like no [ __ ] you no no
just go vote for Democrats no no stop no
stop with the Tantrum no stop throwing
things around like a bunch of these a
bunch of these people are like little
literal [ __ ] babies uh and um
yeah I mean that's not how politics
works and that sort of thinking gets
Donald [ __ ] Trump elected right and
if people in Poland do the same [ __ ] I
mean we're all the same we're all the
same humans and our uh we have similar
tendencies in this regard but like if
you know you know enough enough of these
people is enlightened you know uh
politics is corrupt did you know that
guys did you know that
politics is like bad that like
politicians are like like totally
corrupt like oh my God like if it's this
level of Engagement
uh if enough people do this [ __ ] then
then and they don't don't go to vote and
they you know whatever then you're gonna
have
four or five more years of Peace uh or
pish
you know the the the Polish ruling party
the the Christian conservatives uh
actually how how long are the cycles in
Poland
let's see actually we can look at some
balls as well
uh
Bulls score okay here we go
get her flying everywhere
um yeah so base currently is at uh is at
uh three thirty six percent
uh and the KO is the is the um
is the quality
yeah the the Civic Coalition that's the
opposition party
b2050 is also a position so the yellow
colored ones and then there's lavitza
which is the left
then there's Confederation which is the
crazy party I guess as far as I know
yeah Confederation freedom and
Independence I mean when a political
party starts talking about like Friday
or in the pine is like you know at that
point you you you know that it's it's uh
it's bad
and uh
and polish Coalition I think that's uh
uh oh actually uh
I don't know about the Polish Coalition
party actually but uh let me just let me
just Google because I don't I don't want
to say like oh cool there's this new
little green colored party over there
and going ape [ __ ] and like super nice
and then it turns out that there's some
kind of insane [ __ ]
uh Christian democracy conservatism
agrarianism Center to center right
uh yeah based on this
based on this I think it's they're like
they're better than Piss still uh anyway
but anyway just I'm rambling don't and I
have super chats to go through
um I just can uh just tell people hey
dude look do you like piss no go vote
it's I don't care if I don't care if if
the Civil Civic Coalition the cow is not
so good
whatever just go vote for the party
which you think is less is the least bad
it's you have to do it for 10 minutes
every four years you have to take a box
and then you're done so please do your
civic duty because that's that's uh
because otherwise why do we have
democracy if we're not using it right so
anyway
um that's what I would do perhaps
um wow okay and we have a 50 donation
bye
uh beardly interesting congrats only one
million subscribers thank you and thank
you for the 50 Australian dollars as
well
first I'm going to go through super the
guy if you if you have a question
burning inside you then I recommend
asking it in like a super because I have
to get through the supers I have to
scroll down
and then if you ask a question like 200
chats like 200 lines above then I'm not
sure I'll be able to
uh
you know I like like I will likely not
reach it uh it's just how this [ __ ]
chat Works uh aimless be five videos
thank you very much no message
how cryptic Ian Rak
um 100 crowns thank you very much was
your Leipzig video a sequel to your city
review series are you planning any more
of them yeah um actually I'm planning
um
I'm planning uh to
um
to go to other places as well so my plan
is basically to uh like so this is
essentially City Review what I'm doing
um
basically but like I'm not calling it
City View thing is I will
I will
um go to I think next place I will go to
is garlic slashes grizzlitz it's a very
interesting City and um
I'm going to be just like looking around
saying oh yeah this is nice that's not
nice whatever uh that will be quasi to
review so this is the format evolving
um Gone Big 50 grams thank you fun
stream give bundle mod well bundle
should give me their [ __ ]
uh okay one second I need to give one of
my mods
where are you
um
anyway
give me your YouTube
username please
anyway I have all my mods are making
noises you can order them ignore my mods
because that's a good idea
uh
you might you might ignore my mods but
my mods will not ignore you a harmless
drudge thank you for 10 Australian
dollars yes of course the reason why I
have so many Australian dollar donations
is because in Australia it's it's
evening now
enjoyed your video on fantasy from the
other channel what are your favorite
authors in the genre
um
I don't really have like I mean I like
George Martin but like I don't I don't
read fantasy that often
and um
I let's see see a common criticism of
Fantasy by people is that is that uh
fantasy is you know why should I read
fantasy it's just Lord of the Rings but
worse and in many many cases it is true
uh oh yeah also like obviously Witcher
but like in some cases it's true that
like a lot of fantasy is just [ __ ]
Tolkien but worse like you know there's
you got the hero of the Farm Boy comes
out and be like oh it goes on a journey
meets the gaggle of idiots on the way
who become a team and then they go to
whatever equivalent of Mount Doom is and
defeat whatever equivalent of Sauron is
and there's a wizard because there's
[ __ ] Gandalf so look you know like
many many of these uh fantasy books are
pretty like you know just like
carbon carbon copies of Lord of the
Rings which I don't appreciate song
about the song about Safari was good
because though I
I'll shock people and say I think George
Martin is a good writer but he has his
weaknesses like my biggest issue with
the song of ice and fire is that there
is so much like if you read the first
three books are great
it's like a very tightly written
accident trilogy but then comes the
fourth book which is a [ __ ] slog like
the Feast for Crows
was I was just reading it I was just
like oh my [ __ ] god
at the middle I was like skimming it
like yeah Brienne goes to this town gets
her Shield painted get you ask him yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and then I
was like I even stopped I I stopped
reading it because it was just it was
just this it's after the it's the simmer
down period from the it's very intense
Trilogy from the beginning and
uh it's just it's just George Martin
just did not know what to do he's a
discovery writer meaning he just comes
up with it as he goes along which is not
really fine but oh my God he needs to he
needs at least some planning in his life
he goes there uh
and what I like about ski actually The
Witcher writer is that his world is not
like his world is feels more oh wait
wait what I wanted to say by George
Martin
is that
oh my God there's commotion again behind
me
oh the laser eyes wow he's gonna
okay he he'll he'll have mercy on you
oh no oh God this this should be hey if
anyone if anyone wants to like just
rewind a bit and um
turn that turn the cat with the glowing
eyes into an emote
okay now all of them are here
apocalypse
apocalypse come here apocalypse
apocalypse
by the way I have not forgotten about
the supers I'm gonna read them
lips
hey
hey how goes it huh
what's that some light source
oh my God
go join your
Trooper friends
yeah this is so afraid
yeah well the cats are having their fun
and while they do you can observe them
and I'm gonna Spud
[Music]
I'm gonna read some supers in the
meantime favorite tips don't forget
um yeah and the last thought really what
I wanted to say subkovsky what I like
about ski is that I'm pointing at my
bookshelf is that
he takes a fantasy world and and like a
just like a carbon copy regular ass
[ __ ] monsters elves whatever goblins
and
puts a spin on it which is nice that
like you know there's all this racism
there is ethnic Strife or racial Strife
whatever and that's so interesting
because usually these [ __ ] fantasy
books are like everyone is living in
harmony you know it's completely
meanwhile you know in the real in a
medieval Society right meanwhile in our
real world [ __ ] we only get like at
least in the US we got like for you
Americans got interracial marriage
legalized like I don't know last century
was it it's pretty [ __ ] bizarre yeah
so sarkov actually brings some life
today to the to the universe anyway
um so that was my answer to a harmless
garage thank you for the 10 Australian
dollars
Grace with the two dollars what about
the taskbar well I've tasked it with
different things it's now busy
um
the YouTube chat YouTube just to keep my
blood pressure up is also jumping around
it's when I once I start to scroll down
it like jumps back down so I so to keep
me on my on the edge of my seat uh
Charlotte Bonita too
um two Heroes thank you very much what
do you think of Destiny also like take
me up
and
yes it could be but then there is Berlin
right
it's also pretty close so I would say
I would lean towards Berlin I would I
want to do it this year ideally the
Berlin Meetup I'm going to oh yeah okay
one sec my mod I forgot to make my mod
uh a mod
um
and
okay good uh Pendle you're now a mod uh
and uh yeah I think I think it's gonna
be brilliant but Destiny Oh you mean Des
tiny well he got
I don't know about him but like he got
[ __ ] destroyed by my cats today we
can all agree
Destiny got obliterated by Spud
yeah he's having fun with the controller
there
he obliterated today that like [ __ ]
destroyed him in the debate oh my God
Destiny should retire at this point
because Spud
took him to [ __ ] cleaning uh anyway
or is that took him to the cleaners yeah
that's that's the [ __ ] he took him to
cleaning
anyway
oh God uh
red Rios
1789 uh thank you for the Paraguay
currency 10 000 of it wow what comes to
mind when you think of Paraguay
Paraguay
I don't know
currently
without Googling I'm Googling program
but as far as I know it's in like South
America all right
yes so
yeah so like South America comes into
mind
yeah plus like you know these Spanish
you know Colonial Empire or whatever
uh crowd has a great video series about
that by the way the Mexican border story
to check it out
that's what I think when I
think of Paraguay
it's kind of like butter gay huh
oh oh violence
violence
playing uh so
I should stream my [ __ ] cats dude
she's like you can like send supers and
like a voice synthesizer reads it up to
the cats
the uh oh go away it's fellow YouTuber I
have to answer his question what do you
think of the urban planning in the in
Game of Thrones it's it's medieval
irregular though one thing that ticks me
off is that like they too do this
[ __ ] that like Medi oh yeah medieval
that means everything is gray and dirty
and people are these like [ __ ]
unwashed animals oh that's because
that's the Medieval Era no [ __ ] you it
was actually quite colorful
so you know I wish I wish people would
stop with that [ __ ] hi hey Adam
Patrick 50 crowns
um
whatever uh hey Adam where are you
actually from because you said you live
in Germany you often talk about Hungary
but you sound like a Czech well yeah I I
speak Czech uh I lived in Czech Republic
but I'm Hungarian so original like you
originally I'm from Hungary then I went
to Germany to study and then I went to
live in Prague and now I live in Germany
so I'm a True Pen European specimen
but of course I I have simulated into
Czech culture so like I know like you
know
you know
[Music]
um
et cetera Etc like these these are of
course Staples of Czech culture and
Hungarian culture as well but of course
using different words uh aimless B5
Heroes forgot to add message we want to
ask what's your take
on current German politics what my take
is the left parties are split while they
ride get more radical
ah
see I'm not completely okay so I don't
I've not heard about the uh my chair is
giving up I have not heard about the
German right radicalizing I know that
the if day well actually we can take a
look uh one sec and then I'll be
returning to the supers
so here we have yeah I mean the the
pizza so of course after the SPD keeps
[ __ ] blundering the social Democrats
the social Democrats keep [ __ ]
blundering around and the greens
[Music]
the greens are doing okay
I would say it's like two years the
greens are like yeah I mean their Peak
was 25 now they're at 19 like whatever
it's like it's okay the left
the left is a
doing pretty badly like the left body
but but then but the link here like I
don't like them so the the German left
party is kind of like the tanky party
uh I don't like they had this [ __ ]
party conference where like they they
the goal of them meeting was to
figure out whether they agree
to figure out whether they agree with
with uh whether they will condemn I
think the Russian invasion of Ukraine
and the party could not reach a
consensus you know so yeah that's sassy
yeah the if there is a uh has come up
but uh the IFD is rise to a whopping 14
so it's not that terrible there's only
like 20 percent to maximum 25 of idiots
who can be suckered into half day so
it's in Germany it's like there's like a
hard Gap
because German Germans are like educated
against far-right uh demagoguery
thankfully so this is because of the
cost of living obviously like prices
have increased so like in in an
apartment like if you live in an
apartment like in a comic block for
example in the Czech Republic like my
friend now
pays like like they increased the common
expenses by like
40 euros or something so and then and
then that's it so now he pays like I
don't know he's not living in Prague but
like my friend lives actually in ustina
Alabama so you know he now pays like
uh
uh one sec actually interested to
uh he's what was his rent like 7K yeah
no uh oh 99k
yeah okay so his speed pay is now like
for like a he leaves him again I think
like a one plus one in like a
36 square meter yeah like last time we
discussed this yesterday actually we
were discussing this
so yeah he pays like 380 Euros or so for
the whole thing for like a 36 square
meter apartment and a good location so
you know it's still I mean it's Luciano
then that's like a cheap part of the
Chicago public but still but in his his
common expenses increased by like 40.
because of the crisis and that's it
but yeah back to Germany I mean yeah the
if they will of course capitalized on
of course capitalized on the price
increases and the sale so capitalizes on
the incompetence of the espede which is
I mean that's unfortunate
anyway here we'll see but like German
German politics is actually quite stable
so that's the nice thing about it
so
you know uh so you you cannot expect
really like these like huge swings
uh there
so uh back to the God [ __ ] damn it
I'm so sorry
technical difficulties hey Jack ninja
we're fine once again thank you for this
20 Australian dollars how much do you
pay for your cats for their work on the
channel they should get a raise oh they
they got a raise all right they're
they're two of them are overweight
uh what I I guess I succeeded in like
raising their cholesterol and I need to
put them on a diet
uh Stone Black Dog 2000 foreigns thank
you very much one meal already congrats
thank you uh more chance Isabella Morris
five pounds British pounds thank you
very much uh congrats on one meal and
nice t-shirt have you ever read any
China meville it seems like you would be
right up your uh it would be right up
your alley be a secret Turtle but thank
you very much and thank you for tip
China me Bill
let me just note this down I'm always
interested in you
uh
in you
literary experiences
uh
I think I'm gonna actually put myself
back in the large since uh answering
your questions already
um
a Squiddy with the five pounds hi who
does your motion graphic slash animation
in your videos do you do them yourself
what made you want to use them
um the guy who uh thank you
um whatever so thank you in case I
haven't said it
um so
um the Motion Graphics the guy who does
the Motion Graphics is actually actually
works he used to work for h3h3 he's a
Hungarian guy uh he he does anything
work for this Hungarian politics channel
it's kind of like the majority Report
with Sam Cedar similar I guess talk show
whatever it's called partisan hungarians
will know he does editing work for them
and he reached out to me one day like
early on in my career that that uh it's
like hey need an editor I did work for
H3 here's my stuff I'm like yeah cool
so
uh right Ray VB thank you for the five
pounds oh the BR the Brits are awake oh
no you can you can actually follow the
time zones by currency super cool
uh ready to be hello Adam regardless
what the video about uh your videos are
pure relaxation appreciate your work uh
fam hope you're hope your work continues
to prosper well thank you very much
I hope that as well uh Amir Hassan
yes it's a nice Balkan name with the two
bam Bosnian uh
yes
why does Urban do stuff to help break
down Bosnia
I don't know specifically specifically
about Bosnia but Orban has a very clear
ethno nationalist agenda uh he is a far
right at the Nationalist as you know and
he wants the territories back which were
taken from Hungary following a about a
century of like a rabbit well not
censure but like
60 70 years of like a rabid ethno
supremacist politics in Hungary so
naturally the the the the the
naturally the um uh you know people got
pretty pretty [ __ ] upset like
non-hungarians uh
so I'm not going to say that I'm not
going to say that Hungary deserved
to lose two-thirds of its territories
because I mean it was a disaster for
many people obviously
but I mean
is the sort of thing where he's like
well what do you expect right like when
you it's like there's this charming
little thing when you walk around the
forest and you see someone
uh picking strawberry in in a fur coat
and a fur hat you know
and you and you actually walk up to them
to a custom it's like the [ __ ] do you
expect right
how do you think this was gonna go
um the joke is that it's not a person
wearing a fursuit and they like for for
coat and the hat it's actually a bear
you know
um
you know it's it's actually if you don't
know this like this is one of these like
famous last words of like who's this
idiot picking picking berries in in a
first fur coat in summer you know
most famous last bird
um yeah Orban is an ethno Nationalist
and
he's blessed like he's in Putin's pocket
whatever I don't know Orban only cares
about his own money and power so it's a
uh yeah that's the situation
so don't don't take anything seriously
that Orban ever says
uh except when people does things well
he's an ethno nationalist what can you
do
um
thank you very much can you come up with
a compliment for Elon Musk Greetings or
Amsterdam
um well greetings to you and thank you
for the 10 euros
um a compliment for Elon Musk
he's
converting oxygen to CO2 properly
Ray VB 10 pounds again thank you very
much you know what I remember thought a
thought of run running Euro Nation
um
yeah well running my own Nation I prefer
democracy there's like so much [ __ ]
work involved plus I don't I wouldn't
want to be a tyrant I think like if if
someone like if the apocalypse happened
tomorrow and someone came up to me like
hey [ __ ] you're gonna be the [ __ ]
king of this nation of survivors no
[ __ ] no you know debate I'd be like
okay in that case I think I would do
decent but there would be no guarantee
that the person after me would still
would also have the the same
the same
sentiments like Pro people sentiments
and there's there's of course no
guarantee that power wouldn't corrupt me
and I wouldn't become this like soulless
[ __ ] like you know oligarch and
whatnot
uh yeah so I mean power corrupts and the
reason why democracies can stay fresh
for so long is because
as long as there aren't any militia
sectors anyway is that is because uh
there's checks and balances and like
power cannot corrupt you as much like if
you think about any democracy corrupt
holy [ __ ] try a dictatorship
hmm
so back to some more supers black slime
thank you for the 25 Polish currency you
guys really need Euro
will you make a video about polish
politics Poland is gaining importance in
EU for better or worse and the story of
piss dominance is infuriating yeah it's
basically the same thing as
as Orban like this party which tries to
legislate democracy away basically or
just like turn the country into like
this
fake democracy uh completely legally
because they make the rules and they and
they always like Skip by right so it's
not like hey since we make the rules now
since we're now leading the [ __ ]
you know government democracy is over
like no it's more like you know voter
suppression you know making it really
difficult for opposition uh you know
voters to vote for example lots of lots
of people living in Western Europe are
in Hungary at least like in terms of
hungarians a lot of people living in the
west are actually opposition and they
are there because they don't like Urban
Hungary but they cannot [ __ ] vote
because in order to vote like I tried
[ __ ] voting from Prague and it was a
[ __ ] like it would have been a
[ __ ] like I wouldn't have like what I
what I had to do was to like contact my
my district electoral office in my
hometown
and then [ __ ] like call that [ __ ]
office in jur Hungary and so then just
get some kind of like then contact the
embassy and they're gonna issue me a
paper
in like paper form which they're gonna
send me and they have to have it signed
and show up with that to a some kind of
booked appointment it was a [ __ ] like
yeah it's designed so yeah so you don't
show up the boat anyway uh yeah I might
cover Poland what many people don't know
is that I actually
have Polish ancestry so like my my
surname like at the family surname used
to be knowledge Nick so yeah that means
pancake uh the family is actually from
the the Galicia area the Western Ukraine
so
yeah that's why actually my my father
was actually my father was always
wondering like why am I
my great grandma was putting Dill into
everything like everything and that's
that's because that's that's that's how
Polish people do it in that area
um thoughts on creation joining the
Eurozone good I mean
who the [ __ ] cares about the kuna
honestly
um not even croatians really and uh the
problem with the I mean everyone just
goes to Croatia to like for like their
summer holiday summer holidays and
that's what the country is based on
essentially and I'm not gonna like
completely but like huge part of it and
people
obviously will
um
people will obviously just like you know
pay like a hero there anyway so like
whatever actually it was a bit scammy
because if you paid if you had like your
card uh and you paid by card you know
the conversion doesn't go like for
example hungarians Went to went to
Croatia and then they pay there the
conversion doesn't go the conversion
doesn't go
um you know uh
like foreignty is the Hungarian currency
kuna is the correct decoration currency
it doesn't go
all your paid back on with a foreign car
so now foreign kuna no it goes Forint US
dollar at a bank conversion rate and
then back to kuna once again at the bank
conversion rates a huge ripoff
yeah
um oh actually I I will return to this
because
um
uh I also want to rant about trains a
bit
like Hungarian trains
and
this this is actually a we're going to
be connected so
um there but anyway uh Croatia it's it's
good that they joined the Eurozone every
country in Europe should join the
Eurozone I think it's it's just it's it
makes Commerce so much easier
and it's such a [ __ ] pain in the ass
uh one sec I got post I got post I think
a train game uh be right back
while I received the package
you can consider the kitty I'll get her
foreign
the package is here
watch package
what a great question
[Music]
foreign
I ordered
to run down the stairs a bit but I
ordered
two
I ordered two
Orange dejeve
cars for my
Deja vistette which is uh
I only need like two more I think
first class middle cars for it to be
complete they're a pain in the fuckiness
to find it's impossible but
uh yeah so I'm going to have a
soon a complete orange Deja Bay
on my shelf and I'm gonna be taking
pictures of it when that happens
so back to supers because we have a few
oh [ __ ] I need to
I need to work out more
So Gone Big thank you for the 200 crowns
now we're back to the supers once again
if you have a question to me now we're
doing Q a
if you have a question to me then please
do not hesitate to ask and then after
the Q a we're going to have
uh a
break
that's going to be my lunch break and
this reminds me I should also uh
order my food because uh
I cannot go and [ __ ] start cooking
here
so anyway uh gombik Europe needs to
integrate more I hope recent events will
lead to higher power
to the Parliament and closer to a
potential Federation also unilateral
vetoes need to go yes I agree
uh
a problem with current with current
you know American
European politics is that uh
okay is that uh
see
what I really hate about current
politics is that the
uh
yeah okay I probably cannot multitask
this can I
okay uh one sec yes
I'm just I'm just handling my lunch
quickly
uh
yes
okay good
um anyway so uh yeah the in Europe
there's an issue like the reason why
Orban and idiots like him can wreak
havoc
uh European politics is because
um like the the uh it has to be
unilateral uh many decisions so if one
one country
uh says no to something then the whole
thing is blocked and that's not nice and
urban of course uses that to the fullest
extent
to block European integration to block
your Ukraine's Ukraine's
you know approach to Nato and EU
[ __ ] sucks
now back to more supers hypers even
where was I
hmm
okay but don't worry no super is getting
lost I'm I'm double checking
uh so holy Oreo Taco uh 10 Australian
dollars hired him from Australia
actually I should write hi item for
Australia Ohio
sorry this is not against you I just
like having fun with accents I I like
Australian
um hi Adam Hi from Australia uh I love
your video vids I didn't know I wanted
to know about eastern central European
politics but now I know and that's it
that's good I guess oh yeah good for you
uh what are your opinions on Australian
politics or else Paul I guess that's
what you mean
um I don't really see I don't really
follow Australian politics
uh but uh I heard you had trouble with
the conservatives locally and uh yeah
well that's that sucks uh I should look
into it more but like I heard like the
big question of Austrian politics now is
what's going to happen with China right
so yeah
there's a
there's a cat in the back wait uh oh
actually one more Super and then I'm
gonna try to catch him
how did you end up in Leipzig well I
moved there because it's nice
uh yeah I mean since I work from home
I'm like okay why do I want to go hell
Leipzig okay
Ravi B two pounds thank you have you
ever been to London not yet actually
I've never set foot in an
English-speaking country in my life so
that's uh
I guess that's on me
well actually my voice is getting a bit
raw so now again if when that happens
like I can do the German train announcer
voice maybe I'll do it in a bit
so Antelope man five videos thank you
very much what do you think of climate
activists blocking roads and spilling
soup on paintings
uh our directions Justified or do they
do they or do they do more harm than
good
um
I mean I get what they're coming where
they're coming from but like blocking
roads
fine
as long as you're not blocking an
ambulance or a fire truck or something
but like it's dumping tomato on like
paintings I mean that's just
I feel like that's not effective
advocacy right because uh the people you
need to convince the most are like
currently like the Boomers and like
you know the generation after them
whatever and if you like if you like
they idolize
art like that you know like a Vanguard
whatever
or something you know if you dump tomato
juice on it like then then all day all
you will
all you'll have achieved is like them
just like becoming super angry go oh
dare you with these oh these Zoomers are
ruining or my culturally like it's gonna
be this like there's gonna scream at you
and you're not gonna make any allies
with that right so people might be aware
like oh yeah climate change but yeah
there's this [ __ ]
yeah dumping tomatoes so some paintings
and so and that's that's more important
uh you know we live in the area of
culture War so don't do anything that
can be used that much by the right to
fear monger and scaramu because because
like if you take someone like takaka or
something like one of these like huge
demagogues
you take those activists who spilled the
[ __ ] thing uh the tomato juice on the
painting chocolate is gonna be on the on
the show like
like um
these activists their their minds their
their out of their minds you know their
hearts might be in the right place but
is it really is it really the way to do
this despicable activism by desecrating
our our
you know whatever whatever he would say
like our white Heritage our Western
Heritage or yeah that uses the the the
euphemisms
um yeah that's
you know if you give them ammo like that
just don't it's a bad idea
anyway
[ __ ] you know so Tillman hoped two
Euros thank you very much is a United is
a United States of EU reachable and
useful
I think crowd has a very good video
about that but what is Europe I think
it's European Union I think will I think
that's The Natural end state
of the European Union or something
similar
um but I think it's yeah I think it's I
mean obviously it's useful like uh uh in
terms of countries like if you take away
all like all these like you know uh
considering like nationalistic
considerations of like you know
should this ethnicity decide about it if
you take away all that and just look at
and just look at you know what is
uh hey Kitty what is uh efficient and
what works I mean [ __ ] obviously
right I mean I mean the more uh the more
the more efficiently you can pull your
resources the better it is for example
is Healthcare right because in Europe
there is uh like of course shortage of
doctors and nurses especially in the
East and so Western countries actually
suck away very much needed Personnel
from the East with better salaries
whatever and so you're gonna have a
block where on one half of it it's like
you know it's measurably worse
Healthcare but you know aside from the
underfunding problems you know the
Personnel also isn't there now if you
had a central sort of budget for for
European healthcare for example and you
had like a minimum wage of like okay uh
nurses should make at least next 1000
Euros per month doctors
1500 or 2 000 something like that uh and
uh you know this to a to a nurse in
Western Europe is like okay whatever but
to a nurse and a doctor in Eastern
Europe is like oh okay so if you raise
the salary this will still not be a
western level but it will be high enough
so that people won't migrate uh to to
West to the Western uh countries right
so anyway and the same thing about
military you know like why the [ __ ] do
we have 27 different militaries uh when
we can have just like one unified
command structure in Europe and like and
and so we can like standardize do the
same things buy the same things learn
the same thing whatever like so I mean
this this to me is like it's like
logical
um
anyway
uh
YouTube okay dragos udrea with the 10
Ron Romanian I guess
any thoughts on Austria refusing Romania
to Schengen
yeah I mean that's uh that's uh that's
an ongoing Epic
um yeah Austria has its geopolitical
interests obviously which is unfortunate
but like I mean Romania will have to be
accepted eventually to Schengen uh
everybody it's a dick move uh I think
yeah I think once again watch krotz
video about it the crowd made the the
what is your video I think he covers it
there
or in his denube video but like it's
actually a very very nice overview so if
all of you uh are interested about
Central Europe
um in more in depth than crowd is your
man he's gonna be on actually today at
or in rather uh in about two hours
Diego two Heroes thank you very much
what do you think about the urbanism of
Barcelona I've been to Barcelona it was
very nice um
uh the super blockified streets were
awesome I I really enjoyed them and you
know the city uh seems to be making good
progress I've I did not spend as much
time like I spent like one full day and
then I then I went on to Paris
but uh it's from what I've seen it's
decent and higher quality than many of
many Central and Eastern European cities
uh Luca Lucas pascara I the SZ in
Hungarian is this so maybe in Polish
it's different anyway 25s let's thank
you very much uh you are not judging
Poland and this correctly do research
and do a video about it just you just
copy what western media says about
Poland I heard that phrase before this
is what supporters of War bands say but
hey I will look into it I am
actually well versed about Poland
because Hungarian media very often
covers it
it's a major Urban allies Ally So based
on what I've seen based on what I've
read
it's not the situation is not quite as
dire I should say as in Hungary but
it is uh it's not as dire as in Hungary
but they're trying otherwise Poland has
a more
developed political culture then Hungary
whereas Hungary is like a more
balkanized than Poland so you know but
you know I'll continue accumulating
information NP NPC pork and my food is
here one second
I'm back sorry food is here at some
point going to take a lunch break so uh
squid with the five Australian dollars
who's the best pony uh
well
what are some of the characters
Twilight Sparkle yeah there you go
uh
and I think that was all the supers for
now okay uh
all right people in that case I'm going
to take a lunch break now and I'm going
to be back in about
10 and I would say say 15 minutes okay
no I didn't miss NPC Porky
I read his
oh yeah [ __ ] I did miss did it we have
two supers
oh God yeah I missed NPC board game
Sorry I'm sorry tell me sorry mp4k I've
been I was so rude two years thank you
very much will Mass mobilization help
Russia in the war it will help prolong
the war but it will not it will not be
decisive right so I mean it will help
because like the quality of Benbow is
worse and worse it will
um help prolong the war it will give
them some bodies to throw on the fire
but like that's it basically that's
going to be it
um yeah
otherwise I would say uh
yeah that's that's all there is to say
currently uh yeah so
okay
uh
good all right so I think I covered
everyone so I'm going to also
[Music]
and just to make it clear what's
happening
I'm going to do
lunch break BRB
BRB 15 minutes
just just so that you people don't
get confused as to what's going to
happen
here we go
and I'll be back in 15 minutes I need to
go
at the [ __ ] chat froze am I still
streaming
hello
am I still is the stream still on I'm
gonna
okay okay good it's still going okay
just the chat the chat froze thank you
YouTube
anyway
all right so I'll be back in 15 minutes
and yeah have fun and yeah YouTube great
great service yeah and wait I'm going to
align the camera in a way that if the
cat yes the cat also needs to be fed
because she's whining because she's
hungry
but she will be back
and when she will be
then you'll be able to enjoy her
presence
so
hey
you want any animal okay so yeah so see
you guys in about 15 minutes okay go get
something to eat or drink I'll be right
back
thank you
hello hello
foreign
you're too excited
all right I'm back in the game oh no
welcome back everyone
uh lunch break is now over
um
all right I got a Super Chat what to
wear
uh five videos thank you very much fun
fact from centurio progressives one
majorly in British Slava but the
Slovakian government defunded the
already poor cities so much that most
projects must be postponed yeah
yeah I mean that happens
same thing in Budapest so
cities I'm gonna just scroll back to see
if they missed any
yeah no okay anyway so um yeah
okay task Warrior okay
yeah I know uh yeah CDD funding is
actually quite a
quite a large problem uh in in Central
Europe This is like this Eastern
balkanized [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] governing
when the goal of the government is not
to like you know
so when actually when actually helping
people is like a secondary consideration
and everything is supported subordinated
to uh you know
I'm just like um
like this blind pursuit of power even at
the cost of people's uh people's living
conditions as we've seen in the
okay as we've seen in uh in um well
uh Central Europe basically
I know something would you make a
detailed video on how Urban's government
undermines democracy actually exploring
specific examples yeah um I wanted to do
something like that I will get to it at
some point
I do want to get to it
um
Yeah question is when Etc
otherwise yeah problem is like it's it's
pretty unfair that like
it's pretty it's pretty unfair that like
uh
two videos I worked a lot on like a lot
a [ __ ] on a work went into them like
lots of research Etc was the
I was on the how Orban
helped exacerbate the refugee crisis and
uh and the hip and basically indirectly
caused the Buttercup massacre in Paris
and how Ukraine defied Russia and
both the [ __ ] both of those [ __ ]
videos both of those [ __ ] with won
the the Ukraine video which was a huge
amount of work
um
the Ukraine video was
demonetized it's 18 plus now it's gone
like it's not even on the radar in on
the algorithm so that's nice you know
um it still that it has like 500 000
views but but here let me look at uh let
me look at how many views it's getting
um let's see yeah Ukraine the country
that divided Vladimir Putin 18 plus only
ineligible age restricted [ __ ] you
um
huge amounts of work went into it and
like every every hour like
10 to 20 people see it
now like it shut up like crazy in the
beginning when for like went to like 300
000 within the first nine days
and then it's at like 473
000 and then but no one is finding it
because uh yeah I got [ __ ] by the
algorithm the other video was which I
also worked a lot about a lot on
was um let's see where is it I changed
the title recently it's the
actually you know what I'm going to put
it on screen instead
there we go
let's see
so this is the Ukraine video yeah
and the other video where is it [ __ ]
here how Urban trolled the Western
helped cause the particular Massacre
I've been experimenting with different
titles 205
000 views one of my lowest viewed
[ __ ] videos
this video like I worked this was my
first like really work intensive video
it was like I I put it out like yes oh
my God it's people are gonna love this
and then it's like like nothing uh
YouTube
so anyway that's that's life
uh
well let's get about some questions a
bit uh Adam something would you live in
a city that has almost no public transit
is there a way someone could change it
and how how would that affect the
community I'm talking about Pristina
kosovoia the Balkans are pretty [ __ ]
yeah Kosovo is a strange example first
like Kosovo first of all needs an
economy before anything else happens
um
which actually affords the country
things
which doesn't always happen yeah
yeah and Kosovo would be like EU
membership would be a great uh great
step uh if you can get it make it to the
EU then things will get better for you
so
um calamari Calamity five Canadian
dollars oh the Canadians are waking up
nice
can we see more of your cat you're my
favorite YouTuber YouTuber by the way
thank you
um sure hey spot
he he was licking himself and he was
looking at me like
like dong out one second
[Music]
kitties holding on for his dear life
he's really really addicted to to uh
surfaces like he has to Grapple onto her
something Spud wow Spud no no see he he
sees the ground and like triggers him he
cannot be suspended but otherwise he's
fine he's just rattled a bit Spud calm
down it's okay
kind of breathe into the microphone a
bit
no
it wouldn't even breathe
hey spider how's it going oh he's such a
smart Kitty he's actually quite
intelligent he looks super dumb but he's
actually very intelligent
um
[Music]
he's not amused
anyway
stop freaking out sometimes he
cannot leave me alone like he jumps up
on my lap whether whether I want him or
not but now it now it's
just not in the mood
oh well
that was spurred
yeah and apocalypse
apocalypse is also very friendly but she
kind of I don't know just goes after her
own head basically
now he goes there to like slap
yeah well that's Spud
um
uh let's see oh a new member uh Denny's
Blue music thank you very much for your
membership welcome to the bit
um
blue light zero two pounds thank you
very much have you played mini Metro no
not yet I've heard good things
if I'm if I
think here if I think I'm referring to
the right thing
um Ray DB thank you once again for the
two pounds I think it's good if a
country is smoke free yeah um
I think I think we should phase out
cigarettes eventually
um because they are just there's just no
use for cigarettes right you just get
addicted like cigarettes are basically
like uh corporate schemes to get you
hooked on a substance it's basically
like the opioid abuse but like soft
chord is why no one really cares but I
think the EU has has plans to like uh
to like um
phase out or at least at least some
countries as far as I have plans to
phase out tobacco by taxation so that
like no one will want to but by the way
super easy way to end smoking tomorrow
would be to have uh
I have to keep an eye on them have uh
cigarette boxes
with like these little like these like
really stupid looking colors
and write the brand on them with like
colorful comic scents right like once
you do that smoking stops being cool
because you're no longer are gonna be
like you know uh like you know the
gentleman with the box of Marlboro
instead you're gonna be like the the
[ __ ] idiot who has to suck down on a
on a box of Like Comics and sticks you
know uh every half an hour and that's
not cool and everyone basically most
people will stop doing smoking I think
at that point
um
I'm pretty sure there have been studies
to share with it but
okay now now apocalypse has discovered
the the package that the
cars came in don't be into it uh Leon's
okay actually
apocalypse
okay whatever it's not not too bad
now spot is also there to help okay
one second
foreign
guys
our package has arrived
hey apocalypse how's it going
wow it came wow this this was expedited
wow all right well I'll move the box to
the other room so it doesn't bother us
one second
okay so okay hey everyone welcome back
back to the super is Leon's account five
pounds thank you very much opinions on
two things three Russian Legion in
Ukraine fighting against Putin in the
city of Page Hungary a little bit
personal about crap urbanism yeah um
Russian Legion hell yeah more power to
them
doing great work uh Paige hunger yeah
page is kind of like a Backwater like
although that that's set to change with
like Schengen like um
set the change actually with uh
with uh Croatia becoming part of
Schengen
[ __ ] pitch is
here
it's a it's decent but like
here's Hungary
and wait let me here we go here's
Hungary and this is Page
and yeah
it's like just this
it has like a nice Turkish city center
like it is like this Turkish mosque I
think
otherwise the city is like
um
it's nice I've been there decent but
there is not much to do right it's uh
otherwise like the city is just like big
comic blocks uh there's like a whole
bunch of uh where was that area that
I've been to yeah
um
areas like this basically just like this
big empty
uh also like lots of camera I mean as I
said it's fine it's decent but like
there's nothing to do in page absolutely
nothing so it's like
a back of water uh yeah so
back to the supers I've not forgotten
about you guys
yet
uh radiator five euros thank you very
much congrats to one million subscriber
sorry for top topic but are you aware of
the YouTuber laser Pig I think a few of
you would be a good fit for a discussion
yeah people keep mentioning
um I got a link in on Discord as well I
will check it out I've heard the name
before it doesn't ring about currently
like it does ring a bell but I I cannot
contextual contextualize it so what I'm
gonna do is uh after the stream I think
I'm gonna check it out and maybe I'll
post about it or something because but
currently I don't
yeah
um oh yeah did you see Nick Adams out
for me oh yeah the Nick Adams alpha male
Twitter page rant about feminism and M
M's yeah
actually I'm going to
so Nick Adams
is
this is so this Twitter page
is not a parody
this dude Nick Adams parentheses alpha
male parentheses closed
as far as I know this account is legit
it has half a million followers
in my size correctly yeah
and you know Australian by birth hell
yeah
Bible in hand fortnite controller in the
trash president Trump NFC on display
Nick Adams gave me a book to get yours
today like see I cannot tell if these
idiots are [ __ ] for real or not like
this is surreal
this is beyond [ __ ] parody
uh
I think he's doing this it's like life
coach but I wouldn't be surprised if
this turned out to be a better day but
at this point it's genuinely difficult
to know
uh
the Constitution says I can have as many
AR-15s and AK-47s with that one see like
this is like
alpha male challenge go to your local
grocery store and purchase the largest
bag of M M's oh yes the M M's now it's
culture or destroy the book of MMC
purchased then do not let one pass your
lips
you know take a photo of your crushed
loganies and busting a social guys is
this really is this not a better day
account oh my God
I am done with Eminem wait let's let's
let the man himself
explain g'day guys Nick Adams here I
want to speak about
at least
feminist Eminems Yes you heard me right
feminist Eminence egregious sexism of
the worst and most conceivable kind it
is outrageous it is disgusting and it
must not stand that is why I am calling
for a complete and total boycott of all
things Mars and
M M's it will not stand let me let me
say this loudly let me say this clearly
let me say this unambiguously any male
that buys a packet of academic any email
from
from today for
you has serious serious serious problems
until Eminem's Rectify this grave Wrong
by giving us all male M M's
caught will remain
we will not stand for this at all
dude's such a hero dude
[ __ ] Nick Adams
national hero
both of Australia and the US fighting
against the beta soy boy teachers
this is not parody like oh my [ __ ] like
is American politics really is far gone
holy [ __ ] dude
uh
like I don't know this is this is what
you would expect from some kind of like
spoof candidate in here [ __ ]
yeah well the alpha male you know like
also like actually we can talk about
Alpha meals and stuff but like
uh
you know known known quality of alpha
males or like confident alpha males is
that they feel they need to tell
everyone that they're alpha males yeah
that that you know confident confident
people really do run around telling
everyone how they're confident right
yeah
sure uh
oh and the Leon's account your page
question the the last one yes Paige does
have crap urbanism but the public
transit that did get better I don't know
if it I've only been there like 2013 the
last time so back then it was like went
through a reform and whatever
uh
wait oh yeah I know that was okay so
Denny's Blue music uh who's also a
member a channel member uh we did 200
Turkish liras they were going to give
you up and we're going to let you down
then we're gonna run around and desert
you then we're gonna make you cry then
we're gonna say goodbye never gonna tell
a lie and hurt you
we're in full agreement
pack slime with the 10 pulleys which is
Warhammer 40K yay nayor what the [ __ ] is
that I would say yay it's neat uh of
course like Warhammer should not be
understood understood through the lens
of
people who think
that like you know Warhammer is a goal
because there are people out there who
genuinely think that Warhammer with the
emperor worship and whatever is not a a
sort of a is not like satire slash
negative example but they think it's
like glorified no uh so Warhammer yay
minus all the stupid larpers but like
yeah I guess those exist everywhere oh
dude if you want by the way if you want
the the uh the ultimate cringe like just
pure unadulterated cringe uh
even more so than our Nick Adams alpha
male over here [ __ ] go to any sort of
crusader
song on YouTube and just look at the
comments
you're gonna die actually I can
uh I can
yeah with one with like
lots of some like larpy [ __ ] music
too
uh
yeah here this one
March of the Templars
don't want to get like you know I don't
want to get like copy strike but like
uh [ __ ] like these like I cannot take
this seriously because whenever I watch
these like
when I listen to this like uh it's good
music it's [ __ ] it's it's powerful
and stuff but like
I cannot help but imagine
just like a bunch of
sweaty palmed
emaciated 12 year old in front of their
computer with sweaty Palms looking like
yes they all smoke I'm like oh okay yeah
I know I'm not part of that club I'm
sorry I I do get laid uh before we
continue with the video quick supers
Eric Albany what do you think about
Icarus 2 and already it's great but
obviously at this point we still have to
be hungry Leaf blady U.S 4.99 thank you
very much US dollars do you like anime
at all my favorite is motoko Magica and
was curious if you've seen it yes I've
seen it Madoka is good I think JoJo is
my favorite though nowadays I don't
watch as much anyway but hey I still
have the JoJo mangas Jack ninja five
thank you once again for the 10
Australian dollars I they'll never
understand right wing logic if you want
to boycott something why are you telling
us to buy it and crush it the money
still goes to Mars at the end of the day
yeah yeah I mean yeah I mean these
boycotts like these age one more guy
actually has like a woke Brands Whatever
video about this uh Oak Brands I think
is a title uh it boycotts help the
company so you know it's controversy
marketing but you know conservatives
what can you do
um yeah
so ready ready to cringe
oh my are we are you ready for this
do you seriously want to do this do you
want me to [ __ ]
do you seriously want me to look at the
comments
I really don't want to look at the
comments you know
I think this is a very bad idea
because if you look at the comments
under this
not at all larpy [ __ ]
video
we're getting close oh yeah the Fortuna
USANA
um
[Music]
we're getting close oh no oh no it's the
license this section already
oh no
oh no there's no turning back now
paint comment doesn't count
Devil's vote from Central Europe Central
Europe Germany got these meetings oh I
mean of course you know it's a bunch of
like far right [ __ ] or like before
I'd oriented you know either like 12
year olds or like forehead oriented
Boomers up down here next one
I am Orthodox but this is epic
Christians Assemble
I I get
dude I wish I had this little
self-awareness as these [ __ ] people
my life would be much much happier
deals vote from the Far Eastern
Christians Philippines Viva cristore all
caps
like see see this is what I mean like
this this is like a [ __ ]
so I view these comments as
hooking up a chimpanzees balls to a car
battery
so
or like a chimpanzee doing it for itself
right so it does it like it like starts
like you know chimping out and
electrocuting itself gets really you
know like revved up like engine just
like or actually you know a better a
better um better example would be like
this is like giving a chimpanzee
methamphetamines like a chimpanzee
dosing itself some methamphetamines
right and then they come in and it's
like or actually it's okay so example
from the beginning because I'm getting
coming up with better examples a
chimpanzee you drugging a chimpanzee
with amphetamines because then the
chimpanzee and then you see the poor
animal going like
like all over the place screaming
trashing around mostly screaming crying
all over the place and that's the
equivalent of this like just like these
lack self-control lacking [ __ ]
Boomers and like these people who I'm
sure have very balanced and Healthy
Lifestyles
and like very well-going lives like
screaming in the comments with like gaps
like uh
from Iraq the Lord Jesus Is With Us well
okay I reck is gonna pass
oh no no no no dios vote from Poland to
my brothers and sisters in faith all
over the world be proud about how you
are and never be ashamed of Jesus
okay so Poland is like the Poland is
perhaps the worst
the worst advertising for Christianity
that is like this [ __ ] if you if you
have a miscarriage in Poland or like if
your life is threatened by like I don't
know like a mall from fetus or something
you're dead because Poland is I don't
know yeah more more caps lock
but this person really like they
formatted it properly
uh [ __ ] deals Vault those fault means
god is exalted as far as I know that was
the Battle Cry of uh battle
conservatives yeah today is the belgrave
conservatives I was gonna say
but like it this was the Battle Cry of
Crusaders as far as Anna going into
battle and they did do like massacres
and genocides and stuff
yeah so when you see people doing the
Devils deals full [ __ ] if they do it
ironically okay that's one thing but
unironically that person is just like a
Nazi
some Reds uh I I'm I'm I'm not I don't
feel Mr Stark I'm not feeling too well
but dead I'm a heretic it doesn't matter
defend the hole in arrogance you can go
either way
a bunch of Filipinos I guess what what
the [ __ ] is up with these like deals
from Germany it's not even like such a
Christian Nation I guess
Vault yeah I mean this is like this like
Christian LARP I don't know
yeah it's like this Nick Adams Gulliver
[ __ ]
I'm sorry Nick Adams alpha male you know
type people
uh yeah I don't want to miss this super
where can I trade my man card for M M's
yeah well
just I don't know [ __ ]
uh we we believe in man card
abolitionism here so it's fine
uh you know you know if you seriously
think by the way if you're like this if
you're like this guy who sees the things
that you need a man card to be a man and
you keep and it can be a revoked from
you from not acting enough like a man
then chances are then you are by every
chance the biggest [ __ ] insecure
[ __ ] on the planet like I don't know
like the the last time I felt like this
by the way to tell people like yeah bro
yeah bro someone else from here bro I'm
gonna help her I'm a dominant male like
the last time I felt like that was when
I was like 14. when like hormones were
kicking and then I realized that like oh
wait like being confident is like it's
all about like just like chilling out
and like not not freaking out and
keeping my cool
good confidence is not [ __ ] like me
going around be like hey bro you're not
like doing the [ __ ] Andrew that is
the most most uh [ __ ] insecure
jackass there is like if you watch his
debate with Hassan
Hassan like just almost made him cry
basically like Hassan was like asking
him Hassan wasn't even even like leaning
into him and by the way I have no beef
with Hassan we're good as far as I'm
concerned so whatever there's no I don't
know ill will at least for me uh and uh
so Hassan just was like was like asking
questions and he took down his
headphones to like
like smoke cigar because like he got too
upset if there's a [ __ ] show but you
know at least at least the top G is now
in Romanian prison so
so yeah there's that
um
okay
uh yes we still have about like I don't
know like an hour until crowd shows up
okay what if we play Let's play some
games Okay so let's lean back relax and
let's survive some aftermath because
it's a good game or like it needs more
content but I think it's fine
I mean for that value
yeah and meanwhile I'm also going to be
as I'm playing I'm also going to be a
see I wouldn't want to I would [ __ ]
Paradox launcher like I don't know if
there is going to be like if my email
address shows up my personal email or
something so
uh yeah
anyway
yeah yeah let me adjust this yeah so in
the meantime by the way I'm going to
like my um
my oops not this my um chat is the chat
is open so feel free to send
so feel free to send
supers because I'm going to read them
confirm
let's do a normal game
yeah so Moon gone it's the ixian story
uh one second
injecting J5 175 dollars my main car was
lost so I compromised by becoming a
woman well that's you know outplayed
some backwards for the chest you're
playing
I realized yeah I also had a man card
but then realized that like
flaunting my man card at the age of 14
made me like made me made me look like
the biggest insecure [ __ ]
so I was I just like chilled out and was
like yeah okay instead I'm just gonna be
like you know confident and chill
so
let's go Max difficulty
constant catastrophes lent is dead
because it was very insufficient Berlin
survivors ideology
uh let's see
progress and Technology let's
trigger those Wasteland conservatives
yeah I think here you should start with
scavenger and scientist
and then
um
uh maybe I should actually no this is my
scavenger actually can do a [ __ ] load of
science so it's fine
so let's do a uh fighter
okay
okay
um
and
hmm oh this looks like a nice icon
yeah the colors don't really match each
other but whatever
and
continue calling a name
uh
and
okay
start
item something do you follow what if
I'll test oh God that dude
I wish I didn't know who that was
but I do know who that is what a fault
is huge like if you look at what he
thought his his Mr Dunning Krueger
like his [ __ ]
the person who
a good night Jack ninja uh he's a person
who
is so incomprehensively stupid
and
yet so [ __ ] sure about their own
right
so it's like they're so [ __ ] certain
that they're Jesus
cats performing like you know parachute
drops next to me uh so waterfall test is
such a guy that who like thinks he knows
a lot
he thinks he's a very smart guy but like
it's all done in Kruger he's actually
goober
um
so basically what he felt his
yeah you know it's also like a kind of a
Neo-Nazi like at least his uh it might
sound like might sound like exaggeration
but like his entire stick is that like
you know
Western degeneracy is causing to us to
fall as a civilization and then
and then [ __ ] I don't know women
hypergam is this just the same it's the
exact same
uh is the the exact same rather it gets
like any Neo-Nazi so and when you're
like when you're indistinguishable
when you're indistinguishable from a
Neo-Nazi then you probably are one right
like I know like I don't want to be
throwing out and throwing this term
around like oh naughty naughty naughty
but like if you believe in like
degeneracy like Western degeneracy women
becoming [ __ ] and [ __ ] and ruining
society and then so and the great
replacement which is why genocide you
know like you know what can I say at
that point uh Keys 10 pounds thank you
very much please let me back into the EU
I never voted for this well your
opportunity might be coming just vote
for labor
I mean if you actually if you vote labor
I mean
they might just get you back to the EU
who knows
no I would like to but at that point uh
if Britain comes back to the [ __ ] EU
then nothing personal kid you know at
that point it's like uh yeah just just
you're gonna adopt the Euro you're gonna
you're not gonna have any
uh any special treatment you know
that's it
he believes in ebola's hard time creates
hardened me yeah um yeah yeah uh that's
that's what he followed his yeah
one second
waterfall test
yeah
um
so what I told you about like being Mr
Donny Krueger is it done in Kruger I
think so
yeah the dunning-kruger effect is you
know the the least the less you know
about something the more confident you
are this is what if I'll test
he is Mr Dunning Kruger
this dude thinks he he like he shits the
sun right or he eats the Sun
I I don't know I'm trying to like
convert this little Eastern European
saying into English but like he thinks
he's you know he he for he kind of
[ __ ] figure it out dude and you
listen to his videos and he's just like
it's like it's complete gibberish it's
complete [ __ ] horseshit
and uh yeah and here is also like he's
also um
uh you know
perpetuating
essentially new Nazi talking points
about Western degeneracy so there's that
how about go figure like people like
that are
all right
that was Hungary and I told the
Hungarian that I don't speak Hungarian
unfortunately I wish I did uh what if
artist also really loves turkey for some
reason I don't know well
uh Ray VB do you like aircrafts
sure I mean they're nice but I prefer
terrestrial transportation
uh I went I took an airplane once to
Sicily and it was [ __ ]
you know there's like a Ryanair you know
[ __ ] animal transport you just go in
and be like oh did I miss a super just
go in and be like be like uh
yeah so
20 of you sitting this one row and 10
centimeter wide chairs good luck [ __ ]
you
if you wish to breathe more than once
per second that'll be 10.99 please
but I guess they'll just they'll take
you that cheap and that's the only thing
about it
yeah event plus like it's even more
insulting if you
oh I should probably get some food going
uh
um it's even more frustrating if you
build if you when you think about it
it's like under under you
underneath you there is like a
there's like a like this this
which is a
very good service
and that's the high-speed train Italian
high speed train and you're stuck in
this shitty [ __ ] gold crowded loud
uh aluminum tube in the air when you
could just be like taking a train but
it's not possible to take a train from
from uh
you know Germany to Sicily yet and the
you would need the brand air pass tunnel
and that's not getting done for like 10
more years
yeah Ryanair sucks I don't know I mean
it sucks in the sense that like
it sucks but it's supposed to suck right
so like yeah like don't don't go in
expecting [ __ ]
you know presidential suite or something
you know what's up with airline food
yeah this is big like this is a medium
at this point like this big you know
like what's to deal with airline food
this like stand-up routine
anyway
huh
actually I should talk about uh I should
also talk about uh what you're talking
about well we we brought up [ __ ]
waterfall tests so I mean people like
him
uh I think he's just genuinely stupid
like he he's not like and of course I'm
being rude and being insulted but like
being insulting to him but like he's his
this is surviving the aftermath
um so what if what if all tastes like I
I don't know what a dude he might be
like a nice dude lie about like this
live is what I mean but like the [ __ ]
he's up to online is just inexcusable
like
spreading Nazi propaganda is like a bad
thing in my book and there is quasi Nazi
propaganda as I said because [ __ ] I mean
you know what do you call the propaganda
that tells you that women are becoming
[ __ ] and Western Civilization is
collapsing and the brown hordes
and the brown hordes are coming to I
would breeders like yeah that's it yeah
of course
anyway
um
and um
my my problem though is that like
recently there's been this discourse on
the left about like leftist Role Models
leftist male role models to be precise
[ __ ] asteroids and um yeah it's
actually true quite true
that uh
that there is no good leftist Role
Models out there at least not not like
popular ones there are some they're good
ones
there are there are no good ones in
terms of popularity so you might
uh someone might uh
come up with some good Solutions you
know someone left this someone might
give good advice to guys but they would
never get popular because
they don't have that umph uh that for
example Jordan Peterson uh has
like if you ever have you ever found
this strange that like oh there it is
have you ever found it strange that like
the two
big oh
the two big
the two big male role models online
are
Jordan Peterson
or Jordan Peterson and Andrew Tate
so that's pretty [ __ ]
um and that's because there's no better
alternative like the the reason why
Jordan Peterson uh
was able to sucker in so many young guys
is because there was no alternative
right like who else there was this huge
that means if these idiots could get
popular that means there was this huge
wide open market
just wide open market for for uh
for uh
oops
uh this wide open market for this
self-help advice like this advice for
guys
which
um yeah through there
which wasn't capitalized on by anyone
else but demagogues and so we have
Andrew Tate and we have [ __ ] Jordan
Peterson and I genuinely think that's
and that's that's like a pretty big
issue
do you consider shoe on it to be
announcing now
and she's all over the place she's like
irresponsible in terms of in terms of
like uh you know or how she uses her
platform and whatever when criticized as
far as I know she just like defaults to
like
well no you [ __ ] you whatever oh the
left is being mean Etc
and with that she provides a huge Boon
to conservatives
uh because now conservatives can be like
hey look the the girl is on our side now
and you know
it's uh it's pretty embarrassing anyway
yeah she should just like you know calm
down
um otherwise yeah so what was I saying
yeah so I'm also scrolling through chair
yeah so
do you play FPS games yeah yeah I play
like you know Half-Life series like
black Mesa I'm doing now Etc
um so
when it comes to mail advice to males of
course urban planning would solve a lot
of issues right if you had like social
spaces
uh you know this is America mostly if
you had like proper social spaces where
people can meet then relationships can
happen uh that would go a long way but
uh instead we have
these like solar suburbs which isolate
people which are the which allows mental
health issues to Fester
yeah etc etc we all know that that one
that will
and um then it comes these demagogues
and be like hey
actually
do you know your your do you know do you
know you have a bunch of problems like
loneliness and you know you're not
really
feeling like a valued person and
whatever
you know some people say it's because
it's because of late stage capitalism
and the faulty urban planning and
whatever well I'm here to tell you well
I should do it in my Jordan Peterson
verse well I'm here to tell you
I'm here to tell you that uh actually
it is it is because the walk degenerates
hyper female hypergamy woke woke black
people kissing on TV uh
what's your opinions I'm crying you know
like this is Jordan Peterson bit
yeah herediv heard of Paul Joseph Watson
from Ray V2 Buzz thank you yeah I mean
pajama Watson is like
I mean his his pizza meme at this point
like uh he's been talking about the the
exact same things since 2015 you know no
no
uh change whatsoever
and um
he's still like this this
triggered
you know gamer bro it's engineer like
now he's a culture Warrior he's also
pretty much like uh I mean once again
like I hate throwing around terms like
you know oh he's a Nazi he's a he's a
Nazi Nazi not
swastika no no no I don't like doing
that but like
when someone believes
when someone believes
that
what I said you know that like you know
brown people are here to genocide white
people and Western degeneracy and the
hypergamia women and like if you believe
the exact same thing as them then then
like what am I supposed to say to you
right
anyway uh yeah so in all Role Models
um and which actually
ah I could give some advice because I
know some
like
you know in terms of social skills like
I'm I'm not talking about like self-help
[ __ ] like you know oh uh
download this app and did you tilt your
head in a 12 degree angle because like
no that's like stupid the stupid [ __ ]
but um
uh I would say
how to be confident for example if you
ask
a person how to be confident if you ask
a right-wing demagogue hey how do I act
confident then
he writing demographic will give you an
answer of like ah yes well you see you
have to you have to discipline the woman
you have to find something wrong with
them and then you just get the [ __ ]
Andrew the top G actually now the the
bottom G response
you get the bottom G response uh you
just start to talk down to her bro just
be an [ __ ] because I mean this is the
experience that many people have in high
school right that like your first high
school high school experience with girls
as a guy now I'm talking about like male
to female
your first experience with guys with
girls rather as a guy is that the
[ __ ] are successful and
um
and uh guys you know if you're nice if
you're respectful Etc then you don't
have any success and so this is a half
truth there is uh this has to be
explained though why this happens it's
not because it's not what you think it
happens but then these demographics can
come in and be like huh
actually it's because you have to be an
[ __ ] and then you have like top G top
G you know the Android types
uh it's a it's a full-on like [ __ ]
brain rot but um
but um
see the issue here is that uh
so okay that I'm going to explain to you
okay so what happens when you're in high
school and you're nice to a girl and
there's another guy who's an [ __ ] to
a girl
and the what would you look at that the
[ __ ] gets the girl what happens then
why did that happen did it happen
because you were nice to girl no it's
nice to be nice to people
um but the problem is
the [ __ ] had something that you don't
and that is
well the the emulation that he emulated
confidence so people like confident
people uh this is everyone like people
and like only very insecure people don't
like confident people men like confident
women women like confident men
confidence is universal next to
Universal attractive now an [ __ ]
an [ __ ] emulates confidence by being
like
you know
um at least that of course that's
obviously not confidence but we're
talking about like teenagers with like
brain broken from hormones right so to
them it looks like it looks like uh
confidence and also the it what really
helps is is if you don't
chase after people so the [ __ ] is
attractive because he doesn't run after
the girl right the nice guy is always
[ __ ] there right the the the the the
the phone pings at midnight well it's
the [ __ ] nice guy writing like going
in with another red hot unsolicited
[ __ ] message about something
unrelated very clearly just trying to
just trying to get near in this case the
girl like to get to talk to her because
you're very clearly likes her okay
but this this is actually not you know
you're not signaling really that you're
that you're worth talking to really
because like
because uh you know
should be uh self-evident that if
that uh you know if you're desperate
like desperation and really just like
borderline harassment doesn't really
it's not really attractive so
what am I where am I getting with this
um
the [ __ ] is
challenging because the girl has to you
know the girl has to get his attention
right I'm I'm not saying like guys
should be like ignoring women on purpose
or something that's that's stupid that's
the Android [ __ ] but like that's but
that's that's the dynamic that if you
make yourself scarce a bit more scarce
than usual if the other person has to
just you know so if you don't throw
yourself at the other person but the
other person has to reach out to you to
talk to you
that's great then that's that's exciting
um at least more exciting than if the
other person threw their dicks at you
and um
yeah um and so the reason why the
biggest reason why I think the nice guy
is not attractive is because the nice
guy is [ __ ] boring right as I said in
my video about in The Meadows fair right
so if you're boring you're not getting
laid no one likes being around you
because you're [ __ ] boring I mean
this is tautology this is this is
[ __ ] obvious and
so the [ __ ] emulates this being
challenging Ergo he's not boring and
also he's he's emulating confidence
right and the fact that he's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] to the girl that doesn't matter
like that's that's uh that's irrelevant
and
um you actually shouldn't do that
because that's actually bad for you and
um
I should build a water storage thing
actually and uh yeah that's that's not
attractive and people think like these
[ __ ] like Andrew Andrew Tate think
that what's attractive is when you when
you are an [ __ ] no that's that's
being an [ __ ] is just like it's just
you know it's irrelevant it's actually
it actually doesn't help your case at
all
so what should you do well stop chasing
after people and just like
um let people come to you I would say
phone number is a great thing like if
you're in high school or something or
after high school if you're young adult
frustrated just like what you need to do
is
go to places meet people
uh
and uh you know if you see someone you
like I think the easiest way is to like
just get the phone number because phone
number is personal like of course you
could be like hey what's your Facebook
or what's your social media but like
phone number is quite personal so when a
person and if they don't like you
they're not gonna give it to you
whatever and then you can then use the
phone and then
the invite them out on dates Etc it's a
whole thing actually I might actually
write all this down I don't want to get
into it too deep now because I mean
disjointed this might not make sense to
most people
uh okay it's kind of the [ __ ] phone
uh but anyway
the whole point is I think I'm gonna I
think I'm gonna type this out uh all of
it so to help guys
mostly guys but it goes all goes every
direction basically yeah this advice
misogynistic and I don't like Andrew did
either but I don't agree with your take
to LOL it is too subjective and people
are too complicated yes but but there
are
yes I know but there are Universal
traits that people like right or at
least Universal trade like traits that
most people the vast majority of people
will will respond to positively like
being confident and not being confident
while not being a dick about it is is
something that most people will like
right
um
obviously and unless they're like an
insecure jackass
um and um
yeah and politeness is also preferred by
people right uh and excitement like oh
my God like think about
if there are any post high school or
even high school age males in the
audience
think about why you got so excited when
Stacy like what about Stacy of course
you found them hot whatever but was she
like was the person you were excited
about rip
it was the person you were excited about
all over you were they crawling all over
you bombarding you with text Etc no you
had to do that right it's it was you you
had to reach out to them you had to you
know
uh initiate everything and they were
pulling away from you in a sense and you
were pushing closer and this is exciting
because this this is psychology right I
mean this
essentially raises the value of the
other person in your head or something
like that so
um
right so if the if Stacy just comes up
to me like take me you're like what okay
nice but okay interesting you know
that's going to be your
uh I think I'm gonna [ __ ] die Jesus
Christ
that's going to be your reaction making
yourself scarce really helps not
ghosting people but just just chilling
and
not being in another person's face you
know
the unknown you know it's the appeal of
the unknown right you know who do you
know she loves me she loves me now does
she like me does she did not like me
when you think about this you know when
you keep like ah does this person like
me oh God they haven't they haven't they
haven't texted back yet Jesus what's
going on do they like me do they forget
about me did they hate me you know when
you think like that
about the person you like then
you know it's going to be
it's going to excite you bump you up Etc
and that's how this sort of Attraction
works and this is this is what the this
is the [ __ ] Dynamic right so the girl
is thinking you know I got this i got
this dumbass nice guy chasing me you
know uh sending me 80 [ __ ] thousand
messages per second okay fine and you
and she opens up her [ __ ] WhatsApp
and it's like uh [ __ ] it's it's it's
it's it's another [ __ ] essay from the
dude it's like oh [ __ ] and uh
instead there's the other guy the whom
whom she also is it who she is attracted
to and that guy's like oh my God he he
didn't text me like what what's what's
going on you know why why not does she
did I say something wrong last time a
minute but like you know and the more
you think about this the more you
the more you um
the more you
um
the more you get pumped up about the
person the more you get attracted
anyway this is the this is the uh this
is the dynamic I'm talking about
so that's that's the SL Dynamic and this
is what idiots like Andrew Tate and all
these [ __ ] life gurus and whatever
completely misunderstand
and think it's it's thinking they think
the attractive part is the being [ __ ]
part now anyway this this was Adam
something dating Guru for you
anyway
yeah uh it also helps that you don't
look desperate yeah not looking
desperate really
actually I mean anyway I'm gonna type
all this [ __ ] out and then you're
going to
be able to enjoy it
uh you're gonna you're gonna be able to
you know read it Etc and decide for
yourself
how but I think it's generally helpful
because it puts you into like the right
mindset
uh of you know
and it explains perhaps and it explains
like I think what I figured out kind of
explains the the Dynamics of romantic
attraction pretty well
so I know
um
Adamson have you heard about the game
workers and resources Soviet Republic
yes I've heard about the game work
because the results of traffic I have it
I haven't gotten into it yet because of
reasons but otherwise
uh oh no my colony
I'm getting wrecked
um no um
yeah I I played it I need to get more
into it because it's like a more
complicated or at least it's not so
intuitive
uh and I didn't have the time yet
what's up what's up what's up with all
these [ __ ] radiations or whatever
uh let's see
yeah the plastic Miner is in the
Hospital
yeah yeah men can sense desperation too
yeah like imagine like you are Imagine
like you you have no like like you you
you got laid right uh imagine that for
some it'll be harder than others I
imagine but
um
so if you're like well adjusting you you
if you if you had relationship
relationships before you know whatever
it's nothing new to you is what I'm
saying and then there's and then the
girl really starts coming after you and
you sense their desperation that's a
turn off like that's that's uh if
something's coming someone's coming up
to you desperately
even as a guy that's just like why it's
just like just uh you know it's like
this you know you what what okay well
that's weird so that's the that's the uh
that's the energy I'm talking about
desperation and really
being overbearing with your presence
really really doesn't help your case is
what I'm saying
let's see
wolf-like beings okay distract them with
food
35 [ __ ] fuel oh God
anyway yeah um
thank you I know I now know what went
wrong with my previous relationship yeah
um
look in relationships if you're together
with someone
um like spoiler I am I'm not single very
I'm very much not single anymore
um
and um so the thing about that is the
thing about relationships you have to
maintain the relationship you know
romantic love is not
unconditional right so like a mother
loves her child no matter what that
child can go and [ __ ] mow down
mow down some people in the street
doesn't matter the mother will like we
love her child
but in relationships is actually
conditional if you [ __ ] up too much then
the other person will get tired of you
yeah I mean if you ever dumped a person
why did you dump them well because you
had you got tired of them you because
you were because they were [ __ ] up
you know
annoyances
got to got too much uh
etc etc
and um when you're in a relationship
actually the best thing you can do is
well okay don't first off don't stop
dating
uh if you are if you got together
through dates you have to continue those
dates into your relationship even even
through marriage because dates are these
you know lights
opportunities really enjoyable like when
you spend quality time together now many
people stop spending quality time with
each other once they once they get into
a relationship or married and you know
the meme of like you know the husband is
just like it's on the couch goping down
on beer with a [ __ ] beer belly like
burping and [ __ ] and uh the wife is in
the back like what the [ __ ] did I marry
well because your husband but the
husband probably didn't sit around the
couch and burp all day long when they
first met right
and what a shock when they first met the
woman liked the man but now that he's
like [ __ ] like going like you know on
the couch
now she doesn't like him wow what
happened yeah like we [ __ ] stop he's
[ __ ] stop putting in effort that's
what happened
so in relationships
don't be in each other's faces for 24 7.
I once worked at this place where the
where the where two my two of my
employees were together like they were
like boyfriend girlfriend
and uh they worked at the same place and
they lived at the same place holy [ __ ]
like I could not do that like uh
they were they spent every waking hour
together pretty much and
yeah that's that's actually not a good
thing like people intuitively think oh
yeah I love the other person I want to
spend time with them nah yeah Yes Yes
actually uh spend time with them but
don't spend too much time with them
Cabin Fever is real and it can kill
relationships
um yeah
because your everyone has little
Annoying habits and those annoying
habits will pile up eventually
uh if you let them do much you have to
of course counterbalance them either
like you have to keep them low you have
to get a hold of yourself obviously for
example if the other person hates if you
like burping loudly and their person the
other person hates it you probably
shouldn't do it in front of them and
should exercise some self-control
uh
and it's also it also helps if you
make a conscious effort to not expose
yourself
to the other person's annoying habits
right
so if there's a place where you know
like if they you know if they are
together with their friends and with
their friends they like
screaming around and with their phones
and whatever and you hate that well then
don't go don't go there you know just
like go do something else
right uh
it's it's really that simple uh and yeah
the the main takeaway I think is just
like just don't stop dating just
different relationship like once or
twice like at once every one or two
weeks
go out somewhere okay just dress up
nicely and spend quality time with each
other don't let it be just
inhabiting the same house okay because
that's that's where relationships die
this applies even in marriage
uh
don't don't become don't become
roommates is what I'm saying okay don't
become roommates when you're together
with someone
be a remain a romantic couple as you
always were
that's how relationships die
people become roommates annoying habits
pile up that's it and then eventually
one person uh has enough and the reason
why the reason why actually there's
actually a big meme in like the the the
the the the alpha male community that um
women are heartless and hypergamous and
whatever that you know uh because when I
when a girl when a girl breaks breaks up
with you you know your heart is broken
but like she has the next guy the next
day and it's like well yeah
well that's not because women are
heartless no that just become that just
happens when the other person uh is has
been gradually checking out of the
relationship you know yay I got the gate
when the other person gradually is
checking out of the relationship right
so they're like
they're like um
uh
this is not really working
you know and
um
this their feelings will sink
uh real nose dive but like slowly
slower and slower and slower and then
they they they're not in they're nothing
not not as enthusiastic about you as
they used to be they're not really
kissing you as much they're not really
you know they're more they have lower
energy when it comes to you and more
bored so when this happens like these
signs can be seen that means that means
the other person is getting turned off
by something gradually and gradually is
the key word this happens gradually
um
and at and at some point you get to the
point where okay the other person has
had enough of you
and they are ready to move on and
chances are you don't know that they are
ready to move on because you you're just
you just don't care right like your
senses your social senses are not
developed enough
and you'll end up in a situation where
the other person has been contemplating
moving on
for
months possibly
and when they get to the point because
like with you together if you move
together whatever that means they're
also comfortable because
you live together you got things figured
out whatever like you don't want to
leave your comfort zone but by the time
they they get to the point where they're
ready to leave their comfort zone
they're going to have at that point
they're fully done they're they've made
up their minds
they couldn't they just don't care about
you at that point and so well of course
well the the the next day like you know
they have their they have the
replacement lined up because they just
don't care
um and it's okay like if you were in
their place you wouldn't care either and
it's perfectly okay
just you know don't turn them off that's
it
uh yeah and that's that's why
relationships end like this like this is
how I like a 20-year marriage can like
like end like this and like a week later
the wife already has like a new
boyfriend lined up so this is how it
happens this these develop over time the
other person is like seething on it
contemplating bargaining ins inside and
Etc et cetera and then look it just gone
so did the other person maintain the
relationship
don't take the other person for granted
and puts in the same effort to the
relationship
as you did
when you first met if you do this
chances are you'll be fine
I should yet I should get paid for this
holy [ __ ] well I guess I'm I'm
technically I'm
I'm technically I am getting paid
because it's a stream so anyway
anyway is um
this doesn't sound like signal male
thinking yeah
Sigma males or guys who
have enough self-worth to not call
themselves Alphas but they aren't
delusional enough to call themselves
to call themselves that so
they're like okay I I don't I don't I
don't want to call myself a beta male
because I have self-respect
but I'm also don't know but I'm also
obviously not an alpha male
so oh oh there we go Sigma male got it
oops sorry it's the phone
it's like yeah that's and that's her
signal meals come from yeah this Sigma
grind set
if you don't mind saying where roughly
do you live in Germany I'm from
Stuttgart South
um oh yeah I live in what the f oh my
[ __ ] god
uh I live in uh
I live in a leiptech one second I need
to purge these bugs
I live in Leipzig so it's in Jackson the
cultural epicenter of Germany
it's a nice place and I'd like to use a
very nice place just like I don't know
the area is a bit like you know
a bunch of like Nazi Boomers Etc it's
weird
it's rough out here
I was once called a sigma Mill for not
using Tick Tock yeah I mean
defeat [ __ ] you uh
yeah um
I mean Sigma male is like it's like it's
like kind of like an ironic thing at
this point so
yeah but I mean I mean the original like
these like these waterfall test caliber
dudes making the First videos of like
what is a sigma male well you know it's
like that was the real deal back then
anyway
what's your biggest criticism of Germany
um
well uh
card payments
forget the [ __ ] EC card seriously
there's this German card which only
works in Germany and if you have an if
you have a normal debit card it doesn't
work
plus Germany is like very very
cash oriented
also the fact that you cannot do any
[ __ ] bureaucracy like online you have
to go show up in person everywhere it's
also annoying but otherwise it's fine I
think
the name of the game is
uh the name of the game is uh surviving
the aftermath um actually yeah my voice
is a bit going out so I'm gonna
stock closer to them I can talk about
calmer
uh
do you know not just bikes uh yeah not
just bikes is going to be on the Stream
in about an hour and a half he's gonna
be calling again
so yeah yeah we met in Amsterdam it was
it was a fun time we biked around the
city we actually met twice in Amsterdam
once we uh once we biked around together
and once we went to this like
super super Swanky [ __ ] like drinking
place it was super cool oh I should
probably spend my research points as
well
we went to this like super high tier
[ __ ] Pub which was very nice but like
I don't know it's the kind of place
where you give the way to like a 20 Euro
tip
uh but you know everyone they were super
nice there
uh have you ever been to rostock no what
is your opinion on
yeah is the city that uh that uh
luceroth is the city that that God that
is being demolished currently in German
it's like a teeny tiny place but like
it's being demolished because there's
like a big open pit late night mine next
to it and they have to expand it
see this is what happens when you close
the nuclear power plants and you
suffocate your green energy sector in
bureaucracy
so that's not very much that's a cringe
move not Sigma
what is a drinking orange juice uh yeah
I mean it's a village it's like a couple
people couple houses like it's not not
like at the end of the world but it
still sucks
whatever I don't use tick tock it's just
like a souped-up [ __ ] Snapchat
do you have a job better than YouTube no
I do this full time now
anyway
I'm looking for a few by the way if you
were to ask me now I'm looking at the
chat if you want to talk about anything
if it is throw it in
um
let's see how do you feel about
waterfall test have I answered this
anyway what if all this
yeah far right dude you know believes in
Western generously whatever
done in Kruger thinks it thinks he's
smart has budget insane opinions like if
you it's particularly painful to listen
to him about Europe like because I
actually know European history better
than the average American or maybe it's
Canadian I don't know
yeah it's stick don't don't listen to
him for any reason other than to laugh
please because you're gonna be sucked
down some kind of like weird ass [ __ ]
bizarre alt right spirit science rabbit
hole and that would be very unepic
known known not Sigma move
do you plan on streaming more and we'll
see my rate of videos will go back to
like one or two videos maximum per month
because I don't want to burn out and you
know
I got other stuff also going on but uh
yeah otherwise
um I might buy my stream all right I I
like it I don't uh
I don't I don't uh dispose of the idea
quite quite like that
you know
all right I don't know what British
people would say
tools
they're so close
uh what is your opinion on Boom
supersonic of
heard of them they're like wait aren't
they the company that is doing the
[ __ ]
uh
are they the one who are doing the
[ __ ] the new
all right
like the supersonic plane with the
[ __ ]
I don't know like we'll see what comes
up comes out of it I think supersonic
plane travel is stupid
because of Sonic booms or whatever it's
just like it's just like I mean if you
figure out a supersonic plane
which
again not do the sonic boom then it I
guess it'll get better but like I don't
I don't don't specialize in flying
really I don't I don't much I don't know
much about it
nor do I claim to
do you think we can win back to Chain
Bridge yeah I mean I think so in
Budapest there is this
uh there's this movement now
which is like
which is like um
uh basically
so basically the Chain Bridge was
renovated and there was this discussion
now if cars should be let back on the
Chain Bridge because now it's only
scooters essential Services buses and
bikes and no cars it was pretty [ __ ]
ridiculous by the way that like one of
Budapest icons is used as like a
two-lane through fair for no reason you
know it's just two lanes
foreign
yeah keep voting for
keep voting for the current mayor in
Budapest and the Chain Bridge will I
think stay like that
aka Mr Christmas
that's literally his surname Christmas
uh
see
I'm good okay
um
do you like Deutsche ban
do you really want to pick a fight with
me
no Deutsche ban is
ranges from decent to disappointing
so the d stands either for decent or for
disappointing depending on the day
and uh
actually I can no I think my voice is
now sufficiently like
damaged
maybe I can do the German train
announcer voice the
um
my throat is too [ __ ] for it but
anyway
operates a massive [ __ ] system like
it's massive
uh it's even bigger like it's they
operate actually a more complex Network
than like a more frequented Network than
the the Netherlands
who themselves have a pretty big system
actually but uh it's so huge and it's so
overloaded
and it's so under it's relative to
relatively
relatively uh underfunded right
well this game is about uh someone asked
about this game's about this is like a
wasteland survival Sim colonism and so
Deutsche Bank the problem with Deutsche
ban is that uh
they were relatively underfunded this
over bureaucratized
mess they do move a lot of people and
they do have some impressive uh
infrastructure and infra impressive
Rolling Stock but they need to be better
organized because
like what was like half of all
high-speed trains were [ __ ] accurate
like or punctual
um I think what like last
month
which is like a record low uh or close
to record low at least
this [ __ ] dog [ __ ] and um
but they they do move a [ __ ] ton of
people and they plan to I think double
passenger account by I think 20 30 or 20
40. so it's some insane growth I think
last year it was like uh every two weeks
they got like a new ice train from the
factory and they're like pushing it into
service
um
yeah
but like they're they're not as well
they're not so well funded plus
debianettes the the the uh the uh up the
track operator of Germany I think they
they have an obligation to make money so
and that because or like to be
profitable and uh since maintaining and
upgrading the infrastructure is very
expensive well how are they gonna make
profit well they're gonna charge more
for track usage and they're charging
Deutsche ban for the debate passenger
segment for for track usage and so the
ticket is more expensive you know it's
it's as far as I know at least I
I admit I haven't really delved that
deeply into financing uh on the German
rail but
that's the general idea
anyway
it sounds like Germany needs deep to
deep recordize itself it starts
undermining your improvement yeah I mean
Germany is very bureaucratized in
general but like uh yeah I mean someone
needs to do something about it probably
but I mean in Germany there's also this
like you're like yeah why why change
something it would work it's you know it
always been like that oh you know
or other I should do like although I do
want to change things out it's
everything works perfectly well it you
know and it sucks but like it it also
always been like those you know I'm
trying to emulate this like Countryside
German Boomer accent
[Music]
instead of thing
what's your opinion of Flemish land
usage and suburbia along highways
you mean Flemish you land usage and
Flemish Suburbia along highways
I mean Suburbia sucks a long a longer
Highway double sucks but like
yeah
um yeah like I do know that like Belgium
is a problem with like Construction in
general and like uh
uh zoning
it's not their strong suit
and uh yeah but that's that's but
Belgium is like a uniquely dysfunctional
country so
you know I think it's because of the two
big camps oh I should speaking of I
should build a logging camp
speaking of
logging camps
there are two Belgian camps
[Music]
that's an ambulance like a German name
it is
um
so the thing is you know
there are two camps in Belgium as far as
I know the Flemish and the other you
know the French speaking and the Dutch
speaking as far as I know at least I
could be wrong
and it's very very hard to reach
consensus is because you know
dear camps in fighting whatever
last year 22 was the most unpunctual
year with only 44 percent
of trains on time this is
yeah
I mean you know just one thing to have a
nice big system but you've also sent to
fund it or organize it
anyway
I know something do you think that
private train companies could make
European rails better like yeah I mean
regularjet is fine I like them
they're cheap a reasonably good service
though they're they're like the big
regular jet secret is like them using
all the decommissioned Austrian Euro
City cars uh because Austria is of
course of course buying the real Jets so
the private companies
private companies can like feel niches I
guess
and that's good but I don't think
they're gonna revolutionize anything
Flix train is good for example I took
flick strain to to when I went to
Amsterdam like part like part partly on
the way I think to do is work
and um
yeah like in like in Europe uh in Europe
private rail is financed in a way that
uh
let's see so private rail is not like in
the US where it's like just balls to the
wall here we go have fun this is your
track good luck but throughout all these
state orders uh like the straight the
state owns the tracks obviously and then
there is a there is a uh
there's a general
uh idea of like okay we want this
schedule
we have this schedule so we want we want
this service here so who can provide it
and so someone comes up and be like hey
I have I'm a regular jet I have a bunch
of trains this is
what uh this this is the price I I uh I
want you to pay me for X well for one
passenger kilometer and so I don't know
like so they say like four Euros
this is for example in the Czech
Republic but there's like pretty high
competition and then come zero check
Railway is like hey I'm I'm Czech
Railways and I'm going to
um
you know also I also want to run on this
track I'm going I'm going to offer 3
Euro 50 for one passenger kilometer well
like the state will have to pay that to
them and so regular is like regulator is
like okay so we we're gonna go low three
Euros we can do this and then you know
they win the bid so there's like this
company is bidding and then one wins the
contract of course then then there's
also like there's schedule requirements
capacity requirements and Rolling Stock
requirements although you you can just
show up with like a [ __ ]
some like pieces of [ __ ] like you know
tin cans from 1950.
for example in Czech Republic a big
a big requirement by the regions who
ordered the local train traffic was that
um the carrier who operates there in
this case the Czech National Railways
they have to have new Rolling Stock
there
should the EU ban cars hell yeah
oh and something I want to talk about oh
[ __ ] dude now I'm this is going to ruin
my day
it's this [ __ ] thing so hungarians
recognize this
as the Hungarian IC Plus
this is a new Euro City or Intercity
train depending on right this is a new
build a new new builds have these Square
Windows
now this car is good
ish
but of course this is just a car so in
the hierarchy train travel uh you have
uh normal like a regular uh regular
trains the meaning uh
locomotive cars now with the other
things however uh the the next thing in
the pecking order is uh
let's see
that would be push-pull so there is a
control car at the end of the train that
would be the
that would be the
the
[ __ ] you
that would be the baby rail jet so
that's the real yeah this is the control
car and the locomotive is at the end and
the cores are permanently coupled
so yeah and the whole idea behind that
is that the train can go both ways when
the train reaches an end stop the
locomotive doesn't have to be you know
hooked up and then another locomotive
comes in pulls out the Train the
locomotive leaves out and then the train
gets put back in and the locomotive gets
hooked back and it's a pain in the ass
lots of time lots of money uh these
push-pull trains take care of that issue
because they can go both ways then come
the the the multiple units which are
uh well just that they're just like
they're your average multiplicity trains
that do not have locomotive they're just
like multiple units duh together now the
Hungarian Railways invested into these
[ __ ]
god-awful uh
uh Passenger cars for for and for all
the wrong reasons so but the Hungarian
Railway Railways had in mind like what
the CEO the state-owned company by the
way but for the director had in mind
was that um
basically uh
they are going to do a Hungarian maid
passenger car
okay but um they they but they didn't
have any any sort of concept of like how
it should look what it should be like no
we're just gonna like how we're gonna
use it no [ __ ] that we're gonna build
the IC plus this in the blue striped car
that I showed you we're gonna build that
[ __ ] thing and then that's going to
be the IC plus that's going to be at the
Hungarian domestic made passenger car
and then later we're gonna figure out
where the [ __ ] thing can run and what
we can use it for and which is you might
notice it's it's it's like sitting on
the horse backwards like in Australia it
was like uh in Austria what they did was
uh
they went and uh okay we want we want
this
service
so so this is our concept for our
service what stream would work best oh
real jet okay let's do the real jet and
instead we got the [ __ ] like in
Hungary it's like okay we got this car
what can we use it for and they're
horrible uh if actually if you're Czech
if you're checking you're taking the
Hungarian EC through the Czech Republic
be careful pay in Euros don't pay in
crowns
because it's a huge ripoff it's like 20
overpriced everything in a dining car
and in the Czech Republic magically the
card payment terminal stops working
because then they cannot scam you
and the cars themselves it's like a full
IC plus car uh train a Hungarian Airways
uh car and it's like in the cars like a
variety of things don't work the toilets
aren't kept in order uh passenger
information is usually broken
seats are like these horrible quality
pieces of [ __ ] you just like even worse
than on computer trains the Wi-Fi
doesn't work I know because I took a
train recently from from uh
Hungary all the way to Germany a direct
one and in the dining car they scam you
so uh yeah that's Hungarian Airways for
you so it's like completely [ __ ]
dysfunctional
and now they won't and the way they did
it by the way the way they uh they uh
did the whole IC plus project they for
they didn't hire people in addition so
the railway company's best quality
[ __ ] cars
which are weren't the IC plus they're
like older but like very high quality
Spanish
cars
uh the CAF cars they were just rotting
on the on these sidings because they
didn't have enough people
to [ __ ]
to [ __ ] keep the trains in order
to do to overhaul the cars because every
four years the car needs to go through
overhaul otherwise they cannot build it
on the tracks and instead of doing the
overhaul what they did was they they put
this [ __ ] IC plus task in the into
like onto the repair bases and they're
like or the one repair base and they
were like yeah yeah dude just good luck
good luck [ __ ] and
what happened was predictably the repair
facilities could not cope with the
yeah they were coping and seeding they
could not cope with the with the
workload and so these bra these really
high quality cars were just like rotting
on sightings for years
and decreasing in their efficiency
it's uh yeah it was a [ __ ] show
now they stopped the IC plus program for
this reason and the person was like
fired you know like I don't know 2020 I
think who was responsible for the
teleportion but they continued for a few
years because they already began yeah uh
questions I also don't want to ignore
you dear chatters
um what is the opinion driver restraints
with AI
and you see it is getting replaced uh
driverless trains yeah I mean in Europe
there's like a big lack of train drivers
uh in I think in Bavaria especially like
they bring in people from Serbia and
like and now they
um
yeah like it's it's sir it's all
serbians now and they had to actually
cancel some train lines and replace them
with buses because
uh
one second
okay
not just bikes
not just bikes is here or is going to be
here in 20 minutes he's gonna call in no
webcam
he's in the Bahamas currently
on summer vacation
well no but
no he's in he's in Narnia
uh
okay I'm going to call him
uh call him in 15 minutes approximately
okay good thing I good thing I checked
my my um
my Discord okay
so please Cheddars if I forget about it
kindly remind me oops
that was something
hmm
oh I see Adolf diddler got his message
redacted well I
I'm sure we're missing it
I'm streaming is fun but like dude like
I have to be careful with my voice
I've been talking straight for like five
hours straight at this point so
um
are you pleased that the UK agreed to
send Challenger 10 to Steel grade yeah I
am I'm very that pleases me that's very
nice
uh yeah I mean there's what how many
like 10 but still I mean it's better
than nothing it's it's good and it's
it's useful in like opening the
floodgates or other other
countries as well will not be shy
uh of sanding tanks
come on what what what do you mean you
mean need water what are your [ __ ]
beta
cannot survive without water
it's
surrounded by Sigma Sigma males in this
colony and sigma female
recently yes bunny murder had a big
sickness spikes with some lines and
services being discontinued yeah if if a
bunch of people go like fall sick
uh derail then there's no rail until the
people recover because there's no
Surplus
how do you think hungarians are going to
put up with orban's b as well we'll see
do you follow the check presidential
election yeah I do uh I think I think
probably I will win uh we did I
discussed it at the beginning of the
stream so
um okay
do you like using the German IC yeah I
mean ICS are nice like there's a new
promo of like the new Togo IC trains
like the ic4 something or some new brand
name uh those trains are not delivered
yet but they're very interesting and um
they're like probing like wow look at
the interior look at how nice it is
and it's like oh you know wow this
Exquisite whatever and it looks very
nice really
and then like the top government was
like wow I I cannot wait
I cannot wait to to be sitting on the
floor next to this Exquisite woodwork on
the easy I see
so
oh well
DB keep winning
what's your take on German setting their
biggest sport to China
Color Me surprised except I'm not
anyway we're gonna need another
Medical Institution
in La Colonia
here we go why am I switching to like
sassy bulletin person I don't know
oh yeah the ICL oh yeah wait I'm gonna
look for a picture of that yeah Nick
Adams alpha male
the ICL looks [ __ ] dope
or like the cars
uh they're like they're so small
it's like these little little small
smaller cars
um
here we go
this is a new ICL so this this is a car
and this is a car it's like you know
it's so fun to say small uh they are
indeed very small uh it's like
two cars are like one regular car's
length approximately but you know it's
fine
so as long as they work winter storm
[ __ ] yeah
America
okay um
yeah so the ICL is super awesome or is
going to be super awesome
um thank you for 50 Lira all numbered I
see Generations three five are the fast
ones even numbered I see Generations 2
for the slower ones
and yeah
kinda sorta
is there nice wait wait am I
okay with the ic5 is the new one okay
like the it's in um it's in uh in the
plans only yeah the IC E4 is the newest
one yeah I think the ic4 I think they
kind of dropped the ball with it a bit
because they can only they can only go I
think what 250 kilometers per and then
they were retrofitted into
uh 260 kilometers per hour which is
better than nothing
but ah they they should have gone for
high speed and plus they are only
German voltage capable
which is which sucks
um that means the trains cannot go
abroad
just only like Switzerland and Austria
maybe but not not to not to uh
not at all to any other countries so
yeah oh well I wait back to chat also I
can hear I can hear bike noises from the
distance still
but that that can only mean that not
just bikes is coming on in 10 minutes
you can hear the the clanking of the of
the frame and the and the clicking of
the of the chain
and the bicycle shows up red with blood
uh and I said do you have a spot for
steam locomotive like a lot of rare fans
yeah
and they're nice but they're like the
steam is the steam a couple of their
pain in the ass to maintain and and like
and like get to to get them like ready
for any like a
book a trip you know I prefer electric
uh though I do I do like a good steam
locomotive I mean there's
hey I mean I'm a sigma male yeah so of
course I like it
oh my [ __ ] God I'm I'm I'm thirsting
I'm getting really thirsty over here my
Colony at least
they cannot work
what do you think about the ETR 1000
fretcherosa oh they're very nice trains
that's very nice
what are your thoughts about the
Hungarian Erasmus Scandal um yeah um
the Hungarian ruling party
the Hungarian ruling party uh
basically took over a bunch of
universities through these like
foundations and [ __ ]
and so European Union was like yeah okay
so no Erasmus for you because Erasmus is
this is this for those of you don't know
is this scholarship where you get like
500 euros per month and you get invited
to University for like one semester two
semesters and you get to study there for
free to widen the horizons of students
and make them like you know more
pan-european and it works it's super
it's super fun
so yeah
um
yeah
it's a great it's a great thing it
actually it's very helpful in uh not
becoming a beta
I'm kidding of course but yeah rhythms
is awesome
okay
we need a [ __ ] burner there
all gonna [ __ ] freeze okay um
they are the following I see I see I see
one I see two I see T this alternative
tilting yeah yeah I see three three MF
Valero D I see four and three Neo and
the L yeah a bunch of ICS
are you gonna play Alex I highly
recommend from here to there mode much
better than levitation you need a beefy
PC to handle it though okay from here to
there mod okay I I
from here to there okay I'll look into
it thank you my BC is I think fine
Daniel andreska thank you for the 10
euros hey Adam thanks for being awesome
well thank you for being awesome
yourself
as a fellow expert from central eastern
Europe Slovakia living in Germany I
wonder what you think of nrw
transformation
and bike friendly uh yeah it's it's good
I mean
um I've not been to Dusseldorf but
generally like uh
generally
um these measures are you know they're
my professional opinion they're neat
how many kids do you have four
and they're all
they're not here now they're all KO
it's such a especially spot to use those
like like you know completely flat
like like the Earth
so
okay I'm going to oh [ __ ] I need to take
these out huh
God damn
uh one second
okay
all right let's still get a few minutes
all right
um
oh wait oh yeah oh wait one second
Kraut is going is coming on
uh
can I
can I call it 14.
to any
20 30.
30
[Music]
.
yeah because like uh not just bike is
gonna call in in a bit and
um
and um
well he is going to
and also
a crowd is coming
so
yeah they're all they're coming they're
approaching and um yeah there's I have
to like juggle them a bit
[ __ ] dude I need I need more wood this
this is unacceptable
this is completely
Beyond acceptability
uh let's not forget about the chat I
wouldn't leave you alone guys heckland
wow the the the top of the food chain
aside from me on the Discord
um
so
finally got the stream on my lunch break
everyone watching should join discord.gg
Adam something to avoid being cringe
yeah word
uh if you want you can join Discord
discord.gg Adam something or the Discord
link is under every video so you can
easily find it I think
yeah
um what time at what time is crowd
coming so crowd is coming in like half
an hour
uh maximum not just bikes is gonna call
in now in about five minutes and yeah
and then it's going to go on
and after not just bikes following not
just bikes and crowd
and then Ellen Fisher will also uh grace
us at
uh in uh let's see that's 14. yeah in
like an hour and a half it's a pretty
tight schedule actually then Rhys from
from uh from uh RM Transit
uh and then at 17 meaning in uh three
hours I'm going to have the debate with
the
uh I want to say anarcho capitalism but
find objectivist person
uh he he insists I call him an
objectivist while being otherwise an
anarchical capitalist so whatever if he
wants to I I will indulge him
um yeah and at in at the end after the
debate we're gonna have a condo with
Dylan Burns who's I think heading back
to Ukraine or he's already back to
Ukraine back in Ukraine and um
he's going to be uh well I think I think
we're going to also review the Ukraine
situation with him and that's how we're
going to
conclude the stream in the end
but of course everyone is welcome to
stick around
yeah uh yeah I mean it's not going to be
the debate debate it's gonna be like a
discussion I I think it's going going to
be like
you know
me asking him how this okay it's like
it'll be like me asking like hey
uh how would this work in your society
and he gives an answer and I'm like
okay but how what that that would not
work okay look listen and then then
you'll get into the how will this really
work please explain you know
it would just be like a back and forth
like you know
him being
wrong and I'm trying to get him to admit
that he's wrong
anyway
uh-huh okay we don't need a guard here
yeah
[Music]
um
uh okay so once again the schedule is
the schedule is the following okay
now I'm gonna have not just bikes only
about in about two minutes
half an hour later
Ellen
no it's crowd and crowds
so okay now it's now it's 14. okay in my
in my local time
I'm gonna have not just bikes on
and then in half an hour
I'm going to have crowd on
okay and then in one hour I'm going to
have Ellen Fisher on
and then an hour and a half I'm going to
have Rhys around Transit on
this can be a bit more but we can go
back and forth with the times but this
the general idea and then in uh and then
uh three hours from now I'm gonna have
the debate
and then it comes Dylan
he burns
anyway yeah so
well
nope
okay guys
do you hear it
oh
okay I missed that guys
will the stream be on your channel after
it's over yeah yeah I'll put it on my
channel
um or the second Channel I think I think
the main Channel we'll see but guys
what oh no
it's the sand worm nice
um okay
I think I'm hearing noises uh oh first I
am hearing super chats Pro
justifications 8.99 pounds thank you
very much from the UK your love I love
your videos dunking on infrastructure
scams in the end cap and the end of
series are brilliant thank you very much
for your kind words
though guys
I'm hearing
I'm hearing bicycle noises
something
is
is happening I hear chains clinking
I hear pedals
turning
it's
it's
none other than
if he answers the phone
the bicycle noises are getting louder
hello
hello I cannot hear you can you hear me
I would put device
I think you're muted
let me check on my obs
you're somehow muted can you unmute
yourself or is the is your
your
muted I think
wait output device output devices
default
no say something
hello can you hear me yes I can hear you
uh can you can finally yes okay good hi
so this is hi hey so this is not just
bikes everyone I hope everyone can hear
uh let me pull up Chad actually uh I
don't I'm not home I don't have my
normal uh setup so this is uh a little
bit funny loud it says okay yeah
I don't know what I can do about that
all right wait how you doing Adam oh I'm
doing nice thank you very much uh I
turned down your your audio a bit so
it's fine now
okay good perfect
yeah so well I'm doing doing well thank
you I'm doing the this whole day stream
to commemorate my my uh great fans who
were stupid enough to subscribe to me
yeah Brad congratulations honestly it is
so cool to see
urbanism left us
fan I'll go to a million Subs it's so
awesome
um well deserved too thank you very much
yeah
um and uh yeah I'm it's still pretty
unreal that I'm here though that I know
right made it yeah they made it all the
way but uh I've hey who am I to complain
right
I remember uh I remember we had a
Discord chat like back when you were
fewer Subs than me but you would release
that Dubai video and it was doing well
and I said like I'll race you to a
million well it looks like you won yeah
oh well hey I mean it's it's not a
competition man yeah so it's good it's
good fun yeah it was
and you're out out in the Bahamas now
right chilling I'm in the Bahamas today
yeah well I'm checking out in uh in a
couple hours which is why I had to call
in now
but uh yeah it's uh it's all right here
no I I bet as you're you're in your
strange business trips which may or may
not involve you know illicit substances
and uh and I met up with the guy who
runs foreign man in a foreign land uh
and it was uh good fun I think I'm gonna
try to do a uh a collab with him should
be good
okay yeah
yeah I miss I miss uh I miss our collab
in Amsterdam though that was awesome
that was very good yeah both the live
stream we did although although the
stupid camera like died went through
that live stream and
that's still a live stream that uh that
brings in um like random spikes of
viewers because I think in terms of uh
you know people want to see you yeah
well yeah they want to see us on bikes I
guess yeah I guess so right yeah that's
good but what was that what was the
place you went to the last time though
that like really high-end you know
smelling your own fart from a wine glass
kind of
place you know where we all right
I don't even remember what it was called
you guys were already there yeah yeah
when you got soaked on the way there
yeah that's so funny yeah well that was
good though yeah it's always great when
you can come to Amsterdam I'll show you
around and everything
um and next time let's get out of the
city center yeah yeah yeah well you know
there's there's so much new for me there
like even even in the center they just
like yeah I guess I guess for you it's a
bit boring now uh the city center
already well actually I hardly ever get
to the city center because it's just
such a touristy area and I love it on my
channel when um when I'll get uh you
know some some comment you know never
read the comments rule one but um when I
get some comment that says uh
that says you know this channel talks
about how great Amsterdam is but I went
there and it was just a bunch of drunken
tourists and and like I don't know it's
like oh so I can tell you never left the
tourist area Yeah well yeah that's
that's true
we got it too loud here again too loud
you know what I I turned out wait I
turned you down like you're at minus 18
decibel now in OBS so he should be fine
if you talk now people should be you
know
turned my own mic down so there how
about that yeah okay audio levels are
always the problem on the live stream
because like oh man I hate that
um yeah it's always so tough to get it
right and I remember I I've done a few
gaming live streams and like the city
skyline sounds are deafening to
everybody and I don't even notice it
yeah
now there's a bunch of wires don't don't
pay attention to them I don't I don't
even read their comments you know I
don't care about what they think just
just kidding I think that's probably for
the best day just kidding I I love them
now anyway actually my my
um you hear that fans oh I love you all
anyway uh no like uh actually what what
um
what what I um [ __ ] what I want to say
yeah that like in our communities at
least like the urbanism bike whatever
like this this actually pre-selects for
a more cultured audience thankfully
like of course I dipped my toe into
politics and it was just like I still I
still have these like little mentally
ill idiots like
doing like orchestrating these [ __ ]
like video essays on me for no reason
uh and actually actually the um
actually
um what I wanted to say is uh
what was it like there was this video
that came out recently like someone
linked it on my Discord and it was this
yeah debunking video someone tried to
debunk my Vegas Vegas Loop video of all
things and uh come on yeah I know right
that like the Vegas Loop is good
actually and it's like this it was like
this Elon stand dude
who was
um
whose fans now since Elon shifted to the
right like his fans
consists of
like white nationalists
like half of them were just like we're
just like uh things that trigger Adam
something Elon musk's success and people
who enact laws in favor of white
Europeans and like what
you know what though I'll tell you Adam
if you are pissing off the white
supremacist then you are doing something
right yeah and that's that's what I'd
like to think well although like those
people are usually like snowflakes so
like it's not hard to piss them off with
anything
so
anyway so what's your what's your next
project by the way what's what can we
expect from
not only bicycles
uh I don't know I got a bunch of stuff
in the works I'm really desperately
trying to get a video out about SUVs but
I've been trying to do that forever and
it's so long right now that it would be
like an H bomber guy style essay so I'm
I'm really trying to cut it down mostly
because I don't want to uh I don't want
to go through all that editing even
though I have an editing team I really
don't want to go through all that
editing for the video that long yeah
okay I'm gonna do the collab with a
foreign man in a foreign land here in uh
in the Bahamas
um
um also I really think it might be time
that I make a video about uh I mean look
I've talked about this in so many videos
but still the most common stupid ass
comment that people mentioned about my
videos is that oh yeah that works in the
Netherlands but America is Big yeah yeah
okay like it was the stupidest [ __ ]
argument on the face of the Earth so I
think I might just put out a video about
that and be like that just the one that
the fans can point to yeah but honestly
that is the dumbest argument against
good urbanism like yeah like like who's
driving from New York to LA every day
right like you're not you're driving
within your city you're going to the
grocery store the grocery store isn't
three states away yeah that's true it's
such a stupid ass argument yeah well I
mean what do you expect though I mean uh
this might be the first video where like
Russia can come up as a positive example
in anything so you know because they're
railway lines and they're like their
country I mean they do have like public
transportation however rudimentary so
yeah yep anyway yeah it would never work
over here you know it's not this our
series are built different no your
series were just bulldozed uh but you
you know it man you hear all the same
stuff over and over and over oh wow
first of all people just completely
ignorant about history because the US
was built on trains that's just facts
yeah the railroads built the United
States that's how they went out west
um so that's just plain fact and people
that don't know that are just ignorant
of History
but also it's the same excuses over and
over and and like you you suggested
there everyone thinks their city is
different oh we're different we're like
this you know we're like no other other
city in the world it's this kind of like
weird like like City level nationalism
you know where people just like
desperately need to defend their City
yeah we're special just like everybody
else
so on your channel like what what are uh
the what are the really uh what videos
do best these days I mean I know your
Dubai video totally popped off so like
excluding that like you do a whole bunch
of different stuff because you don't
just do urbanism obviously you do lots
of other great content including you
know debunking stupid Elon [ __ ] and um
and uh some politics stuff so what kind
of stuff is is you know if you were to
put out a video on one of those topics
tomorrow like which one would you expect
would be in the in the sort of one
degree of the latest ten videos actually
currently it's hard to tell like
currently I think what what's doing
really well from these Ukraine updates
funny enough right right yeah but also
actually the like when I like my content
like my element seems to be that
um
my element seems to be uh essentially
videos where there's like a stupid
Transit idea like the previous uh Swift
cities Gondola systems [ __ ] whatever
and I never heard of that until your
video actually yeah good like these
things should be stamped out early
before they blossom into like this big
poisonous [ __ ] uh yeah and uh those
those actually are doing really well on
my channel usually but now funny enough
like the the algorithm kind of loves me
and hates me like I get these really big
Optics
uh it's like upticks not Optics and
that's great though that's like okay
that so that happened uh I don't know
why and then sometimes I I like upload a
video which my audience likes good
retention whatever and like everyone
watches them but my My Views like it
doesn't get recommended as much and it's
like okay well right I have [ __ ] you
know whatever but um
yeah for you um I actually actually put
out my latest video the Jeremy City in
Amsterdam I I used footage even from the
from our Amsterdam uh bike around
oh right yeah yeah the stream and that
actually is
uh very much like your style
uh and people seem to like it but that's
not it seems to me that that's not my
element so people checked it out it was
nice but it was like it was doing okay
but yeah
yeah well like as we talked about that
that video is a little bit different
than what you normally do so it's always
gonna it's gonna take a while for people
to kind of Discover it because I do
Wonder like how much of an overlap there
is between your audience and my audience
there's certainly a big overlap but I
wonder if uh if there's also like big
circles of of people that just watch you
because of your varied content that are
like not even aware of me and it's
entirely possible so uh it yeah it's
interesting to see how those things do
right yeah there is actually a big like
when when I look at my analytics I I
also see like okay others other videos
your your channel reviewers have watched
it and it's always like thought about
that it's always like real life lore
bend over or whatever and then there's
always not just bikes like third or
fourth uh so yeah I think yeah I mean
it's it's not difficult to to to you
know transition into each other's
contents like as a viewer
you know they're just gonna be like yeah
like let's check out this other person
uh yeah but um
it's still like my your type of content
for me will remain I think a side hustle
so to speak
yeah and that's fair enough I mean I'm
not exactly going to make like and cap
content either oh I know I think it's
yeah well maybe right
um and maybe I should uh I do sometimes
wonder if I should do some more politics
stuff but I think honestly if I did it
would be closer to like what second
thought does than uh than the stuff that
oh yeah yeah that you do I think just
because I I feel more comfortable with
with that kind of format yeah yeah but
although they did not just bikes debunks
you know and like not just bikes and
local capitalism destroyed would be uh
that would be an interesting video I
must admit hey hey guys Jim here yes I I
I'm looking up the channels your
audience watches right now last 28 days
the first one is Adam something yeah
okay and then Johnny Harris real life
lore Vox and half as interesting uh half
as interesting made the top five this
month instead of Wendover so okay well
uh okay well that's somewhat interesting
yeah
yeah
anyway
um yeah so uh I think uh I have that is
saying yes is this not just bike said
yes this is not just yes this is this is
in fact not only bicycles yeah I don't
know I I should I should figure out ways
to make fun of your name like in like an
endearing way so anyway uh yeah um yeah
you know if that comes to that then I'm
going to be saying Adam and then some
inappropriate word every time so Adam
you know that's the uh yeah that's
that's the recurring theme usually
all right yeah so anyway thank you for
coming on I have I have crowds kicking
down the door on me uh correct no
problem man I gotta pack and get out of
this hotel anyway and I actually have
some more filming to do yeah so you you
went to this busy life of a YouTuber you
know oh yeah so you go to this like
Island you do business and oh God I have
to I have to pack and get out of this
hotel so goodbye
well a safe best of luck in all your
endeavors
thanks so much and again Adam like
congratulations I'm really so glad to
see someone in this circle of videos get
a million Subs uh because you are not
going you are the first but you were not
going to be the last and we've got a
whole growing movement of urbanist
YouTubers and politics YouTubers who are
going to just uh
hopefully hopefully suck some of the air
out of the uh out of the oh the [ __ ]
idiots online yeah who are getting way
too much coverage because they're funded
by billionaires oh yeah that's true yeah
well I mean I'm super glad that this is
like a Grassroots movement as well so uh
uh you know the fact that we're all
doing this just because we want to and
we're not being funded by the Koch
brothers or something no hey if there is
a pedestrian walkable City Advocate Coke
brother cologne out there my business my
business email is open please reach out
yeah yeah George Soros call me man come
on everyone says that I'm funded by
George Soros where's my cat yeah I know
right that's my my last payment what the
hell Uncle George my last payment didn't
come through
uh
anyway
I'll let you go man I gotta go you gotta
go kick uh keep up the good work thank
you and you know I don't know we'll
we'll have to see who gets to I'll race
you to I'll race you to 10 million yeah
oh well that's the next Milestone isn't
it well thank you very much for thank
you very much for coming on and good
luck out there with the serious thanks
Adam yeah bye-bye
but
ladies and gentlemen not just bikes
uh so
but we have a second guest if you're
hearing parrot noises in the back that's
because
the
notorious YouTuber
whose four or five pictures of parrot by
the way that's where reference comes
from notorious YouTuber
and central eastern Europe aficionado
kraut
is also coming on in five minutes
apparently he just woke up so
just woke up oh yeah he's well where is
he I should I should actually ask him
I should ask where he is because this is
suspicious like this is not this is this
isn't the Austrian time zone I'm afraid
Eminem something do you like Berlin
what's your opinion about Berlin can you
do is a review in Berlin uh at some
point yeah I think I will because uh
it's a fun place uh like I've been there
multiple times
and
um
yeah
it's a
cool place I like it it's a cool place
and it's gonna get colder
you're bundled up now
wait till you get older
I know like what I really like about
Berlin is this new uh Berlin
Berlin Otto fry
um
movement which I hope catches catches on
is basically uh basically turning Berlin
into like this huge like pedestrian car
free zone whatever not completely car
free but like stuff like you know if you
live there you can drive to the center
12 times per year and it's like or
something like that and it's like [ __ ]
yeah dude finally some finally some
delicious find us some good [ __ ]
policy uh yeah so
and Spud
Spud no
his his disciplining the other cats
against their will
okay so Kraut is ready
uh
uh his coffee is boiling
he said
now it's no longer boiling
good morning hello hello good morning
Jesus you woke up now what time zone are
you in
I was up until like six in the morning
yesterday oh okay no doubt working on
your next video epic
um no I had some other things to do
yesterday but uh
okay
yeah
um but nonetheless not less important I
just woke up it just literally just made
it out of the shower I boiled up my
coffee
and um congratulations thank you thank
you million subscribers uh thank you uh
very much is your
uh I'm gonna ask Chad really quick is
crowd's audio okay should I should I
turn it up a bit
I'm not on my studio microphone I'm on
my headset if you want to come okay
quiet okay wait now yeah because I don't
know it's fine on my end I turn it down
how about now now talk of it
hello everyone congratulations to Adam
to reaching on me and subscribers
which very well deserves
yeah thank you very much too uh it's
it's been a wild ride and I've been
enjoying it all the way and uh I'm ready
to discuss the future of central eastern
Europe thus thrusting with you thrusting
us into a new golden age of uh
Central history
well who would have known that you could
build a channel talking about
infrastructure yeah well
you should be proud of that yeah while
times will even huh
you took one of the topics that most
people are the most disinterested in if
we're being honest and you turn it into
something that is actually interesting
and that is not that is quite the
accomplishment well thank you very much
yeah I mean yourself actually like I
would never have thought that I'll ever
care about like central eastern European
politics and I'm just like okay good I'm
like wow okay nice all right why do you
believe that what do you think that well
because it's I mean I've been because
it's Central and Eastern Europe yeah no
I mean yeah
political scientists in particular like
you can read um Snyder Timothy Snyder
but it is out I think fukuyama also
wrote about this politics of Eastern
Europe is actually far more interesting
than the politics of Western Europe yeah
more like the wild west a bit no no
absolutely not like
you know Western Europeans often have
this very
awful perspective where they look down
on Eastern Europe as backwards right oh
yeah
like that place that is recovering from
communism those people who still have to
learn to be like us enlightened
westerners and blah blah blah blah
that's wrong
in not just from a moral standpoint to
an ethical standpoint of you shouldn't
treat people that way
um
one could argue that from a political
perspective
from the perspective of political
development Eastern Europe is ahead of
us
considerably ahead of it okay in what
perspective though
the perspective is that so
Eastern Europe um we in the west all
universally all democracies right not
just in Western Europe but also in
North America to extenders in South
America and in Southeast Asia we're
going through a process of
developing oligarchies in a way right oh
yes the neoliberal policies of the 1980s
they created an enormous amount of
wealth but they also create the huge
wealth inequality
and across the world's democracies we're
seeing you know the establishment of
small powerful individuals with a lot of
wealth who are starting gradually to use
their wealth to impact politics oh yeah
with Elon Musk we're definitely seeing
that yes yeah
and the thing about that process for us
it's still a gradual process so we're
still in the midst of it
the Eastern Europeans
if we're using a gaming term they did a
speed run through that process they went
for shock therapy in the 90s
they're long into that and that's that's
like the thing here the things that
Eastern that the checks the polls the
hungarians the ukrainians the Russians
are going through these are things that
we will face in the future Yanukovych
right the um crony oligarch strongman
well strong man in conflict with
oligarchs in in Ukraine yes viewing him
as sort of a backward Eastern Tyrant is
the completely wrong perspective correct
way of seeing him is as a a Potential
Threat for European democracy in the
future
um oh yeah I mean that actually makes
sense I mean obviously everybody think
about this yes campaign manager
work was the campaign manager for Donald
Trump ah okay yes from that perspective
you know Trump's politics can be
interpreted as a sort of an import of
that oligarchic
power politics that was developed in
Eastern Europe imported into an American
democracy oh yes I mean I I can I can I
can see a sense in that though I think I
think we're trending towards that anyway
because uh like this trending towards I
think let's just take just that's just a
side effect of the whole thing like the
Donald Trump sharing a campaign manager
with with yonokovic but uh I think also
like uh yeah as you said the system we
have the systems we have set up the
economic systems we live in are bound to
like they are fundamentally autocratic
so they are bound to reproduce uh
reproduce I'm not sure I don't think
that the future is the past I do see
this as a new development what I mean by
that is like reproduce uh an Eastern
sort of oligarchy uh or something
similar in the west so that's that's
what I mean it depends I mean not all of
Eastern Europe is the same everyone went
on the different developments oh wait
that's true yes the Czech Republic for
example is really very much ahead while
uh yeah while Hungary Hungary is not
Hungary is like sliding into like the
north Balkans now instead of like
Eastern Europe
so yeah that we're doing that figures
going like ah this is just bulking they
thought I actually saw that very often
recently A lot of people started
referring to hungarians as Balkans
because there's a kleptocratic in
governance yeah yeah it's kind of funny
but it may even though there's still
Slovakia between them and the Balkans
yeah but like there's it makes sense
though
in a way I guess in a way not so much I
I think it's not like a cultural thing I
think it's a failure yes yes I mean
obviously I mean to me as a Hungarian it
makes sense like emotional like oh yeah
[ __ ] dude hell yeah but uh but uh yeah
of course from a geopolitical
perspective no I mean the thing that
sets the checks apart from the rest of
Eastern Europe is a very small policy
measure actually not small but an
overlooked one I should say that is in
the 90s you might know what I'm talking
about the Crackdown against organized
crime and white called crime yeah oh yes
yeah exactly yeah I know that one yeah
and that's what you're referring to your
audience may not would you like to
explain or should I explain fear free
feel free you're better at explaining
these things to the audience when the
Soviet Iron Curtain collapsed Budapest
in Hungary was sort of a
um a operational base of various
organized crime syndicates in Eastern
Europe in particular most famously the
Russian mafia was Simon moklovich
and when the Iron Curtain collapsed
these Russian organized crime syndicates
tried to set up shop in the Czech
Republic
and the chicks didn't like that so they
organized and the police Crackdown
against organized crime and that's what
they did during the 90s and it worked
really well these crime syndicates left
and as a result though the check State
realism do we really just have to do
this against organized crime no we could
expand this so they turned it into a
police Crackdown against white-collar
Crime in general
and this had yeah it makes sense and it
had a really great impact to sort of
purging Czech State institutions of
corrupt mismanagement type of politics
that unfortunately developed in places
like Hungary
and because of that in terms of
political development
the checks have a far better
institutionalized setup in their state
than most than even places in Western
Europe in terms of political development
they're less corrupt even than many
other Western European countries oh yes
I did notice that the government I mean
for all its failings it's still like an
efficient system uh problems there's
like a one oligarchic type of figure in
the Czech Republic Andre Baptist you
probably oh yeah yeah he's running for
president now but I think it looks like
he's gonna lose to Peter panel or
nerdova which is but the thing about him
though he the way he operates is so much
more different compared to like
oligarchic figures in the rest of
Eastern Europe right oh yeah yeah I mean
even babush is like milk though so like
I was wondering like yeah the stuff that
checks got mad about are like yeah like
what babish did in during his term that
or for Orban just like a Monday so yeah
well Andre papage he he was like um he
worked for the Communist secret police
spying against anti-communist dissidents
he then sees control of a acrophone
which is like I think a pesticide
company which belonged which was a
communist industry and he took control
of it through some shady dealings yeah
yeah the big difference between him and
like a Hungarian oligarch is that he
babish
he went into politics to save his skin
because he was being investigated for
his corrupt dealings by the by Czech
prosecutors and he basically went into
politics to get a political immunity to
save himself from those investigations
hmm yeah well that's that's yeah makes
if he loses this election time's up he's
going to face those prosecutors probably
hell yeah yeah I mean I I heard that
like charges were like dropped against
him for now at least but uh yeah I
cannot I cannot wait to see babish
in a place where he belongs belongs
there was still like a DD check those
big you know Czech anti-corruption
protests uh in the uh in the Republic
when babish's corruption came out I'm
like I read about the corruption and
like people are this mad about this much
that's good you know yeah it is good
yeah very very much so like the whole
the whole country was in up in like a
frenzy and I'm just like damn I I wish I
wish this happened in Hungary but nah it
won't and for us in Western Europe it is
it would be very prudent to look at
these developments and to ask ourselves
you know as as we face
our future struggles with oligarchy and
wealth inequality do we do we want to
end up like the checks or do we want to
end up like the hungarians yeah uh Trump
definitely definitely represents the
Hungarian wing yep here
yeah uh but um how how can we avoid
though becoming like hungry or like how
can you avoid I should say well
like studying what the hungarians did I
mean it's not just the the Crackdown
against white collar crime right it's
also just um
did they have an active and franchise
citizenry as you mentioned before the
the anti-corruption protests yes this
definitely mattered him having a public
that is actively interested in how the
country is run who
get outraged when stuff like that happen
that is certainly
vital to ensuring the health of the
institution of the state
oh yes uh apathy I would say is is more
of an enemy to democracy than than
anything else definitely definitely and
that's something that we're dealing with
isn't it oh yes and Hungary is a very
apathetic country because well actually
this this actually Cuts both ways you
know like people in Hungary actually the
reason why they voted for Orban again
and again is because never mind never
mind culturable issues never mind
never mind uh you know uh well pretty
much culturable issues uh so never mind
that uh Hungary was going through an
opportunity an economic optic period for
like that's an uptick not optic and an
economic uptick period for uh 12 years
which now ended with the war in Ukraine
so
uh and people were genuinely living
better under or but never mind that the
country gets stolen under under them you
know crony stick or everything and which
Dooms the country long term economically
but uh people were just like we're you
know the the a simple tax tax
cuts can earn you a lot more voters I
guess than than uh than long-term strict
financial planning or like
which is a competent long-term Financial
Planning and so we're through this
uptick period people were just like oh
yeah I live better on the robot sure
like Fitness is fine and now is now the
big question is how much did the could
the government entrench itself
in people's heads you know with so that
they will be
they'll vote for Orban regardless of uh
the economic situation which is getting
worse
so I'll be I'll be very much interested
to see that
how do you pronounce that the name of
the of the richest man of Hungary is one
of this
uh pardon me this Hungarian Mongol names
May
sarosh
um
yeah
that's yeah that's him so for those of
you don't know Lawrence May sarosh is
this gas repairman from Hungary the guy
was the guy is barely literate he can
barely write his own name then but he's
hungary's richest person
because he used to be orban's high
school like Avengers school friend and
and also uh and so Urban is now using
him this like extremely stupid person
without any values
to to basically Park his money so he's a
the very nice German expression to this
for this is
like a straw man for for Urban's wealth
so that Orban doesn't have does isn't
wealthy officially it's it's it's far
more than that like he gained his wealth
solely out of running a construction
company or opening one when his friend
became the Prime Minister and just he
got all the government contracts to
build yes but the thing is highways
bridges any kind of government building
he's a he's a state subsidized
billionaire which is sort of the most
grotesque thing there is yeah but and
and yeah yeah even worse is that a lot
of the money he got which is his private
wealth yeah I eat new subsidies that
were sent to Hungary to improve on
Hungarian infrastructure and make it a
on average wealthier and better
developed country and I said billions of
these went into the pockets of the sky
yeah yeah I mean the thing is though
like the game is very complex because
sure he made his money through a
construction company but
the thing about that is that's not
that's not his money like that that's
not his construction company that's the
funny thing about it it's like
everything that man controls and and
runs officially belongs to someone else
um in the party so learnings might have
a construction business sure but that
construction business he's just fronting
basically uh for some High Level Fitness
functionaire usually
yeah someone close to what about like
the bigger the bigger the business the
closer you are to Orban that's the
that's the idea and yeah yeah and and so
nothing like that's that's why I'm
saying like during this message owns
nothing has nothing runs nothing
he just uh he just like he he's an actor
essentially and he's like he's very slug
dim uh person illiterate as I said he's
a mechanism by which that like that's
why the Hungarian oligarchic state is
more similar to the Russian one in the
Ukrainian one right because
because in Russia what we saw is that
Putin's so in the 90s politics was the
play thing of oligarchs then Putin the
strong man came in and subdued the
oligarchy under his own will and
learning
however you are yeah
yeah he's basically like that he is
oligarch under the control of the strong
man
it's a means by which the strong man can
maintain economic control I've read
that that was there was another rich man
in Hungary
um oh um well she built a tech industry
sector or something and
and he was opposed to Urban oh yeah yeah
and other than over regulated his
specific economic sector Innovative yeah
he was a media Barren sort of yeah uh he
was I think and he had the left and he
had to leave Hungary as a result of that
then then I don't know if it's him I
think still lives in Hungary anyway like
Urban had multiple falling outs with the
with multiple oligarchs but uh
it could be either one actually
I think
shimichka
s said I typed it out
yeah yeah
normally ish that doesn't sound very
Hungarian yeah they said it's like a
Slavic origin name uh
publicly and then it was this like big
color blue uh but like he was basically
like shimichka used to be this like uh
how should I put it
uh he's he was this like this uh this um
how do you call the person who's like
behind the ruler you know he's pulling
the strings Etc like the ruler's right
hand man
um I know what you mean but I don't know
what the technical term is right anyway
that's
yeah he he was he was the he was the
hand of the king for a long time and uh
to the point where
um like I've heard test like I've heard
testimony from like past Hungarian like
ministers elected ministers who
um
who
uh were ministers under like the the the
the uh the I think the second or third
urban government the second I think and
shimichi was still at large at that
point and um
they they said that like they had to
meet with shimichka because he was like
the big Power broker yeah the the gray
Eminence whatever yeah
and he was uh he was
um uh the one you had to go to
so that he'll size you up and he'll
assign you a place in the pecking order
basically it was full-on Mafia and
um what happened was the minister the
elected Minister goes into this goes
into this image and he's like so who the
[ __ ] are you again and and why the [ __ ]
should I care or said something like
this
and the minister had to explain himself
to this dude who had had no no public
position by the way
uh as to like you know what he's good
for what he's useful for Etc
it's [ __ ] unreal it's just it was run
by like the country Hungary was run by
like a mafia even before this whole
current business I I know I know
I know it's a very unfortunate story
yeah well uh one one more thing
um I forgot I forgot who but uh anyway
I'll recall there's there's a there's a
second similar story like this but
they're they're all like this it's like
some some big you know uh gray country
like uh oh yeah oh yeah hungarians know
who I'm talking about happening is a
very interesting guy
he is he is a guy who has no legal
income no political position
uh he's not a public figure uh like no
one knows what where his money is from
and uh and uh
I guess someone's again another public
figure has no wealth has no income and
he has a VIP pass to the parliament
the gourds let him in on site
and no one knows what he's doing like no
one knows why He's there but of course
we do know why he's there obviously he
is there to um he's there is another
right hand man but a completely
unofficial one
and he was actually caught
uh he was actually caught
uh is actually a pretty funny story like
there was this promotional video
uh that that was made I think in the
Bahamas or something or some like these
you know Dubai caliber not Bahamas not
to say the Bahamas is like Dubai but
like you know rich people go there to
have fun type of place and there was
this very expensive Club there that made
a promo video uh with the guests having
fun and whatever and on one of the on
the promo footage
people noticed this guy this Hungarian
like this dude who comes in and out of
the Hungarian Parliament always
to like do orban's bidding he they
noticed him really really sniffling at
his stable look just like looking around
like
like you know like like that and uh yeah
uh he was he was doing coke
and uh it was like this big uh you know
Scandal slash
[Music]
too extended you can even report on a
scandal in Hungary at this point yeah
base basically yeah so like it's in
Hungary the media the canceling media is
actually a real thing and it it doesn't
go it doesn't it doesn't happen via
uh
uh like it doesn't happen via uh actual
government censorship like it happened
before 1990 but it happens through uh it
happens through unpersonally freezing
you out unpersonal yeah so like
suffocating you basically
it's a very interesting method to do
because that is not something that the
Communists pioneered like originally the
first to sort of do this with the
Mexican PRI the 1950s and 60s with their
opponents and it's very effective
instead of just you know disappearing
someone who is an enemy of the
government you just slowly unperson them
and ruin their reputation through
continuously publishing nasty untruthful
attack pieces against them limiting
their ability to work oh yes it's not as
competent think like Hungary is not that
competent thankfully so it's it's not at
that level yet but I mean it's it's it's
in the bag I would say it's definitely
but um like with Hungary they tried this
like at one point one of these
government run magazines made a list
it's like black black background white
text on it made a list of the of of the
allies of George Soros
which basically which which should be
interpreted as it was it is interpreted
as
uh
by fans of the regime actually as like
you know the people who are in cahoots
with the Jew you know like that's the
whole idea because everyone in in
Hungary knows that like yeah your church
is Jewish
and being against shorosh is being
against the Jews right and that's the
that's the entire idea this is this is a
euphemism in Hungary
and anyone who denies that you can
immediately discount as like a either a
useful idiot or a or someone who's in on
it it's it's the same [ __ ] as like like
oh no if this is the okay symbol not the
white supremacist symbol even though you
know
only white supremacists use the OK
symbol at this point
so it's something like that
one of the greatest flows of the
European Union in its establishment was
that it um
it didn't account for the fact that
democracy is actually capable of
collapsing into itself yeah yeah
unfortunate
and also the the The veto system how
it's how it's set up like one one
country can can sabotage real real easy
like the whole
have you ever you you you probably have
heard the word Gray Zone right uh yeah
yeah there's the tanky Magazine name
crazy yeah yeah oh that one yeah oh God
did you know that Grayson is actually a
technical term in political science okay
it's what you call a regime that isn't
Democratic but pretends to be Democratic
oh yeah okay shine democrati would be
the German word oh yeah yeah so like a
parent only only a pattern to democracy
apparent democracy is and Hungary we I
guess many people in in the European
Union didn't accept it at the time isn't
really a democracy it is one of these
Gray Zone States yeah yeah
yeah I mean it's it's actually it's
actually a um like Hungary is officially
now called the hybrid regime that's a
technical term for it
you could call it that yeah it that it
does make sense and yeah I mean we're at
the point where we
I've had conversations with people where
people are seriously discussing if
Hungary should be removed from the
European Union at this point oh sure I
mean hey as soon as I get my my German
citizenship we can do that okay
well just just wait wait a few more
years and we will get to it okay you
know now that I live in Austria I can
tell you that I'm pretty certain that
the Austrian government would block any
such movement yeah that's true yeah they
they do it's some conservative political
maneuvering yeah
not just that like among other things
then Vienna is a Hungarian City
it's a very Hungarian City because
everything is just filled up with with
Hungarian what our help the health
sector here oh yeah you constantly find
Hungarian nurses Hungarian construction
workers Hungarian this everything is
Hungarian here because you you obviously
make a lot of money just being a migrant
worker jogging across the border and
working here yeah I mean there's like
there's like Vienna is like an hour away
from like Western Hungary by train like
a slowly regular commutes or whatever
yeah and because of that I am pretty
sure that there's sort of an economic
codependence here that would permit
Vienna to sort of block any move against
Hungary yeah in order to ensure that
the Hungarian laborers the cheap ones
keep coming
yeah almost all doctors here are
hungarians my dentist is a Hungarian
like I'm moved here and every doctor
I've had so far as a Hungarian
okay yeah actually the the um the um
Hungarian doctors are not actually funny
enough it must be an Austrian phenomenon
then because over here though in the
Leipzig area
Hungarian doctors are not so there's
like maybe one that I know of I I have a
friend who works at the hospital the
doctor
so uh and it's like there's like one
maybe
and well that's very different yeah yeah
there's a whole bunch of
um serbs and people from the Balkans
though so
I had a conversation with
um my Hungarian house asked about it Mom
doctor he told me that um
yeah he studied medicine in the 90s
and then as soon as he got his degree he
immediately just left for this place
because Hungary was so corrupt etc etc
yeah
yeah he told me that there's an entire
generation or two generations of doctors
those who graduated from med school in
the 90s in the 2000s and in the early
2010s they all just packed the bags as
soon as they got the med degrees and
went off to Austria yeah yeah Germany or
to France he said a lot of them also
went to France okay I didn't know that
and um
that the Hungarian government's decision
to crack down against this practice was
by um you can study medicine to Asian
free in Hungary
but only if you sign a contract where
you sign off to working 10 years after
you get your med degree in Hungary yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's actually everyone
had to sign that I had to sign that as
well so but I I think I think I worked
enough in like I paid enough taxes in
Hungary so that they leave me alone
but like you think better check up
before anything otherwise you'll become
a tax Refugee yeah no like I mean you're
fine I mean if they ask me to to repay
my tuition I will like whatever if I get
a letter like hey yo you owe us this
much like it was like what like a
thousand Euros per semester so it won't
bankrupt me but like you know
that is better with something else like
since we're talking about Labor
migration
um I have um a friend he works for a
policy Institute in Brussels for the
European Union
and he told me that his Institute that
one thing that a lot of people they are
working on is
they're basically preparing for one of
the greatest migrant crises that we will
ever have because they believe that
within the next five to ten years tens
of millions of Russians are going to
flood the Eastern European borders of
Poland and Lithuania and Finland and try
to get into Europe yeah I mean that's
I'm not discounting that
I the migration in the 90s like the the
amount of Russians that came to Europe
is very
very unders like we often overlooked
that but you know that almost how many
million three million Russians in
Germany yeah almost yeah the origins of
them are here by the way in the east
yeah the origins of these are really
funny because uh when the Soviet Union
collapsed right the um
that is a historic German minority in
Russia the um the Don Deutsche okay uh I
think yeah the uh Catherine the uh the
great imported German Farmers from
Prussia and Northern Germany to work the
fields around the dawn hmm and the the
well like um 200 000 of these in that
region when the Soviet Union collapsed
and the German government made an
announcement saying okay if you're one
of these and you come to Germany you
will get German citizenship and
um
well a million Russians stand up Which
is far more than those two hundred
thousand right yeah they all claim to be
then and they all got citizenship but
the funniest thing after this
is that that after these million
Russians arrived there was still a
hundred thousand of these Germans
the vulgar
hmm yeah I'm not sure what's going to
happen with the like if if not now that
Russia is going to nosedive I don't
think it's going to be like a sudden
collapse but more like a slow decline of
this country but the the pressure will
build obviously to get the [ __ ] out of
there
for people most of my friends have left
most of my friends have left okay yeah
and even even even now like oh Millions
I think left already so uh
yeah
yeah I have I have two friends who
refuse to leave and it's becoming
annoying okay I've tried really hard to
get them to leave but they're not
I mean one of them is a is a trans woman
okay who lives in a in a city and she's
very very
just one of my more left-wing friends
which would like to discuss well no not
no no that's another one sorry she's
she's a liberal Russian like myself not
to the left but um
but the thing about it is like how
existence in Russia at this point is
just dangerous as you should just get
the [ __ ] out of there but she she just
doggedly refuses and I think she
I think she legit seems to have that
delusion that the revolution is coming
and she wants to be there for it yeah
um yeah I disagree with that assessment
yeah
the other friend of mine he's Siberian
he lives my condolences yes
well he's very proud of that
interestingly enough he lives close to
he I would say he lives close to the
Mongolian border that's something that
he would say but close to in Siberia is
you know a relative term he lives um a
12-hour drive away from the Mongolian
border but for him that's close yeah
yeah because he lives in Siberia
um a big country
yeah he's very left-wing
um
he refuses to leave and stays because he
also believes there's going to be a
revolution and he wants to
he wants to see Siberian Independence he
wants to see the establishment of a
Siberian Republic oh yeah yeah that
that's that's uh Siberian Independence
Movement that's very interesting but
yeah the problem is you know if you're
if you're listening to this from Russia
I mean look if you're like if you're
waiting for the opposition Revolution I
mean there might be a revolution all
right in Russia but if you're a trans
woman especially it's not going to be
the type of Revolution that you like
yeah it's it's it's all downhill I think
like what what do Nations do
when there's big like what do
conservative reactionary Nations do when
there is already a big like a big
economic upheaval well they sure is
[ __ ] getting more Progressive
so you might want to consider you know
saving your own life
I guess
yeah a lot of the Russians here now in
Europe at least they just try to not be
noticed as
as Russians they're they're aware that
to a degree they're not welcome here
by large parts of the public or to a
degree they are you know but they they
think it is important to sort of hide it
and we
like one friend of mine in particular
still has to come come to terms with the
fact that she's now
an exile uh yeah yeah okay that's that's
also yeah
that's you're not going to come back
home probably for decades to come yeah
if if if at all yeah
um these that that sucks uh I mean I I
wouldn't I mean for me I guess okay when
we moved me in Hungary like I I
personally don't don't give a [ __ ] but
I'm like hey I'm not going back to
Hungary anymore cool you know that's
that's what my you know I cannot go back
there anymore yeah
my mental health has already improved
now like uh well you can go back what
are they going to do arrest you and
murder you I don't think that they would
do that yeah of course not yeah but like
I mean yeah actually yeah I mean if if
okay snark aside I mean I think actually
it would weigh on me psychologically if
I knew that like okay if I go home too
Hungary I'm gonna be killed most likely
one one way or or another one way or
another
and by that I mean you know
the state you know I had conversations
with other hungarians about this
especially since there's so many
Hungarian migrant laborers here those
who come here and sort of become
business owners and Wealthy Etc make a
life for themselves to them that's
actually a very very
it's a process of entitlement almost to
a degree where they get this thing that
their Homeland denied them so now they
they can stroll back into Hungary and be
like look there's a better world out
there look at what these [ __ ] are
doing to us
yeah yeah
yeah but also like the the biggest like
the
funny enough like the abroad you'll find
like the biggest anti-orbond people and
but also the biggest Pro Urban people
it's super super [ __ ] that does make
sense that does make sense to be honest
like a lot of
right wing idiots have this sort of
Fantastical delusion idea of who Auburn
is yeah oh he is this great right-wing
traditionalist no he's a gangster yeah
yeah but like what I mean is that like
yes I mean that plus the fact that uh
it's hungarians who went from Hungary to
say Germany and now they're like like so
they live in a functional liberal
democracy with Jackson balances
but but they're also
um
but they're also uh you know very very
uh Pro
uh
very very Pro Urban because they don't
have to live there and you know well
it's it's a uh there's a lovely
Hungarian saying you know when when you
when you're when you're you're beating a
nettle with someone else's dick
so when when someone else has to take
the take the uh shot for you and you're
just like in the back screaming that
like you know hungry is [ __ ] great
whatever but you're not the one who's
who's forced to live there right like
you you're you're screaming this on your
German salary surrounded by German
infrastructure like Western
infrastructure I should say
etc etc so
it's like some of the most deranged Pro
as sad syrians
uh live in Australia or Canada or the
United States or France oh yeah I mean
also these like tanky types I mean it's
the same thing it's just this reaction
that's the tanky type is like a
different entirely different thing but
you know there's a tip there's a type of
Migrant from an like we have a like
members of the huge Russian community in
Germany you probably encountered some of
these people it's just doggedly
pro-putin idiots yeah yeah
yeah I mean that that happens but
to an extent that sort of also ended
like at least in the European political
process you've seen that um
a lot of the far right and far left
pro-putin parties basically
self-destructed over the course of the
last year thankfully yeah in Germany
laganard in Italy is also just a
sideshow now yeah that's that's very
good yeah yeah I mean what what what's
what an invasion can do for you huh
the happiest yes I am the happiest over
the suffering of the foreign
how enough do you are you going to run
in the European democracy with that
baggage yeah I mean I I I remember that
when like when the first like this
Scandal first came out of like you know
the the pen took money from the Russians
the leopard was like yeah of course I
took money bro like no one would loan me
this is the Russian post with Putin like
she used pictures of her posing with
Putin congratulating Putin shaking hands
with Putin as campaign posters in her
campaign she literally had leaflets with
that of the eve of the invasion yeah
well you know shake hands with danger
stay safe well they kind of deserve it
I'm kind of happy that this is all
coming down on them yeah [ __ ] them
actually I had this like disagreement
over this with uh
what the [ __ ] it it's been so long since
we talked what's his name three arrows
yeah like I I we were we were thinking
like Walsh's stream I think separately
the uh and and like I was explaining
that like hey dude like that like the
the link [ __ ] sucks kind of
uh and um
and and I was I made the point that like
yeah the link is not to be trusted dude
I mean it's it's I've seen these people
before and it's and it's it's it's bad
news okay and and wouldn't you know it
turned out to be yes like they link it
to this day I think they had this party
Congress where they couldn't decide
whether to condemn the Russian invasion
of Ukraine or not
like it's better than that like they had
a leader a party leader who once when
she was elected I think or at some
occasion she held a speech about the
policy program of the link as a party
and she praised the accomplishments of
stalinism oh nice
wait what was that wagon connector
what's her name I think it was wagon
connect she she spoke about the
accomplishments of stalinism yeah how
great they were for Europe yeah hell
yeah dude I'm sure she found many
friends with that statement in Europe in
the east
yeah no it's I by the way I cannot talk
about these other figures that you just
mentioned I am
a little bit of a reveal here I signed
an agreement with other European
YouTubers who I work with
that I I cannot get involved in any
drama and part of that agreement is that
I can't say negative things about other
creators oh sure that's publicly at
least I have to stick to that oh sure
it's it's fine
um I'm not saying like like yeah this is
not like you do you mean the the three
arrows stuff
yeah yeah I can't say anything bad about
other creators I'm not saying like three
arrows I mean he's a great content
creator I like his stuff a lot
um thing is uh it's just uh I wasn't no
I'm just saying I can't give you my
opinion yeah on his news or on the views
of anyone else okay
don't worry yeah yeah I wasn't about to
knock him because I like him well and I
watch his videos it's just that uh I was
reflecting on our disagreement that uh
but yeah it's a it's a he you have to
keep in mind that for a lot of these
people right it's it's almost like the
world collapsed last year yeah yeah when
Russia invaded this is what this was
something that sort of shouldn't
like it was weird to build up to the war
watching how
the military experts and I mean the
non-political military experts they were
all convinced that this was going to
happen a month before
and when you read through their
reasoning behind it it became very very
clear why right because the Russian
military was revealing secret ammunition
deposits secret bunkers secret positions
that it kept in case of like a defense
against an invasion stuff that you
wouldn't reveal if you were just having
a normal exercise they brought enough uh
ammunition for almost a week of combat
etc etc so all the military experts knew
this was going to happen they were right
about this happening but meanwhile on
the internet all these people the Linker
types in the server were just screaming
into the void oh no Putin is benevolent
he would not do this yeah blah blah blah
I mean it also hinges on this I think
there's very I think this term is from
vosh actually the American diabolism
like I think their their ideology the
problem with their ideology is that it's
it's the end will be all you know U.S
bad this that that one I think
Christopher Hitchens described it the
best but saying that it's a sort of
reverse nationalism
it's a masochism you really just want to
see yeah okay there's also other factors
to this right like I've had a lot of
conversations with Eastern Europeans who
just do not understand why there are so
many Western marxists to have this view
of them right yeah but there's still a
degree something that people don't
understand about this right that um
that's I think you get the best insights
by looking into something that um Noam
Chomsky did in 2014. yeah
um in 2014 Nom Chomsky was given a award
for his Linguistics work by check
university and he traveled to the Czech
Republic and used the opportunity to
give some speeches you know as he always
says and do these speeches he said ah
you checks are an ungrateful people you
do not appreciate what the benevolent
Soviet Union did for you your dissidents
like that they are all um liars and
manipulators Asians of imperialism who
stabbed the Soviet Union in the back and
that um you know the the um your stories
of being oppressed by the Soviet Union
are not true and exaggerated and he also
blamed people like that survival for the
um for right-wing American cruises in
Latin America oh yeah they use the they
used you guys to disguise what they were
doing there and there was a lot of
outrage in the Czech Republic when you
did that
um I wonder why
yeah he had to leave the Czech Republic
and go back to the US and you know for
for people like you and me this is a
very
weird thing because we know we Europeans
we know you don't say that to the chicks
yeah yeah yeah 30 000 people were
murdered under the Soviet occupation it
was a brutal [ __ ] regime you don't
say [ __ ] like that to Czech people yeah
it's like it's like that old English
fella who walks up to an Indian says are
you you Indians you just don't
appreciate what the British Empire did
for you yeah your own great ungrateful
brownies oh I'm doing a Southern accent
for some reason yeah like you know the
UK brought civilization to the colonies
and your you you know all they get all
they get in return of enlightening you
is you kicking us out huh ungrateful any
words you know and that that's what
you're noticing right there like we have
that also Germany right the type of old
German who's like uh well at least
Hitler you know those types oh yes I
know oh the French have these as well
you're like oh the algerians just don't
appreciate the Napalm we dropped on them
yeah
that is what Chomsky is that attitude is
what Chomsky and Co and what a lot of
Western marxists have towards Eastern
Europeans it's just it's not a genuine
sort of political consideration or
anything based on any sort of political
Theory no it's just a a salty
spitefulness against the people who
decided to have a revolution against
awful regimes yeah against yeah because
it's Lefty because it said it's left
it's you know it's like a red coat of
paint Etc that's that gets to a lot of
people because you know U.S bad hey
who's we are leftists who's doing
leftism hey well the Soviets are saying
they're doing baptism
so you know
I have to tell you and you probably
noticed this as well
you've probably noticed how a lot of of
especially if they're Americans
they treat us Europeans as if there are
politics and our political
decision-making process doesn't matter
like they behave as if we were just
nothing but
American puppets yeah it's cute yeah I
mean what really got it really um got to
me was that like it was like really
annoyed me I should say was that [ __ ]
Kyle Kolinski when the when the whole uh
Russian invasion before the Irish
Innovation I should say so Russia is not
invaded yet but they were messing on the
border and Kyle Kolinski made these
[ __ ] comments on a show that like
Russia's reasonable asks should be taken
into account I'm like what reasonable
ass yes reasonable asks and so and he
advocated for on his show he advocated
for turn so he was like okay okay guys
so uh I I propose so just turning the
these those states in the baltics and in
the East into buffer States I'm like
well yeah and and here's the thing
though like I he did he meant well right
he didn't he did Kyle Kolinski is the
last person who would have any malice
towards uh any sort of average European
right no he's a he's a nice dude but
like because I was like listening to
them like what so this is once again
it's this view that you said that like
yeah Eastern Europeans are just like
pawns on a chessboard and he like many
other U.S lefties cannot think outside
of U.S like in a way they are they are
used I'll tell you a little secret
um
I I had a private conversation in the
build up to the Russian invasion with uh
a leftist YouTuber who has sometimes
privately talked to
um and he had this conversation that his
line was just but what about Iraq right
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and that is a
really annoying thing to bring up
because for some reason these these
Americans seem to think that we were
fully on board with them they
conveniently overlooked that you know
the French actively tried to stop that
war the Germans deliberately tried to
stay out and said and advocated against
it yeah Turks tried to stop that war the
belgians even threatened to sue the
United States in the international
criminal court if they went to war in
Iraq yeah yeah like that there were we
were not on board with this and the
funny thing about that conversation I
had with him was I I I shared my screen
with him in that this could call and
showed him a map of Europe
and asked himself okay show me when
Europe is Iraq and he pointed at
Bulgaria okay and it's it's just ah wait
so you asked him where you asked him
where Rockets
Bulgaria okay
it was like yeah maybe that might be an
issue there as well you know a lot of
these people think that the enlightened
Americans yeah but to a certain extent
you're just Americans yeah I mean that's
yeah yeah I I did notice this
yeah sort of thing oh well
uh [ __ ] I mean yeah and like this is not
nothing against Americans obviously but
like holy [ __ ] like American lefties in
particular like dude just they should
not
be allowed to talk about foreign policy
like so many people have I I wouldn't
say that I wouldn't say that look ask
the average European way Montana is on a
map and there will point at New York or
Florida okay so Americans shouldn't talk
about
europe-centered foreign policy and make
confident points about it then I'm gonna
phrase it I I would I would say I would
phrase it differently I would say get
informed first there is no limitations
on what you can or cannot talk about
just just
please at the very least read the
Wikipedia article of what you're about
to talk about oh yeah that's yeah that
would that would help a lot of people
just please just hope open the Wikipedia
please okay can you hear me yeah can you
hear me the link I sent you quick
uh yeah
anyway what can you do Americans
I I wouldn't I don't like The Stereotype
of the stupid American to a degree right
me neither like I'm joking obviously so
it's it's more just like there is a a
political disconnect from this
yeah yeah
uh well yeah plus that coupled with with
the usual you know American diabolism
and uh which actually I
um one person's like
the person I like ripping who's like
ripping on uh ripping on uh these like
us bad lefties is actually
I think he's gonna be coming on to today
uh wash
he called it a holy war I believe which
I think is pretty apt so you know so so
the the reason why these tankies are so
you know up in arms about this is
because for them this is a holy war
which I think is generally true
it's difficult to say because it is
it's something that I actually don't
really like that much doing because you
don't know what goes on in the mind of
people right you kind of have to take
people for their word right when people
say these things to you
it's like there's a difference between
us too I'm a liberal right for me
it is essential for the functioning of
any political framework that you are
charitable to people and that you accept
that when they tell you that you know
that you don't undergo a process of
questioning their motives and saying oh
what are your ulterior motives but just
to take what people tell you on face
value and to a degree kind of have to do
that and when people just tell you
things like uh the Russians are just
anti-imperialists defending themselves
and blah blah blah yeah you have to you
have to sit down and go through these
things these points and you have to
patiently like the onus is in us to just
patiently explain why this is not the
case
this is the rounds bag and it goes into
the round oh okay no no no no no no no
no no you're not in your mouth not in
your butt around it sounds like yeah it
sounds tedious right but yeah it is
essential if if I if I am confronted
with someone who walks up to me and
brings up I don't know the Crimean
referendum right
and and says oh the the Russian like
they ignored like have you ever looked
into the Crimean referendum by any
chance yes I I know I'm familiar with it
then you know probably
um your audience might know as well that
the referendum question on the ballot
was do you want to join the Russian
Federation or do you want to become an
autonomous Russian federal state so
basically it was a referendum between do
you want to join Russia or do you want
to join Russia so it wasn't really a
referendum in any way and when people
bring that up right when they say oh the
crimeans voted to be Russian rather than
being oh you're just an ulterior motive
you just have this inept deep
psychological desire to explain the
world this way rather than doing that
which I think is ungrounded it is far
better and far more rewarding to just
sit down and patiently explain no this
is how you got this wrong this is why
you're wrong this is this and this and
this and to just go through the point
oh I mean as as long as yeah I mean as
long as the other person is coming at
this in good faith because I
I've encountered not one people who came
at this end like I don't make that
judgment I don't make that judgment I
don't make when someone comes at me and
I think they are in bad faith I'm still
going to pretend that they are in good
faith I'm still going to be charitable
but you know I don't do any debates or
discussions like this anyway I just like
that's that's the thing that I do right
I don't mention other YouTubers on my
channel I'm just very I just address
points yeah yeah and I think that is
essential it is essential to be
charitable for a political process to
continue in some ways oh yes yes I mean
I agree I agree charitability yes is I
mean it is important but uh I mean as if
you're opponent like what I mean I guess
is uh if they like actively actively
um
actively revealing that like they just
don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ] you whatever they
just say to Screech then it's like yeah
sure whatever oh you just ignore them
then yeah this is there's this concept
in in Confucianism of um
I don't know the word there's a Chinese
and a Japanese word for it which
directly translates to um
to kill with the Silence of contempt to
murder someone with the Silence of
contempt in in that Confucian tradition
of rhetoric and debate and discussion
um it is
um
it is
the idea is that if someone is so wrong
and so stupid right that there's almost
no point in arguing with them yeah the
best thing to do is to just ignore them
to be silent to let them rage in in
quiet like to poison themselves through
their rage and I I apply that kind of
concept if someone is just so ridiculous
and so nasty and so uncharitable I
ignore them I blocked them I pretend
they don't exist
I let them rage into the void it's
probably best for your mental health
yeah
that's nice
yeah and there's there's the other
Chinese concept which is um director
translates to to politely poison
someone's tea
and that is when when you it's also the
confusion idea in rhetoric which is when
you encounter someone who you disagree
with fundamentally you're overly polite
to them you politely poisoned their
teeth yeah as you speak with them
happens to me every day I'm just kidding
yeah no no but I I understand yeah I
mean it's yeah makes sense I don't I
don't I also don't uh like I think the
secret to a long and healthy existence
on YouTube is just like being a bit
above it and not being too attached to
it and basically what you're saying that
like uh uh this ignoring those who are
obviously bad faith I've I've learned
that
I think that we in particular as
Europeans just um
like if we're being honest YouTube the
online environment on YouTube the
culture on it right it is very
it's very American right yeah and we can
see that reflected in sort of the way
that commentary political commentary in
particular is done there it's
um
it's this cultural politics where people
see their political beliefs as part of
their identity right where when you
disagree with someone they almost see it
as a personal insult against their being
well we Europeans have a sort of
institutional
um politics where politics is mainly
driven through the direction the
derogation of power through our
institutions and there's a there's a
reason for that like in political
development the Americans had a
democracy before they had a functioning
centralized State because of that social
forces are far more impactful and
cultural forces too in their politics
when we Europeans got democracy right
our democracies are basically just
the people the public as a sovereign
cease control over the institutions of
state that had been built during
monarchies yeah yeah so the that's the
reason why our institutional forces are
far more powerful why are politics is
more consensus-built and more like
orientated around
Corporation and compromise
and I think we as European creators
we sort of faced the challenge of
establishing that way of doing politics
online
and we have to ignore that American way
of doing things to a degree oh yeah yeah
well I appreciate your anti-americanism
I'm just kidding I'm not a tanky I only
talk about American issues anymore
very rarely yeah I mean yeah America I
mean yeah good luck sorted out uh yeah I
mean plus like I think I think uh on
your end like what you did uh what you
launched I don't know if you caused it
could be that it was actually actually
you got got this started but uh you were
you're certainly a big force in like
bringing these like European issues into
like mainstream so like before uh it's
like I would say around like 2016 the
Donald Trump craze Etc like it was
Unthinkable for like European politics
to be you know uh uh in the mainstream
or like to be to receive as many views
as they are getting now it's like what
what or to even receive recognition oh
yeah yeah Europe is is you know when
Europe is viewed as this like
little kooky place with people living in
their castles and eating you know
meeting them irrelevant
American puppets
this area they are actually yeah I think
this also stems obviously from like
American American exceptionalism but
like
what can you do
it's it's
um have you noticed that none of the
tankies like none of the people who are
have you argued the case for Russia over
the last year are European
oh yeah again that's weird there's not a
single person who speaks French German
polish Czech or Italian what's up with
that yeah not a single one who's ever
lived here it's it's like that
it's that stereotype of like the the
California Valley girl who thinks she's
an expert in European politics because
she wants on a Euro trip ate at a
McDonald's with knife and fork in Paris
yeah yeah yeah
or and also also that also the thing
about uh also might be might be related
to the phenomenon of you know the the
most nationalistic Pro far right people
live in Western democracies from
different countries that is you know
like the biggest pro-war bomb people
live in uh
in a in a
in German Village
nice German areas which would be like
science fiction in Hungary yeah
yeah it was still like I had these like
tanky debates I mean I I was Burying my
face in my hands a lot during that
uh and it was all it was it was just
these like circles I mean actually I had
a debate against
[Music]
um
what's his name the the the the what's
his name people the the guy who looks
like a caveman and yells a lot and he's
like a big Tankian like many of those
barely yeah but like he's he's special
like a caveman like he's a literal he's
a literature I barely watched that
segment of YouTube anymore oh twitch I'm
unable to give you an answer I probably
wouldn't that okay he's a literal like
neanderthal
by the way people in chat are asking
that people in chat are asking what game
is this is surviving the aftermath so
what what was
you were talking about a guy who looks
like a neanderthal yes apparently yes
hot infrared yes infra yeah it was
infrared like that I love that guy I I
love that guy yeah I I he's he's a
painting that needs to be admired from a
distance
no he's just mean material perfector and
the the other thing about him is if you
look at him from my charitable lids you
will notice that he sincere about all
the things he thinks he says yeah I like
I very much appreciate that about it you
remember that that thing he did with it
I am a [ __ ] yes that is what I am
and that ranty made and everyone just
laughed at it at how ridiculous it was
and I was like man I recognize that
you've read Dugan you're basically
spouting against points okay that's
Dugan that's where he's getting it from
huh yeah yeah that's Dugan It's that
idea of like Asia Eurasian civilization
magical Mongol energy and all that stuff
yeah always yeah I I watched her video
where they discussed that actually
though okay yeah the the common left
segment dude Cosmic Mongol energy stuff
all that yeah he read Dugan It's very
clear that he read took it
um
foreign
has a had a talent for attracting you
know those kinds of people Dugan had no
Talent whatsoever Dugan is just an
overrated piece of garbage he's um
nothing Dugan ever wrote this originally
he just ripped it from other authors who
came before him Karl Schmitz left
gumilev and um evaneline oh yeah yeah
okay yeah evine alien that's that's the
name you mentioned frequently
yeah it is very important to
understanding the current there are
people who disagree with me on this uh
Vlad vexler if you watch that video
vlavexler did a very good response
challenging my idea he believes that
yeah he believes that the ideologies
don't play as much as a role and that
they're just a cover that their flags
that their makeup with which the regime
poses um he and me have a bit of a
disagreement on that one hmm wow I
cannot wait for you to Duke it out
finally in the Thunder though I'm not
going to Duke attack in the fun the term
it was a polite disagreement among
gentlemen that's kind of how we did
things and that's how I kind of hoped
that European commentary on the internet
continues no stupid dugging it out but
just politely questioning each other's
points just asking some questions
exactly hmm
yeah but uh hmm I'm not really into this
I'm not really into the the uh the whole
uh
polite back and forth on YouTube thing
though then don't do it don't do it what
I mean is like I'm not really into it as
in like I'm not participating in it I'm
not I don't know if I would be into it
but I guess it wouldn't be my kind of
content
I think a lot of people who do
the back and forth thing that they loot
themselves into thinking that they
actually matter uh more than they
actually do
oh yeah I I've uh yeah uh previously we
talked about there's are you familiar
with this uh Channel called what if all
test
it's like I told you before I cannot say
what I think of other creators because
oh yeah okay okay fine uh anyway yeah so
we we were having a discussion about
that person and yeah
yeah yeah you don't like him well
[Music]
you know interesting interesting person
they were like I I just don't like it
when it's like oh yeah this this what if
this is cute alternative theory about
history here have this and also a bucket
of Nazi ideology it's like oh are you
sure about that one I I don't know
because I haven't watched any of his
videos he once um reached out to me and
asked for collab and no no no no no I
don't wreck dude if you want to if you
want to lose your like just Google the
Reddit bad history Reddit takedowns of
his actually he butchers
he butchers some of your ideas as well
so to the point where
like he's this like evil psych guy I
think I I watched one of his videos I
know that like yeah the Barbarian energy
of the Primitive civilizations have
created this like life deeming life
energy conqueror Spirit which then
transitioned into um
yeah I mean he's basically just doing
the the
strong times create Hard Men create bad
you know like that that sort of thing
just like with more words
but uh what is
but actually uh the bad history really
did like this massive takedown of his
but because he's like spreading
misinformation online so I wouldn't I
wouldn't recommend getting involved
uh because
yeah but the thing is I don't do
networking right I don't try to get
shout outs by other YouTubers I mainly
just stick to myself I have a very small
circle of people who I actually talk to
which includes you and a few others but
I don't really talk to a lot of other
YouTubers oh me me neither I mean I I
have a life outside YouTube so yeah but
when it comes to YouTube I just um I
think the process of building your
audience for shout outs is a very
bad one because it isn't your audience
it is fundamentally it is someone else's
audience so it's always better to grow
as much as you can by yourself yeah I
mean I I would agree with that I mean
it's nice if you if it likes if it like
gives you traction you know like uh if
it's uh if the shout outs I mean yeah of
course you can gain an audience with
that but uh yeah
I would say it's better it's better to
grow organically and I I think the
YouTube algorithm has been relatively
fair with that recently like back then I
heard people complain that like oh yeah
they did the YouTube algorithm is not
you know
is a
the YouTube algorithm is a
unfair to creators whatever and I don't
think that's true I think the YouTube
algorithm is actually pretty neat now
nowadays for now like it can of course
change I'm I mean I realized that
I have no idea how it works that's the
perfect thing I have to say I don't know
so I can't match judgment I mean me
neither obviously but like uh yeah
and it's it's very dangerous to talk
about things that you don't know much
about or under informed over and I don't
know anything about how the YouTube had
algorithm works so I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna dwell into that one yeah me
neither actually
um I have I've in a few minutes I have
Ellen Fisher coming up next in the
roster
so uh we'll have to cut the conversation
uh short unfortunately but but it was
very enlightening as always and in of
course in the future we can talk about
things even more and thus Revolution is
the way we think about European uh
politics and save the save the continent
both of us will save the continent
Alan Fisher is that the the public
transit guy yes one of the many yes one
of the many in our cabal
then I am going to leave something for
you before I
before I go I love it when people leave
things for me oh yeah no it's kind of
one of the funny things that you know
what your channel is basically doing is
you're trying to convince Americans that
a public transit network is a good idea
oh wait actually
uh I hope that when I call someone else
on Discord uh does it does it does it
drop you from the call or does it just
make the person yes
it drops you or do you want to make a
group if you want to make a group I'll
share my screen with you and I'll show
you how to do that okay okay
um
wait I need to share my screen
[Music]
oh yeah don't don't mind the fact that I
have like 500 on answer DM so that's
normal for me unfortunately that's fine
um if you want to make a group that's
this symbol a figure with a plus symbol
above the Hedge do you see that add
friends to the ammo yeah okay you click
that this window opens and you type in
the name of whoever you want to add
and then they will be added into it
okay that's how you open a group
so if you want to make a group later on
that's how you do it I'm going to stop
sharing my screen now all right all
right okay though I can only add friends
and we didn't add each other uh God okay
you should have thought about that but
yeah yeah okay no it doesn't just gonna
send you this one thing this is the
reason one of the reasons why I moved to
Vienna I sort of made the decision to
move to Vienna do I move to Copenhagen
and this is one of the things that sold
me in this city oh yes that looks very
nice I'm putting it on the screen right
now the
venerlinian the public transit Network
the best public transport it's probably
the best public transport Network in all
of Europe with the exception of good
Dipper 95 of the city is accessible by
public transport during the day
um 80 during the night you literally do
not need to own a car to live here yeah
yeah it's an amazing [ __ ] thing yeah
I've been I've been to Vienna multiple
times it was always great the public
transportation system yeah I love the
rail system and everything around it
well since you're getting ready to get
rid of me I have to tell you
congratulations on um reaching a million
subscribers here's to the next million I
hope to see you at 2 million at one
point um you deserve it
like I said at the beginning you made a
topic that many people consider boring
public transport infrastructure
interesting to people and that's quite
the accomplishment thank you so you
deserve everything you've gotten it's
quite the accomplishment there thank you
very much congratulations see you soon
in the million Club as well thank you
and all the prosperity you may want to
achieve may come to you thank you have a
good one you too bye-bye
so are we ready
that was a very nice call I always enjoy
talking to crowd and we're about to
get an angry Florida Florida
Philadelphia man into the call
let me just lower the audio a bit hello
hello hey hello welcome welcome to the
stream uh Angry Philadelphia man
yes no Vienna screwed that the best
public transit is Southeastern
Pennsylvania
can you give me a map so I can contrast
it with the wiener lenient
uh
yeah interesting thing is they don't
have a rail and bus map they only have a
rail and then
bus uh uh except the rail map hmm
there's a and it's also okay so the
United States has this weird thing sort
of like in uh European countries where
if you go over the border of a state or
like a um a country like the transit
operator changes
and uh in the Northeast here in the
United States when you go over the
border of a state the transit operator
usually changes so certain cities like
New York have actually like three or
four different Transit operators because
of all the borders they cross which is
kind of stupid but that's a whole uh I'm
trying to find there's like a map of
like the three different Transit
operators
um in the area that's the best that's
the better map
let me see
yeah well
uh just I'm just going to say to the
chat uh if you don't know the current
guest he's Ellen Fisher you can find him
on the same name on YouTube he does
public transportation uh and planning uh
Realty content
trying to find where where is good map I
don't want bad MAP I want the good map
but we all want the good map this is
true
who wants to [ __ ] bad map
so SEPTA has three different systems
um and that's just SEPTA that's not
anti-transit or PATCO but SEPTA has a
regional rail network which is like an
s-bond system they have a trolley system
and then they have a Subway and
inter-urban system
um and all of these work together in
this conglomerated mess and uh it's our
rail system here in Philadelphia and it
is I think probably the third largest
one in the U.S you're okay and putting
it in chat there's a decent map I think
uh-huh
oh yeah okay so okay so it's a
Contender to Vietnam it looks this is
only rail yeah yeah so the dotted line
ones are uh lines that they're going to
extend or did exist in the past so this
map is taking some Liberties in that
aspect so it's fan fiction is what
you're saying uh yeah so I have the
dotted lines don't exist
um but or are coming back or in
construction like the the purple line in
the top left that one is getting built
actually currently that dotted line
um any of the other dotted lines are
kind of fiction at the moment
okay well but and how frequent are these
because uh well like is is the service
actually decent
so the uh uh the Regional Rail lines so
that's all the ones that are kind of uh
White
um those can range from every 15 minutes
to every like hour
um if you get further out in the system
it's basically every hour
um if you're if you're on the inner part
of the system it can be five to fifteen
minutes depending on where you're going
but for the most part yeah it's it's
gonna be every like hour-ish 30 minutes
to an hour okay okay and these These are
the these are the the the uh like the
rolling stuck that this is built with
heavy and Light Rail or just heavier
it's just heavy rail oh okay oh that's
that's pretty good actually and
surprisingly except for the Atlantic
City Line excuse me except for the
Atlantic City Line which is the one that
goes to the bottom right all of these
are electrified wow okay
um so for the US this is actually pretty
good uh so the the line from so the
atletic Atlantic City Lindenwold all the
way to to North Philadelphia he's like
that's not electrified that's not
electrified past uh past North
Philadelphia it goes from running on the
Northeast Corridor and the part of the
SEPTA system to running on like an old
Main Line in New Jersey and so it uses
the most uh it uses the least
aerodynamic uh locomotives possible it
is amazing and they go it's they go like
80 miles an hour which is it's so funny
okay yeah but here I'll find a picture
of them for you sounds like a very
energy efficient system
yeah like I heard about the the American
high-speed train attempt which was like
this usual like aluminum tub
like you're you're average like a
aluminum tub train like no no like you
know uh uh how do you say well it wasn't
really like aerodynamic and it like blew
windows out of trains standing next to
it when it was being test run
because it was just like pushing this
like huge column of air yeah so we have
the three
out of the three fastest speeds in the
US ever recorded for rail uh two of them
are gas powered okay
well if it works but it if it's stupid
but it works you know you know I you
know how that goes but uh there's that
picture that is a um that is what we
call a Jeep
um the reason why is it's called a gp40
um and people just refer to them as
Jeeps oh yeah
um but these are very common both in
Freight and passenger usually in
passenger they would have some sort of
cowling over them to make them look
better or to look faster
um but the NJ Transit ones don't have
that yeah it's it's brute yeah
I think these look so and these things
do 80. yep these things do 80. which is
just to get an accurate measure that's
that would be uh 130 kilometers per hour
approximately
oh no so yeah three fifth was it three
and a half thousand horsepower uh so
yeah you can go any speed you want it's
like I've seen these go 90 or 100. we're
getting close to a hundred I don't know
if they can break 100 but I've spent on
the corridor and seen some um
uh some maintenance trains go by at like
90 with these on them which is very
funny yeah okay yeah I mean I wouldn't
want to be near there like this this
looks great but I wouldn't put to be
near this thing when it accelerates you
know they just they should it's just
like one two bricks put together and
it's like yeah it brick go fast on on
rail
oh it needs to accelerate it's it's and
you're next to them it's very great
because your ears get blown out because
just
destroy it's like a loud diesel It's
like because these these engines and
like I could probably look up 42 one or
42 14 but most of these are from the
late 60s or early 70s but they've been
rebuilt like many many times
um like most of the actually have a
video here's one of them flying by and
these These are these are on gas or
diesel or like these are diesels I think
the end the NJ Transit ones might be
running on
um
they might be running on some sort of uh
biofuel because New Jersey is very
Progressive like that but okay uh but uh
yeah diesel basically
[Music]
it's going
zoom in we just watch the video Jesus
flying break yeah I have a clip of one
of these so there's a spot on the
network you can see there in that where
there's third rail and then the outer
rail is the the Atlantic City Line
um and the inner rails are this this
um
this one train called PATCO Speedline
and PATCO is really cool it's like a
mixture between a commuter train and a
Metro it's pretty much just a modern
Metro
um oh yeah that's futuristic uh
is it that like yeah
I did a video on it a while ago I think
yeah I think I seem to recall it from
there yeah I mean the text actually
looks pretty decent one second
uh
yeah it's uh
NYC Subway wait the
if you type it here I'll find it but
this is uh one of the cool things is
sometimes the the Atlantic City Line
which is diesel train and PATCO which is
the uh sort of Metro that can hit 65 and
could hit can hit 70 sometimes
um race each other which is very
interesting to see once in a while
downloading the video let's let's check
out a train race
uh let's see okay
it's very like beat up diesel racing You
In This Very like 60s futurism uh Metro
Car it's it's very goofy
foreign
it's not not going too slow either
oh yeah there goes the brick
[Laughter]
man I don't know American trains look so
goofy I don't know it's so nice
uh the American trains look as goofy uh
to me as like European trucks look to
Americans I suppose oh yeah uh no I
would say the goofy thing I don't know
uh because like European trains are kind
of the default in a lot of places just
because like they're being exported
nowadays
um the the goofy things I find is a lot
of European buses are very goofy
compared to American buses such as
American I should say
such as in what sense like which buses
because I would have to point them out
but there's this like
um like it's very very rare to ever have
um like rear axles or rear uh wheel
covers on buses in the United States oh
yeah those are I know those are the fun
cool buses usually like these yeah and
it's it's very rare to also like I've
seen a lot of uh um like articulated
buses in Europe that have like a tram
style front on them too yeah you you
mean this uh the stream might have a bit
of delay yeah I'm watching it oh wait
I'm just gonna send you the picture
so
here we go look you mean stuff like this
yes like that's that basically doesn't
exist in the U.S yeah these are yeah
these are usually like Belgium
Netherlands uh maybe France so these are
like a uniquely like Western Western
European phenomenon if you if you know
what I mean yeah I don't know is that
like a byd I don't know buses that well
um
but uh yeah no buses in the US are
pretty standardized
um
our SEPTA NJ I'm reading your comments
uh our SEPTA New Jersey planning on
buying dmu emu yeah I mean like uh New
Jersey Transit has bought stabblers
before
um they're uh what was it the River Line
the small ones right the uh
the flirts okay so they're they're
thinking of buying flirts now but they
have bought the gtws in the past
um yeah and they the ones that um
uh the ones that New Jersey Transit has
bought the gtws have looked kind of
goofy because they have these like uh
um they have this like flat rounded
front well I'm finding a picture of them
yeah um one sec me uh I'm gonna also
switch
yeah uh
I'm sick yeah the GTW uh check Railways
actually bought a bunch no
but they are they actually look pretty
good with the library with the with the
uh blue
Library if I can find a properly framed
picture actually I can find a like a
let's do the live one here we go this is
not the best picture but I'm trying to
find a few like side views that look
decent of this thing so um yeah
hello
yeah the the oh yeah it's the uh
it's a bit different yeah the funny part
is is these actually like Street Run in
a little bit
um
for uh
hmm oh yeah I can sit on the street but
yeah but these These are these can
actually be used as the tram trains
these small ones these and the studler
RS swans which uh like I'm just like
well versed in like check train
procurement currently
studler heiress ones are kind of like
the Pacers but good
yeah like um like this is this here's
another image of it these things are
very funny because um they there's two
sections on their route where they
Street Run
um so it's it looks like it acts like a
tram but it's a dmu uh yeah but I mean I
think looks neat I think they wanted to
Electrify it originally
um but they uh it shares tracks on a
good portion with like freight trains
and
um they didn't feel like going through
the hassle of uh electrifying the whole
thing and uh
oh that's that's that's cute that's very
small oh yeah the the yeah the G the uh
yeah that's the RS one yeah but they
used to go in like these all right let
me see I can find a good better picture
because since we're since we're uh
looking around
studler Alice eins
Germany
but because they actually go go into
these like little German towns in the
mountains and it's super nice like in
the center of town you can see one of
these things pull up next to you ah but
I cannot find the pictures now I'm
afraid anyway you just just imagine this
imagine this nice Baroque German Little
Mountain Town normal street and ins in
the center of the street there's this
little brick coming up to you which then
go out into the forest to the on these
like teeny ass [ __ ] uh that's funny
tricks yeah
yeah
um go ahead
so yeah the the other thing is that like
uh the US finally relaxed a lot of our
roles about like crash protection in uh
with trains okay um which were really
stringent for a while because
um basically because a lot of uh
passenger trains shared tracks with
freight trains here in the US and
freight trains are big here so a lot of
the the mentality here was very like
well we must fix trains really stupidly
strong to survive like crashes with
stuff instead of actually improving
other Safety Systems
um but they recently relaxed a lot of
those rules so now a lot of the European
manufacturers can just import models
over and not change much the most recent
has been uh Caltrain recently bought a
bunch of Stadler kisses and there's a
bunch of great pictures of uh Stadler
kisses running out in the middle of the
desert and on the uh
um
on the test track we have here in Pueblo
Colorado
uh let me find
I'm trying to find a higher res picture
than that but there's always I saw this
yeah this is so funny to see get started
like cases in this environment
yeah with the weird double door as well
because yeah I think yeah we talked
about this I think the the American
platform different height differences I
mean it was just easier to do this I
guess oh yeah because the American high
level platforms are stupidly High
they're like they're like a meter High
um uh so like they these are designed
for American high level Platforms in
American low-level platforms which
American low-level platforms are more
like like European level
um but the problem is is that these are
also going to run into a high speed
terminal eventually when that gets built
so the they need the high level doors
too
um so that's why they have the goofy
configuration
um the funny part is is um
one of the uh one of the good parts
about this is that some other Transit
um
uh some other transit authorities are
looking to buy these now because of the
double doors
um
mainly because uh
uh they don't they don't don't want to
invest into platform leveling yeah so
like it's very expensive
um at least relatively to build
high-level platforms
um instead of just building low levels
or or what or just upgrading existing
stations yeah um so my operator in my
area SEPTA is thinking of buying these
because they don't have to upgrade uh
the current platforms if they just get
these with the high and low level doors
because then they can open at both uh
types of stations
because let me like find a picture of a
local station that I go to often
um
so like the the downtown Philadelphia
ones
um the stations are all high level
platform basically any of the the really
important stations are really uh like a
high number High number of boardings per
day are high level platforms
um the other ones are usually low levels
or are getting converted slowly
um
but in America there is no standard like
uh like the European Standard is like 55
centimeters from the top of the rail
there is standards
um but like certain places follow it
more than others
um
because like it's just more important
um like I'm trying to find a daytime
picture of this one station I go to uh
because I'm always this is you'd laugh
this is the station I go to uh for the
Model Railroad Club uh
so I can't find a daytime picture
because I'm always leaving at night
but yeah this is the local station for
that uh yeah but it looks nice though
like this I like these little wooden
it's wooden platform too like I haven't
seen it ever okay damn
yeah and it has a nice little like Stone
waiting room from the I think mid 1800s
wow this looks great this looks the
stuff I built in railroad Tycoon 2.
yeah I mean if I actually find some
pictures of the downtown from this place
like this place actually looks it
doesn't look American
um
like uh that's a video yeah I would say
this if someone told me this was in like
Spain I would say like yeah
um well I'm trying to find a picture of
like the downtown because the downtown
actually like other than like the street
lights and signs and everything it
doesn't you could you could send this
picture to someone that's not like super
stringent on their stuff and you could
say like oh this is this is not the US
um I think the thing that gives it away
is maybe like the the street with and uh
obviously all the signs
a sec let me open this because that's
like the little little downtown that's
like next to this station yeah this this
looks more like Germany honestly like uh
or UK or something with the brick
buildings and the style yeah yeah huh
yeah I should actually I should check
out Philadelphia after all like the uh
um I do plan on I do plan on collecting
like collecting my courage and like or
like my willingness and to like fly
somewhere Long Haul and I think it's
going to be down the East Coast
oh yeah once uh once you get over the
Atlantic it's not too bad yeah I don't
know like I I flew to like I flew to
Sicily in like September and it's like
yeah that was enough like uh uh it turns
out I'm not a fan fan of flights but
when I flew to Japan it was okay
but like I'm [ __ ] unfucking a Ryanair
or like I don't know what it was it was
like oh God just please yeah I just said
I just sent a picture this is in Society
Hill in um Philadelphia like um that's
that's a pretty typical scene for a
Philadelphia street especially when
you're close to Center City that looks
like Amsterdam a lot actually just with
a bit more cars but generally
yeah looks nice okay
uh let me see if I have any other good
Philly pictures so of course of course
not all of these were destroyed for
highways Robert Moses oh stopped in time
so that's the thing that's the thing
here in Philadelphia we don't
um it's kind of a secret because like
all everyone everyone in the U.S that
wants to move to a big city with good
urbanism they move to New York City
because they just that's the one they
think of
um but we Philadelphia is kind of like
unknown to a lot of Americans because
when they think of Philadelphia they
think of our sports teams and they think
of like the history here but they don't
know that there's a a lot of the city
that was never changed or never rebuilt
uh from the old days and so there's huge
sections of the city that look like this
that just have not changed obviously
there's some buildings that are a lot
less ornamental than those in that
picture because those are specifically a
more wealthy section of the town but
there are huge sections of the city that
are like super nice and all have a ton
of row homes
um
um just finding a collection of pictures
one second
uh like here's another one uh here's
Chinatown
let's see
okay one sec I need to accidentally
closed
yeah yeah take your time so uh let's see
here we go Philly
the city looks neat
and so the old neighborhoods the South
Philadelphia areas that there's like row
houses as far as I can see basically
yep a lot of row houses a lot of old
um
buildings that have been converted from
like old factory buildings or there's
tiny streets with like old we call them
trinitys because they're originally from
like the Revolutionary War era
um but there's tons of old and different
buildings there's an entire section of
the city
um that uh is called callow Hill let's
see where are you looking is that
Passyunk yeah
um yeah I'm looking at the names though
we get like forgotten bottom
oh that's a good one yeah Devil's pocket
so uh Philadelphia names either either
come from like it was a thing that was
there or it's a it's a Dutch name it's a
Native American name or it's a uh Quaker
name
um it's generally like the three things
where stuff comes from yeah it's uh like
Gray's Ferry there was literally a ferry
across the river so that's why they
named it Gray's Ferry all sounds like I
don't know locations from from Wednesday
you know the the the show Netflix
oh yeah like the the most expensive
Parts in the city are generally near the
center so Rittenhouse is one of the uh
most expensive areas
um the near the hospitals there are
pretty expensive uh but old city near
um the West part of the uh city is
pretty expensive
um the bottom down by the uh the sports
stadiums uh we call that the sports
containment Zone
um oh yeah I see yeah I see it why
that's that's that's generally uh yeah
that's needed for Philadelphia uh fans
yeah okay is there like a good aerial
shot I'm looking for no just Stadium but
oh God
yeah well they they oh here here's a
little photosphere
well good people feel it you like their
asphalt I guess
yeah I mean like there's a but there is
Transit there there is a metro line that
goes out to that section but the the
main
the main thing is that you probably it's
hard to rip a lot of Americans away from
uh parking near stadiums because
tailgating is a huge culture here which
is basically like you have you you grill
out of the back your car and you also
have like beer and stuff oh I see I see
wait [ __ ] why did I close them up
uh yeah I mean yeah I I saw I heard like
I have this image of like
I have this image of like the the
American with the with the
pickup truck or something with the grill
or something
uh in the back I didn't know it was like
I thought it was like like an occasional
thing like uh oh hi Leipzig uh the
occasional thing of like you know hey
sometimes sometimes your family goes and
does it like is it like culturally
ubiquitous over there
American thing to do like is it on that
level or it's City by City because
obviously if there's a stadium in like
the center of the
um city or something it's not as uh it's
not as culturally ingrained like if you
go to like Boston or Chicago some of the
um some of the stadiums uh historically
are like in this in downtown of part of
the city like regularly field in uh
Boston is like in the center of the city
so like when it comes to certain games
there no they're not used to that so
they'll no one expects that
um but it's one of those things like
it's only because it's been a certain
way for a certain amount of time like uh
there's this huge controversy right now
because the basketball team is thinking
of moving their Arena to downtown
Philadelphia and one of the
neighborhoods in downtown Philadelphia
specifically Chinatown doesn't want it
there because it they will fear that it
would push out a lot of their businesses
in a certain part of Chinatown because
it would like basically force a bunch of
sports bars and stuff next door yeah
okay okay
um so like I think that a Stadium
downtown would be smart it's just that
like you have to do it in a way where
you're not disrupting any neighborhood
and that's the hard part
yeah I mean yeah I mean I certainly
understand yeah but like hmm and
sorry I'm doing two things at the same
time uh I also wanted to add
[ __ ] how do I create a group called on
on Discord because RM Transit is also
ready to go
and I can actually drop you both in into
the call and see you do get out uh yeah
I think we just have to move over there
I assume yeah I mean we're both all
three of us are in a DM group now but
that's not what I wanted
well I think I just need to hang up on
this and just like call that I assume or
you call that
uh no I I can I cannot actually call it
uh yeah wait yes start voice call okay
so I might then drop you into that one
second yeah
okay so you're in
I'm back yeah okay and Rhys will accept
my boy
[Music]
our boy is not here
our boy
hey we cannot hear you yet but this will
change
he's muted he's unmuted his uh muted
probably fixing his mic yeah okay I
guess
yeah because I never understood like oh
I of course I mean I do understand like
the need for for like the the American
need for stadium parking but like if you
look at I think one of my first examples
I used was like strahovsky in Prague
which is like a monstrosity there's no
parking spot like everyone just not even
Metro Everyone just like gets there on
foot in by tram and by oh yeah by
Gondola I mean like uh certain American
cities do have hello like yeah our boy
hey
hey how's it going all right
all right it's it's good I uh I just
woke up
um I'm trying to think
trying to think why I just woke up it's
kind of late for me well obviously
obviously for the stream well why was it
yeah well no
obvious but uh why was it so late I
think I was I was out riding trains late
last night so I understand
don't we all
um for the chat the person joining is uh
Rhys he is he you can find him as RM
Transit on YouTube he does
um very more specific uh public
transportation content I'm gonna link
I'm gonna link both Ellen's and Reese's
channel in the chat so you can go and
subscribe to them
yes
congratulations on on uh many
subscribers thank you that's true I
indeed have a a number of subscribers
now
uh yeah it's a rather a rather
substantial number
would you would you say that well I
would I would rather substantial teams
like uh seems like an appropriate
quantity yeah I mean I agree and uh
actually though much of this comes from
like uh
blood essentially like a version of like
video essay blood Sports by the way I
linked both of our channels uh both
Ellen's and Ryan Transit channels in the
chat
um yeah so I mean I think the popularity
of my channel because both of you do
excellent content as well
I think the other the algorithm is a bit
biased towards me because I'm sort of uh
I don't know like I I go more the the
the the the McDonald's Route of urbanism
of like
very basic and then I also do a little
blood Sports and also the end cap just
like I'm a bit more spread out
content-wise especially with the end cap
Saga
hey that's sometimes uh very useful the
uh I'm also very I'm a very loud and
obnoxious American so I understand why
people don't follow me
I think that's that's the appeal so
that's fine I think
no but like uh yeah but I mean your
content I mean I I think I think I
watched all your videos and I've watched
many of recess videos I think it's
impossible to watch all of them at this
point but uh but yeah I have a I have a
large
yeah
right so I don't know how you do that
yeah I mean Rhys is a true Sigma mail
um
that says a lot of a lot of late nights
let's come again
a lot of late nights oh oh yeah exactly
but hey actually your channel also uh
also uh grew quite a bit right so you're
now at uh 178 000.
yeah I don't even uh
whatever people like uh like Transit I
guess and uh cool yeah I'm honestly
focused on big projects in the future
because uh I actually just got a new
camera and I'm excited about it what
kind of camera uh is a Fujifilm xt5 so
oh very nice very nice
so I I that's a good chunk of change
that has left my pocket but I'm excited
to uh to use that uh in the next few
videos oh yeah I think that's uh
very good I'm also looking for camera
tips because like so far my strategy is
like here's my phone I'm going to make a
video
I need some better gear desperately
there
so yeah it's all I mean honestly
um
the if shooting on a phone is underrated
um because if you do like standard uh
photography just suggestions you can get
most modern phones you can get most of
what you want done
um the hard part is just if you do more
technical stuff like shooting like
in-person interviews or shooting like uh
like art C stuff that you want to
include
um so it all depends oh yeah I see you
see our city hall which is very cool
building
yeah yeah it's with the with the trams
going around it underground yes so it
has a trolley Loop underground and it
also has two Subways or Metro lines that
intersect under it I hear it's quite
heavy and it's sinking or was it that
building
uh they actually they they fixed it by
shoving a bunch of logs under it uh 100
years ago okay it's sophisticated that's
a
City yes but it it is the tallest
freestanding masonry structure structure
in the world okay that's the one one
thing we have here in Philly
yeah yeah it's a very cool
um
um uh what's the name but like
victorian-esque structure that's like
very gaudy but in the best way
and I hear that like the the Metro like
the Metro was a was supposed to go under
it like through it but it went around
because the because the building would
have collapsed or something or what was
the story behind that
so if you look at the uh market
Frankfurt line which is the Blue Line
like we turn on Transit on the map
um you can see that that goes like para
like parallel like straight under it
um but the Broad Street Line
um is supposed to go straight under it
but they had issues with digging around
certain pieces of the foundation so that
one kind of goes at a weird angle
through and around the uh The Concourse
under City Hall oh yeah
and then there's um
the trolleys uh which go in sort of a
loop around City Hall which is very
goofy
um but uh I that's I I take the trolleys
very often and I take the market
Frankfurt very often
um the Broad Street Line I don't take as
much but um it the Broad Street Line is
probably the best metro line in the uh
in the um in Philadelphia
um because for the most part it's four
tracked and then when you get south of I
think it's Locust Street it goes to two
tracks
um
but uh that was a hot take you almost
made there Alan best in the U.S oh no
best in the US would be like the seven
trains careful careful careful there
careful you know Reese is with us you
know yeah
New York is New York is uh I like the
seven train but I mean I think uh
do you have a new line probably I mean
it's just you know
excess yeah it's the or the L train the
L train is also pretty good yeah
the seven is just impressive with the
amount of Express Services it has
also if you do manage quite a bit
despite being a triple track yeah also
if you're looking at the transit map
here in Philly uh goofy uh part of the
Broad Street Line is the uh the Ridge
Ave spur
um you can see which is the little kind
of part of the yellow or the orange line
that goes like off of the main part of
the Broad Street Line
um oh yeah
originally back in like the 1930s the
idea was that they were going to do what
Chicago had which was make a loop under
Center City
um but similar to the Chicago Loop that
is above the City
Underground and that the Broad Street
Line would go into this Loop via the
spur and that it would be like a
um a sort of square under
um
Center City they never finished it but
part of the the tunnel that was like
constructed for this turned into the
PATCO line so the the red line
um
there's actually a on there's actually
an unused tunnel for like
10 blocks under Arch Street that was
never used and it's still sitting there
abandoned because of that okay well I'll
have you know my kind of loop is the
Vegas Loop
uh-huh
oh man yeah well that thing go but I
mean that thing also happened that thing
is now open and yeah everyone is like
hmm that's that's pretty stupid at least
I mean at least people are not realizing
yeah
Philly has some weird weird it's
probably the weirdest North American
city when it comes to the the variety of
Transit options in the city
um yeah I'm looking at it's pretty crazy
I mean it's it's at least hey you had
you had some ideas and you weren't
afraid of you know making them happen
for a better years I think the main
thing is that like um
uh the main thing is that uh Philly had
a lot of stuff and they never got rid of
it like they had a lot of interurbans
and they never fully got rid of them
um so the 101 102 trolley and the
Norristown High Speed Line are all old
interurbans so if you look in West
Philly over at 69th Street where all
those little ones come together yes
that's um
that's uh that's all the um
uh what you may call it uh that's all
the trolleys and the Norristown High
Speed lines so the purple line
um those come together there oh yeah
that's that's up in Northeast Philly the
um
that's uh a lot of a lot of Northeast
Philly looks like that yeah I was
checking out the the uh the uh I was
like what the [ __ ] is that oh it's oh
it's all row houses wow
yeah no I mean a lot of Philadelphia is
like that and it's one of the densest
cities in North America because of that
hmm yeah but that's that's good but yeah
69th street here is the um sort of hub
for West Philly and all these services
West of Center City so this this
building The Terminal Hub
uh thing or terminal oh it's terminal
Pub I'm sorry it's it's a it's about
oh I've been there that's pretty good
yeah the terminal Pub check cashing
yeah let's see if I see if I can get
inside now oh there there's Photo
Spheres okay
this looks like yeah the 101 trolley is
really it's cute
um the trolleys and Philly are weird
because they look and the Norristown
High Speed Line is weird it's all weird
um because the trolleys were built in
the 80s and we've never upgraded them
um and then the Norristown High Speed
Line looks like a Star Trek transporter
um North Star High Speed Line
it like I have a picture of it I'm
trying to find it
um
where is that
speed being relative in this case it
used to like in the old days it used to
go 90.
um like it unfortunately only goes 65
nowadays
and it's in its Advanced stage yeah
well high speed was like everything
above like 30 you know
yeah I mean back in the day they used to
run into Urban's on it it's all third
rail
um
so it's very weird it acts as a trolley
though you pay on the the car instead of
um on the uh what you may call it on on
the platform also I see you saw Raleigh
Depot yeah those are all the pccs
they're gonna hopefully run again very
soon okay one second to close the map
again I instinctively close it uh yeah
there we go so back back to feeling
so for the fourth time
okay
so where were we 69th Street uh
that station actually looks like
your the 16th Street Transportation
Center apparently it's called very much
looks like there was like those Soviets
Suburban substations that they built
like not substations like subway but
like adjacent stations that they built
through next to you through stations so
there's actually a big big trend of like
we have like a big ass megalomaniac
Stalin buttock you know uh you know uh
uh [ __ ] uh through train station and
next to it goes a uh a uh a Suburban end
station
okay uh wait it's actually it's
yeah in Kiev this is like a very good
example
it's a massive uh stall I think it's
Stalin Baroque uh thing and then next to
it there's the there's the uh and
station of the of the Suburbans and it's
[ __ ] weird I don't know I prefer the
Berlin hope van hoof version of like
everything goes through just like on
different levels
I see in your comments how bad is North
Philly homeless and addicts uh so Philly
has like when it comes to homeless in
the United States Philly is not that bad
compared to other uh cities especially
like San Francisco for example
um but the the thing in Philly is that a
lot of it has all been forced into one
area of the city so for the most part
majority of the city is very good and
you won't see that many homeless people
except like here or there in Center City
but there's this one neighborhood called
Kensington where
um has kind of gotten out of control
because basically there used to be
um like 10 years ago 12 years ago 15
years ago there wasn't many like
Philadelphia wasn't that developed
because people just for the most part
moved away and it was very empty
um but 12 15 years ago it started to
redevelop in a lot of the places in
Northeast Philly started to
um develop and a lot of that was uh like
old warehouses that were turned into
Lofts which are very nice for the most
part and um when that happened that
forced a lot of the uh drug trade or a
lot of the
um homeless population out of these
places that once were abandoned and
because there's not many places left for
them to go or to hide away they're
forced out into one section of the city
called Kensington and Kensington is
notorious for just being kind of a [ __ ]
heap of political and just problems and
there's just one Street in particular
where kind of every like homeless and
did all the drug problems are forced so
it's not the best but
ever the the mayor that we have
currently is kind of an idiot and we're
uh we're hoping to get someone better
soon because he doesn't do much like he
literally just doesn't do anything
which is just like good and bad
yeah that's enough of that rant I'm
seeing some very promising pictures of
of Kensington on Google
yeah so East Kensington is good
Kensington is a long
um I think it's Allegheny Street it's
like the the worst part but basically
the railroad tracks divide
um sort of the good and bad oh yeah okay
as usual
yeah but yeah I mean at least you know
it's not could be worse could be worse
I mean yeah the main thing is that like
at least it's in one section that's
easier to control so if someone does
actually enact very wide the systematic
things to change these problems at least
they can do it very easily in one spot
um but there are some great people in
Philadelphia and great programs that I
know that have tried to
um step in and do and enact change with
themselves which is great
um otherwise uh uh I it's not too much
of my forte to know everything about
what's going on up there hmm
um but yeah I mean even in the like
worse sections of Philly you're still
going to find super dense row homes and
everything hmm yeah I'm seeing these
like uh
uh in some is some places anyway like
great great Sun Windows like gun gun
victim shrines like it's
yeah no not the best yeah
um Philly is interesting because a lot
of a lot of
um older sections of the city used to
have like bars and windows and some of
them have just remained because they no
one ever took them off but Kensington is
probably the one spot where I'd say yeah
bars and windows probably mean something
yeah how about this this looks other
than other than the issues apparent on
uh like I see socially she was like this
seems like a decent neighborhood in the
sense that like there's stuff to do so
it's not just like a [ __ ] suburb oh
yeah like if you want to see my favorite
neighborhood
um you can look at Manayunk or it's uh
m-a-n-a junk y-u-n-k
um that one is super cool because it
looks like San Francisco but it's
Philadelphia okay because it's too it's
super hilly and there's an elevated
train line that goes through it
um it's very unique
ah okay all right it does look nice
yeah it looks like yeah there's an old
there's an old bridge that's not used
anymore that goes across it that
actually SEPTA is thinking of reusing
again which is big arch bridge but the
orange with the green uh the green steel
riveted things
uh uh no that one's good
um but there's a there's the big
concrete arch bridge that goes across
the Schuylkill
um that's uh that one uh used to be a an
electrified train line
um but then was cut back in the 80s
because of budget cuts
um uh it's now a historic penkoid
Viaduct
yes uh but the the the one you were
looking at there with the green rivets
and everything that one's still used
that one's Regional Rail um and there's
a train there roughly every 30 minutes
during the day that's that's nice yeah I
mean there there's hope actually like
when it comes to the US okay lots of
people actually uh in Europe at least in
like uh Transit oriented communities
people just like you know just go like
yeah to America yeah it's done it's it's
over like they're never coming at it but
I mean it's not quite true though
because like America like you're still
richest Rich As [ __ ] right so if you if
America puts Americans put their minds
to something they can be very easy to
accomplish it they just have to oh yeah
do it right but yeah like if Philly and
a lot of these cities are good examples
of like either it is possible to do this
stuff yeah but yeah but then the problem
is that like everyone said well you have
like a Robert noses who also also wields
the financial and executive power of the
American
State I guess
yeah well I'm going to be the Robert
Moses of the opposite direction I'm
going to be making some background deals
to get that rail line not to get a
highway yeah
Yeah well yeah I mean if it's I mean
America is going through uh maybe Reese
can also comment on this uh from the
Canadian perspective but like America
seems to be coming through he's coming
going through this like uh
Transportation Renaissance like stuff is
not getting demolished but built which
is shocking to me
yes very slowly and surely
um stuff is being built play some places
faster than others
um like honestly the most impressive one
to me has been Denver
um Denver
um 20 years ago did not have a regional
rail system now they have a regional
rail system that's being built out and
they have a light rail system that is
debatably good that's Denver Colorado
yes
um there yeah Denver has built uh
they've built a lot actually for easy
you want to talk about it I'll be right
back let me grab some a drink
yeah Denver is uh Denver you know has
built up this uh fairly substantial uh
rail system
of course not uh not without its its
problems of course as uh as these things
tend to be but uh yeah you know they
spent a lot of money built uh built a
rail system the service is not amazing
though and you know you look at some of
the frequencies and you've got like a
train every half hour every hour yeah
but like I mean it it exists right so
that's that's step one and they've
successfully completed step one trains
exist in Denver and they run
yeah I mean uh
to be fair I think
my opinion is that you know any serious
City basically anywhere America is
included has trains you know it has a
rail system I think that uh I wouldn't
necessarily I wouldn't phrase it as step
one I'd say you've you have exited
um
some some stage which I won't name
because uh it's it's primordial
basically
um you have uh you have a rail system
now that's kind of the basic expectation
for city of like I don't know Denver has
will be four or five million people in
the metro area
um so like rail system yeah you should
have that
it's uh expectation
um some of the services have been pretty
popular the air Rail Link
has been really successful in Denver
because the airport is off to the east
Zoo mountains it's super gigantic I
think it's like the largest airport by
land area in the world it's it's
enormous so getting out there on the
train is convenient and so it's become
quite popular hmm yeah yeah uh well
that's I mean that's that's that's great
I mean it's finally something I mean
that's that's I mean that's that's
really what I'm at going like like just
just do it it's okay it's okay just just
do it it's fine something please and and
they do and uh actually Canada
uh Canada has Canada has never had
particularly bad public transportation
if I'm correct so you guys yeah it's
it's more you know in line with what you
would see in Europe I mean there's a lot
of problems obviously but at you know on
the basic level the bus has come there
are trains in the big cities they run
often hmm it's good yeah okay there's
issues but uh but yeah like people here
take transit you're growing up going to
school you get on the bus take the bus
to high school this is very very
normal part of the culture there isn't
like oh I wouldn't get on a bus uh type
of thing yeah I mean I also found that
weird actually that like At first I was
like when I first heard that like like
you know in like American movies are
like you know the bus what I'm like what
you know my direction was like you know
when the character is like you're taking
the bus I'm like yeah he's taking the
bus
and and then you know oh it's a bad
thing there okay I see yeah I think it's
so important for kind of social cohesion
right like I remember when I took the
bus to high school and went through some
like industrial apartment so we'd be
like people like going to school uh with
our with our textbooks and stuff and
there would be all the like iron workers
and stuff going to the industrial park
and you just otherwise you often don't
have those interactions with with people
like in all kinds of careers and in all
stages of life and so I think the public
transit is so important for that for not
creating you know like a class system
Society basically yeah yeah like
literally just put everyone in a metal
tub together
um
yeah uh actually yeah one of the uh the
bad things about Suburbia actually is
that is that uh you are
uh like people are segregated based on
their based on their social status so
you know you can uh yeah like I think I
think not just Dykes had this video
about like um one of his latest videos
anyway he made the point that like uh
there's no there are no third places uh
in the uh in places like the US
in many places like the uh inside the US
that is I'm sorry I'm a bit like
I've been streaming since 8 30 so I'm
late it's late late late late at night
oh no no it's 4 30 no I'm just uh it's
just I've been I have hit the eight hour
streaming Mark and I'm still going to
have a debate in like half an hour and
then I'm gonna have Dylan burns on and
then I'm going to then I'm going to uh
call it a day
debate with who uh oof uh yeah um there
was this I I'm gonna actually link it to
if you want there is this guy who had
the debate against Sam Cedar he's a an
objectivist so-called which is basically
a an end cap but like he insists that
sounds uh that sounds incredibly silly
oh that's so I just can't imagine
labeling myself as that's something like
that well yeah
something weird some people do
apparently but like uh he he had this
debate with Sam Cedar where people in
San Francisco's chat called him
infertile and he got insulted and some
cedar you know sorted out anyway uh they
were like I I just watched the debates
he linked me and you know it's gonna be
I think gonna be a fun time but uh
oh boy anyway
um
whenever we I'm sorry feel free feel
free to continue the discussion I I will
jump in I'm just on the back foot in
this moment
um I just put a bunch of pictures in the
chat if you want to look of Denver
um both of the regional rail and the
station because I was there in September
oh yeah the Union Station in Denver
looks uh looks great it's a cool design
it looks great I'm kind of frustrated
it's a Terminal Station but yeah
yeah I mean you're asking a lot for them
to have been thinking like oh yeah like
like we need to do it through station
like this this would have been I think a
level of sophistication that I'm not
sure
uh was so this this wavy like the
station with the wavy uh yes that's
that's an end station
oh come on
come on
yeah they did it because of there was
some development going up next to it and
they didn't do it through a station but
theoretically they could knock down one
building and then go under another and
then they would have a through a station
but uh we'll see let's see five ten
years if they ever need to the biggest
the funniest goofiest thing is this uh
the third picture I posted is so I rode
Amtrak to Denver I rode from San
Francisco or Emeryville to Denver on the
California Zephyr and um
when I did that the Zephyr has to back
into Denver Union because it can't pull
forward because then it would have to
back out again it doesn't have a cab
cars or whatever yeah because it's a
long distance train it goes thousands of
miles
um so the uh The Zephyr has to uh has to
go into a y and then slowly back in with
a conductor standing at the second level
of the super liner just telling the uh
engineer when to stop backing in
so that the the the place you're talking
about is the third picture right because
I I have that on currently on the screen
no next one next one ah yeah oh this big
thing okay yeah so those are those are
called super liners those are double
decker train cars
no but they're not like they're not like
half-assed like European double deckers
they're fully double decker and you can
stand straight up with room between your
head and the ceiling like on these Alan
is tall so that is that is quite the
statement yeah like like I don't feel
cramped in these let me find a picture
of uh my ride on the Zephyr
um
wait how how tall are you though because
I don't have a problem on like European
trees usually I'm like the American
would be six one I think 1383. let's see
I'm six four so
I'm 93 centimeters so okay well you're
you're 100
193. 193 yeah not missing a meter there
about three feet tall
the pictures don't really convey size
usually so I I have a few pictures of
the inside of the Zephyr like here's the
lounge car Lounge car is dope I love the
lounge car
uh let's see oh that yeah the timer on
wheels
essentially there is well there is a
diner actually wait here's a better
picture uh or as my girlfriend calls it
here's a Paul person picture of the
lounge car
oh yeah yeah that looks I think you sent
me it sent me this picture before it's
very nice yeah
yeah so it's it's like a lounge there's
another car that's attached uh one up
that's a uh there is a diner
um
where there's uh I think there's like
eight eight tables on either side of the
car and then there's a kitchen in the
center
um and that was a fun part of the trip
because that that forces people to sort
of talk to each other yeah okay
and you have to they they they sit you
down for dinner if you have a sleeper
and then you basically get to seated
with a bunch of other people that are
also in Sleepers yeah okay it's like oh
[ __ ] I got to the chat seat again yeah
which is very funny because I made some
friends when I was riding there was one
guy that didn't drink alcohol usually do
you want my drink and I was like yes
please
oh no
oh God I I recently took a trip though
uh um by the way Hungarian Railways are
[ __ ] terrible I'm going to talk about
them a bit uh they're they're like I
took I mean terrible in the sense that
like it could be so much better but like
I took a trip from like from uh Budapest
all the way to Germany and uh
the the dining car is used to be this
beautiful I'm gonna find a picture of
this beautiful [ __ ] uh
Spanish interior design
uh red like this crimson red uh interior
plush interior or like you know textile
interior
and
[ __ ] it if I can find like a better oh
I'm Gonna Make You kind of sad because
we had talgos in the U.S and we're
slowly getting rid of them because of
the new Siemens equipment and some of
them had beautiful Interiors yeah I used
to I used to take those quite frequently
on the Cascades route from Vancouver to
Seattle I'm jealous because I never got
to ride them and the cafe car you still
could you could I think right I don't
know
um because I think book your ticket
yeah so so um I'm trying to find there's
a like the cafe car is the most
beautiful part of those
um I I put out the picture on my screen
about I found a final a good picture
like these things work [ __ ] gorgeous
and the second picture especially the
second picture with the golden trim
that has very much what I call this the
style of uh winga dinga which is the
like ad Chrome and anything shiny to
everything which is a good yeah yeah
yeah it's very much those like rolling
[ __ ]
30s feel to it and they [ __ ] ruined
it like wait let me just um yeah the new
car
I believe this is the same
um is the same color [ __ ] anyway it
looks like this whether this is the same
car type or not I put it out on the on
the on the picture on the
stream and they turned this into this
like white blue design
which looks objectively inferior uh
because this is the new like core
renovation project which sucks because
you know uh yeah that's frustrating yeah
like hunger yeah Hungarian Railways
approach the problem like the austrians
did it the right way they were like okay
we want this this sort of sorry
that doesn't look terrible but it just
it misses all the the really fancy stuff
yeah if you compare it to the red and
the gold yeah I mean it sort of looks
like a an unport waiting waiting yeah
yeah so I'll be right back I gotta help
my partner get her bike out of the uh
the biker I'll feel free it's okay here
is that so like as I said before like uh
in like in Austria they they had like an
idea of what kind of service they want
and then they said okay what sort of
equipment what sort of Rolling Stock
fits this service oh real jet okay so
let's do that and then the Hungarian oh
yeah that's great yeah it's [ __ ]
awesome and the Hungarian Railways
instead was like hmm we're gonna do a
domestically made car because we said so
where could we fit this thing where
could this thing run and then now we
have this god-awful project which was
shot down already uh now the age of
crisis has hit Hungary so there's no
money for anything including rail so the
project is killed maybe overhauls will
be will be uh done properly on the
existing Rolling Stock I'm not sure I
took the train to Germany like the
trains were maintained like [ __ ]
uh so yeah take uh thankfully like
Austin hey at least you can at least you
could take the tree yeah yes yes yes
that's that's very true yeah but like
I'm just approaching it from a European
perspective of like [ __ ] why isn't it
good like you know where is the
emergency perspective is why isn't it
there is there is there are some good uh
the rocky Mountaineer just got some new
Statler bi-level like cars for their
it's an Excursion train but it's just
they're so beautiful I think um honestly
something like that should probably just
be made standard in North America we get
a huge loading gauge got a picture
uh let me see if I can send something
and then I gotta
I gotta go soon unfortunately
oh yeah I think I have a debate coming
up in 20 minutes so uh
yeah you need to prepare oh I'm already
prepared I I know everything that has
ever been said and written so it's fine
I've read everything this is a
this is a real this is a real picture
okay this is uh this is the upper deck
oh
nice yeah it's uh it's Swanky damn okay
this this this looks French
this just looks like something like
French people would use like around
Paris or something
if the Train's gonna look like that I'm
not gonna
hey all right I'll take it yeah okay
sounds good to me yeah wow super nice
and then you even get a little pillow
yeah
oh yeah the pleasures of rail travel
yeah why can't we have this in like
central eastern if there aren't like the
only things the only the only uh more
exotic things are these like these like
uh panoramic Swiss cars that sometimes
run from Poland to Switzerland and then
that's it
otherwise we have to make do with the
ice terrible the railage that's terrible
you know we're we're suffering oh the
real chat you the race ew the the uh the
the ice
whatever
this is you know the newer ones I do
think are of not the most attractive I
think it's kind of crazy that the ice4
isn't higher speed and
and yeah it's amazing that France still
doesn't use emu's yeah well it really
committed to the we're gonna have power
cars and and this is the best way to do
it even though everyone else does not do
this except for America yeah
uh you know like uh actually the the IC
e4s I think I think it was also like a I
think it was like a missed opportunity
to put them like to like put them up to
like you know high speed but generally
speaking now they're retrofitting them
so they'll be able to do
260 kilometers per hour instead of 250
which was the original
oh big upgrade yeah
yeah it's better than nothing yeah
because like the problem became that
like
um they built these new tracks to like
300 kilometers per hour and then they
ran the ice4 on them which you can which
could only be 250 it's like why
seems incredibly nonsensical yeah I mean
it's the sense in it the original sense
in it like it kind of makes sense from
the perspective that this sort of train
since it was 250 and it didn't require
any sort of like special [ __ ] and uh
and uh
essentially they could like Mass produce
it quickly and relatively cheaply and
they needed a lot of trains like now and
um
and so in that from that perspective yes
but every other consideration is like no
not really it's it's decent but still
you know yeah I love the uh the Italian
high-speed trains oh yeah yeah
the agv is
because you know all finally made
it's beautiful awesome egv
agv okay sorry
yeah oh let me put this up to the screen
this looks Neato
yeah it's uh you know that Italian
Italian influence nice red beautiful oh
I'm looking at the I'm looking at the
gray version the silver one yeah oh yeah
that's nice oh yeah I'm sorry silver
yeah yeah oh yeah here's the uh here's
the red one oh yeah
this is indeed
yeah I actually saw these trains in
where was I don't like when we when I
took the train from Madrid to Barcelona
I saw I saw I think not these These are
the newest one but like I saw the freche
Rosas in Zaragoza
at the station like a bunch like I think
one or two of them were like standing
there because they were doing the tests
uh like the track tests and now they're
actually like the service has launched
yeah and now you can yeah and now
there's like dirt [ __ ] cheap like
Madrid Barcelona uh train tickets like
for like that's what
that's what yeah yeah absolutely
that's great
win for society you know like yeah we
always talk there's so much there's so
much negativity in the world but like
that's such a win it's such a way to
yeah to get on the eight Euro high-speed
train from Madrid to Barcelona which is
a fresher of seven thousand dude oh
that's it's [ __ ] great yeah but we're
talking we're talking about the the
fresher of such trains and how they're
smashing uh we have the red one on
screen currently
oh yeah those are those look good uh we
should have bought those or the ice
threes instead of the alstones huh uh
because the alstum availas are not doing
good for us how come like what's the
issue I've heard this is because Amtrak
has some kind of ridiculous no it's
great requirements no it's because it's
the French
um
[Music]
I mean this is the nicest away so the
reason why Alston is annoying with their
high-speed trains is because alstum is
used to working with sncf specifically
and especially when they're developing
something
um I have a friend that's in Amtrak's
research and Engineering division so
like when they uh when they run the new
trains to try to get them um uh I guess
certified uh this person is always on
the train sets with the sets of
computers and whatnot running all the
data et cetera et cetera
um the problem is with the current
availity of Liberties which they're
called is that
alstone has has one computer model for
them but the computer model doesn't
cover all conditions that the train is
going to run through okay the
um fra which is the United States like
uh government agency that regulates all
train stuff needs the model computer
model to be able to cover all conditions
where this thing will run so the fra is
asking Alston where are your other
models for this and alstone is saying
that we don't have those we only have
this one and they're saying well what
what do you do in this like certain
condition and they're like well we don't
know
if only we do at home yeah and then
Alston will just blame uh uh Alston will
just blame U.S track conditions which
granted like there are certain areas
where the track is not perfect but it is
the Northeast Corridor so it's actually
pretty good yeah there's some truth to
that but
yeah like there is truth to that not all
the US track is perfect especially
because you're this this specific
Corridor which is running on is like
very old and has been upgraded over time
so there's a lot of Legacy stuff that's
still left over
um but it's just that uh alstum does not
like
developing extra stuff and now they have
to and they're they're annoyed by it and
then there was some issue with the um
pantographs that were at high speeds
they were bouncing on the uh overhead
wire because that's that's fun yeah
look good yeah they look good there is a
picture of them somewhere
I have it on screen right now they uh
yeah they do it's also like a power
brake system right so the cores don't
have Traction in them
yep
yeah so I
I
forget
[Music]
older like tjv Brazil the ones that have
some power in the first carriages as
well yeah they're just not interesting
um so we made the mistake of basically
being beta testers for the French
um because uh the the Evalia Liberties
are the first of their class meaning uh
they these have not even showed up in
Europe yet they're literally just
showing up in Europe
um alstom just unveiled new ones in
Europe to run on the LGV
um and so the Evalia Liberties are the
first ones so that means we're doing all
the prototyping for the French yeah well
hey that's that sounds like a sound
business model
so we got kind of I think Amtrak kind of
got suckered into doing this stuff but
uh that's a that's another conversation
I've gotta I've gotta go in a minute but
but worth a
Eurostar E300 because that's like the
craziest to me that's the craziest
high-speed train out there because it's
it's got the British loading gauge so
it's like quite narrow and it's got like
a funny shape to it and then let me send
a picture of one of them I think I have
take this one
um they are they're just so funny to me
I forget if they I think they still run
but they are being replaced by those um
Siemens villaros like kind of oh this
files apparently too large let me see if
I can put this one in here
um they're they're being replaced now
but they they're like 20 cars long they
have they have part of the powers in the
first Carriage they like the first
passenger Carriage is 50 passenger 50
power
um and I believe they're able to be
split in half in the channel so that
they can they can shuttle half of it
away if there's a fire or something and
they have third rail pickups because
when they originally ran them when they
originally ran them they didn't have a
High Speed Line in the UK uh they built
the new I believe it's just the LGB Nord
um that runs to like Leo and then
Northwest to Calais in France but uh in
the UK it took them took them like 20
years to get a high speed line to the
channel built so until then they ran
over the conventional third rail
Southwestern lines yeah and now they're
building the hs2 the high speed 2 I mean
best of luck
yeah it's a it's a really questionable
it's questionable a lot of
a lot of it's like credible amount of
tunneling under like arms okay I mean
questionable like the UK itself nowadays
so I don't know well the problem is is
the problem with high speed 2 is that
it's built in a way to make nimby's
happy but the problem is is that if you
build things to make nimby's happy you
will get stupid outcomes yeah okay yeah
yeah
um it also has like a it has like a 10
kilometer new rail tunnel into London
which stub ends uh you know like it
doesn't connect to hs1 which also has a
pretty long rail tunnel into London it's
just incredibly wasteful I think to
build these giant tunnels and then
let them running into terminals so well
you know what they say the Sun never
sets on the British Rail System I don't
know it's uh I think it's said a while
ago to be honest yeah well at the a
that's true well for me the sun set on
on uh on the UK in 2016 I think May with
the brexit referendum anyway we'll be
we'll be happy to have them back once
they figure it out uh so uh I think uh I
think I'll have to go and take a break
now before the debate but uh it was very
nice to have both of you on
yeah thanks for having us on of course
and once again for people in chat this
is Ellen Fisher and uh Rhys Martin AKA
RM Transit they can be found under the
same name on YouTube so you know go and
subscribe to them because we need to
spread the word
thank you for for having me as well uh
Adam and uh congrats on uh big subscribe
thank you big big number me me big happy
bigly
it's excellent yes I think um it's it's
really good to have people who were were
talking about public transportation have
a big success on YouTube
um so yeah it's uh have a good debate uh
don't uh don't get uh too too feisty you
know I'll behave myself sportsmanlike
um and uh and yeah
to stay away yeah yeah so thank you guys
for coming on and I'll be seeing you
around
all right bye-bye
oh that was a nice there was a nice
discussion all right people uh what I'm
gonna do now is
uh so what I'm gonna do now is I'm gonna
take a 10 minute break and afterwards
I'm going to have done Norton on the
debate's partner the objectivist and
that debate will go on I think for like
an hour or so and then in the end we're
gonna I'm gonna have Dylan burns on if
he's online and then we're gonna end the
stream but uh during the debate and from
this point on if you have any questions
I will still I'm still going to answer
them so feel free to ask them uh super
chats uh please because then I'll I'll
see the list
um
if you can or you can DM them DM them to
me on Discord I hope I won't forget uh
to check them uh but I will I think and
um yeah so I'm gonna take a 10 minute
break now then debate then Dylan Burns
meanwhile questions out uh feel free to
Super and uh
and uh uh yeah that's what we're going
to do so uh in in the meantime I'm going
to put the information board up
and I'm also going to
leave you in very good hands
thank you
all right hello everyone I am back
prepared for a fruitful civil discussion
about
uh
we'll see
all right
so
now the camera needs to be adjusted a
bit
there we go
so I'm going to call
hmm
I'm going to call our guy
I'm gonna put my phone on mute actually
because it's an early muted all right so
we're ready to roll
yes
okay
I'm calling
or call it
hello Dan
hi yeah hey can you hear me yes perfect
you sound very uh you sound your sound
is very high quality is what I'm trying
to say
uh
one second let's ask for some feedback
from the chat uh is it too loud is it
too quiet what are you saying can you
talk a bit then
Justin one two three too loud too soft
just right
uh testing testing
check one two
second okay apocalypse not now the kitty
is just decided to bother me at this
moment
so okay I think it's uh yeah I think I
think no one's complaining so we're fine
should I put you on screen or do you
prefer uh like we thought without with
or without a video
yeah let's do video okay uh you are on
the screen wait let me
there we go
and so this thing doesn't blur I can't
leave you here actually okay uh right so
you are I don't see you is there a way
for you to show up in uh Discord
on Discord I don't think so because OBS
is OBS is a OBS Hogs my camera but you
can you can look at the stream though
it's going to be it's going to be
delayed like on stream
my audio just switched to um
my iPhone instead of my laptop so I
could see you but let me switch it back
to
my uh
just a sec
all right
actually one second for me as well
okay
okay
hello hello
yeah I forgot my vitamin supplement so
uh yeah uh I I can hear it just fine
okay sorry when I turned my iPhone on
that messed up the settings but I think
it's back to the way it should be
oh no no worries whatsoever
so uh we're here to discuss our ideas
regarding uh
well let's uh I suppose we can open by
you describing uh where you're coming
from your position and uh if you if
there's anything else you want to talk
you want to tell the audience about
yourself
uh sure so I'm uh objectivist or at
least heavily influenced by objectivism
which is Ein rand's philosophy
and just to give a very brief summary of
it
she was in favor of Reason in the field
of epistemology as opposed to Faith so
she thought you should go by the
evidence of your senses and use logic
and reason to reach the truth
not rely on just feelings or emotions
but use your your logic and your reason
and then in ethics she's in favor of
favor of rational self-interest
or egoism sometimes she puts it as
selfishness but she has a distinct
meaning that she attaches to that term
it's not the conventional meaning of
selfishness she thinks people should
neither sacrifice themselves to others
nor sacrifice others to themselves
and we can talk more about that and then
in politics she's in favor of
laissez-faire capitalism and uh what
that means is the government should not
interfere in people's lives all it
should do is protect people
from Force now there should be a police
system to protect people from criminals
domestically and then there should be a
military to protect people from foreign
threats
and then a court system to peacefully
settle disputes between people
but that's it the government shouldn't
be uh taxing people uh taking money from
some to give to others redistributing
people's wealth regulating people
forcing them in various ways she's
against the initiation of force so all
there's tons of government programs that
would be done away with
in the kind of society she envisions
like Social Security
Medicare public education public roads
um United States Postal Service a
Government monopoly all of those would
be gone in her system so we don't have
anything close
to the uh system she advocated a lot of
people say we live in a kind of
capitalist society today but you would
say that's a straw man
um if you go back to the the 19th
century that's closer to the kind of
society that Iran advocated wasn't
perfect there's never been pure
capitalism but it was at least closer to
the kind of system she advocated so
that's a little sketch of her views and
then
I have a channel on YouTube where I
advocate her ideas I have lots of
discussions and debates if you want to
check it out
um it's youtube.com Dan norton1
or you can search for selfishness
projects that's an easy way to find it
and you also had a debate with Sam Cedar
about this correct a similar topic like
your objective yeah I've called Sam
Cedars show uh three or four times he
wasn't there the fourth time but
uh the first time was just to talk about
chat policy actually because I thought
people in his chat were being rude and I
wanted to talk about you know what what
policies are appropriate to that and
then that led to another uh call about a
week later where we talked about
objectivism generally and
um at the end of that call we talked
about some Island scenarios oh yes
well we didn't get into coconut Islands
on that call but um on my third call the
next time I picked up on the Island
theme and uh not not the coconut Islands
we because that's a vulgar example and
uh he didn't want to have a vulgar
example and I didn't really want to get
into a vulgar example myself
um so I chose a different kind of
islands example to talk about
and uh about halfway through that third
call he switched and gave his own
example which was a hiking example what
should you do if you're in this kind of
life or death survival emergency
scenario and that led to a discussion of
coercion the topic of coercion is really
the theme that was underlying
um my it was the whole theme of the
third call and much of the second call
so that's the the the topic of coercion
is one that's I think a fundamental one
or that concept coercion is fundamental
to political philosophy and I think it's
it's often misunderstood people think
something is coercive that is not or
something is not coercive that is and if
if we're not on the same page about that
we're gonna you know we're just kind of
talking past each other so I thought it
was important to drill down on that
concept and get clear on exactly what is
meant by it and we didn't actually reach
a agreement by the end of the discussion
but I think it was at least clear that
there was a deep difference here there's
even more fundamental issues like an
Ethics egoism is it appropriate to live
for yourself
or should you sacrifice yourself for the
sake of others which has political
implications and maybe be good to get
into some of those uh full ethic all
right whole issues uh okay so yeah right
uh sounds good to me then uh thank you
for the introduction and all uh I
suppose my audience knows my position so
you know my positions uh basically uh if
we want to be brief about it I would say
Social Democrat left side of that and
then we'll see category so I believe of
course in in the uh social Dem some new
interpretation of Social Democratic
model
um that we have in Europe in Western
Europe of course that model is no longer
sustainable because uh well the fall of
the nation state and all it's a whole
different discussion but generally I'm
found in this this uh this uh sort of
area a region of thinking
um actually I wanted to I wanted to
begin by
by asking you about one of the first
thing you said in your Society or like I
suppose you were talking about your
idealized Society you would have uh
basically so there would be a state and
there would be basic uh arms such as you
know a police and a justice system which
can process
disagreements which really is about the
foundation of society so but there are
there are also no taxes in the society
so how do you so how do you maintain
those services in your system
right so it would be through voluntary
means and there's various ways it could
be done voluntarily but I just want to
make one point
um before saying more about that I
should have mentioned in my intro which
is I am not an anarchist and objectivism
is opposed to Anarchy so I I noted in
your announcement about this call yeah I
mean so that was an objectivist I was a
bit flipping
anarcho-capitalist with extra steps I
think anarcho capitalists might be a
contradiction in terms because
capitalism requires a government I
believe to protect individual rights
whereas Anarchy is getting getting rid
of all governments and uh objectivism
definitely poses that it says there
should be a government but it should be
properly limited to protecting uh
individual rights that's
proper role which means protecting
people from the initiation of physical
Force so the access to voluntary I'm
sorry just just to jump in so it would
be a voluntary uh okay so the basic
services that in your system would be
kept up by voluntary donations by
individuals
right and that's one way I mean there
are other ways you can fund it other
than uh donations lotteries is is one
way which I think historically has
actually been used to fund governments
and maybe still is in certain places or
at certain levels maybe at local or
state levels there's State lottos
sometimes in the United States how does
that work especially if the government
would be much smaller the kind of
government I advocate there's not a huge
massive government apparatus to finance
if it's just restricted to these roles
of police courts and Military and my
concern though with such societies
though I I get the I get the uh the
Baseline idea and I and I appreciate it
uh my my issue like my fear like I see I
don't I don't have like a beef with
these ideas I just have concerns in the
sense that how would it work would it be
would it work for the average person and
with the consequences and what I see
an issue is you have a state which is
financed by donations
um what happens if so a police like a
law enforcement agency financed by a
small law enforcement agency minimum as
minimal as you can get that does its job
you know that is not necessarily a
strong force like if you look at police
forces in the U.S they're highly
militarized in Europe less so but see
but there's still a formidable Force if
it's a minimalist system with a
minimalist service we're funded by
donations and lotteries
how do you counter risks of people just
bending together in a militia and just
gunning down the police and declaring
themselves the new rulers of the of the
area I suppose armies wouldn't exist in
your world either so it's just the
police force and the justice system
necessary to facilitate
commerce between people
well there would be Army I mean if you
consider that as part of the military
like the the Navy the Army the Air Force
all the Armed Forces uh those would
exist to protect people from foreign
threats and then domestically there
would be a police force but people have
to proportion their donations or their
Lottery
participation to the threat so I don't
think there would be much of a threat
much less of a threat I think there
would be in a capitalist system I think
there would be much less crime but
whatever level of crime there is people
would should donate accordingly so if
there's if there's only a tiny bit of
crime in your local area then you should
have donate some amounts if you see it
starts to get worse then maybe you
should up your donations to accommodate
the greater threats so you proportion
your donations accordingly it's not a
one-size-fits-all it has to be the same
cookie cutter level of support
everywhere you you you read the facts on
the ground so basically you use your
self-interest in accordingly act right
so basically basically in these with
these fundings like with these voluntary
fundings would be based on people's
personal perceptions of the situation so
if they perceive that there is more
crime in the area of course they'll fund
the police more but how does this system
account for issues such issues such as
problems with perception so for example
currently in unconservative media
there's this the new the new uh Mania is
that you know Democratic cities or I
guess crime infested hell holes crime is
going up crime is up up up you know
um cities are burning Etc
well that was BLM but anyway uh the
general perception is that crime is up
even though it is objectively untrue in
most areas in some areas there has been
a small uptick but nothing that would
Dem that would necessitate such an
uproar so clearly this is being
manufactured uh uh in by uh by
capitalist corporations you know like
Murdoch's media Empire Fox teams Etc so
if someone in control of such a media
Empire decides to facilitate false
perceptions of people to try to
manipulate uh their spending you know uh
how would you uh how is your system
account for that like there wouldn't be
my concern is that there wouldn't be an
impartial
body that would review the facts and be
like okay look this is these are the
facts and so this is why we're gonna
spend x amount on the on the on the uh
on on these Services it's it's
completely democratized allocated to the
people I think and I think that does not
account for for uh malicious actors how
would you how would you how would in
your system how would your system react
to such militia sectors who give people
so these false Impressions on purpose
maybe for some sort of monetary gain
like if some some if some company
manufacturers you know defense equipment
or something like that then it's their
interest you drama fear to drum of
Hysteria and uh
that way you'll get resources going to
the wrong places so how does how would
you counteract that
well one that I have on this is you need
to use your own judgment so there are
certain uh cities like I've heard in San
Francisco where they have these policies
where criminals are allowed to just
engage in these Smash and grab behaviors
so they can walk into a pharmacy a CVS
um or uh some some store and just uh
loot the place basically and the policy
of the city is that the police aren't
allowed to stop that what's happening I
mean I think that's that's a terrible
policy that's that's a um that would be
crimes the election of Duty on the part
of the government they're not protecting
people's rights and people I mean if it
gets bad enough I think you know there
can be a revolution and that's what
happened in the American Revolution the
government the government was not
protecting people or it was infringing
the rights and it got to a certain point
where the the American colonists said
you know this is tyranny we have to
overthrow this and if things get so bad
uh in America like if it just devolves
into rioting and looting you know know
that hopefully doesn't come together
which city allows shoplifting
essentially like where exactly does this
I I believe it was in the San Francisco
Bay Area there might be others too but
it was just the policy I I think nope
excuse me what's the name of this policy
because I doubt I don't know the name of
I don't know the name of the policy okay
we can look at it but I I highly doubt
that like that a
um oh yeah I think what you're referring
to is is D is um
um
yes there's it's not decriminalization
but like or actually maybe it was like
the they they changed the limit of of of
of value that the police will
incarcerate you for uh shoplifting uh
you know in relation to so for example
if you steal a candy bar you will not go
to jail you'll get fined Etc or
something else I think that's what
you're referring to uh but uh in the in
but those policies uh it's not not the
disc not the topic of the debate but
those policies actually are good because
uh of course if you tend to uh if you
look at it from the perspective of a
hysterical Fox news report such as San
Francisco you know very liberal places
Democrats you know they have legalized
crime now you can just shoplift and the
police won't take you well these uh I
believe you're referring to once again
the the policies where uh it's it's just
that they won't throw you into jail for
four or five years if you if you steal a
Snickers bar so there are other
so instead of like a punishment based
you know measures you know they they can
they can uh they can just use other
measures which are which which have been
shown to be more beneficial so cities
aren't generally run by complete idiots
sure there I mean okay uh or in some
other sense they are they might be
stupid but they aren't idiots so uh
usually at least so these policies uh
let's let's substance change
sensationalize this is what I'm saying
though in your Society
um would be a Howard's laws be made
so how how would the framework of law be
agreed upon so how would you say how
would a group of people decide okay for
stealing the Snickers bar you'll either
get like you know two days of community
service or 10 years of jail so like who
how would it be decided
well there there is a legislature and it
can be a complex procedure to figure out
exactly how laws are
um made and you know what appropriate
penalties are for breaking law but one
way laws will not be made I can say in
my Society is just by unlimited majority
rule so if you that you might call that
mob accuracy uh rule of the mob where
you get a majority to votes uh for a law
and whatever they want goes so if
majority wants to enslave or or to tax
the rich with taxes uh that's not
legitimate just because a large number
of people want something doesn't mean
it's legitimate so laws should be
structured so they protect people from
the initiation of force and you can't
have a gang of people gang up on a
minority and violate their rights like
you know in Athens ancient Athens the
Athenian assembly famously voted to
um put Socrates to death because he
allegedly he was corrupting the youth by
going around Athens and having
conversations that were challenging to
some people you can't just get a mob
together and vote people uh uh vote
people's uh rights away that's not an
appropriate way to conduct Society or
make laws so it's not mob rule it's not
unlimited majority rules uh so it's a
limited uh kind of uh representational
system but who who would it enforce the
details of it are complicated who would
enforce who would enforce these limits
though so if there's a society and the
majority of people say oh you know that
group over there they must be they must
be kicked out of here they must be even
exterminated who knows uh we're now
gonna go and do it and then so if and
then you know they they say oh actually
the law laws the laws on the book say
that we cannot do it well who is going
to stop us you know this this little
meager police force that's that's uh set
up but it also meant partially by us
that's infiltrated by us so to speak uh
and this judicial system which which
I mean without the police I mean they're
just what are they what are they they're
gonna do so if a mob if a violent mob
and of course there's an overlap between
for example far right sentiment and
being a police officer so if these
people in your Society get together and
say we're going to
you know Purge black people from this
area then how how what would what would
stop them is what I'm what I'm asking so
like mob rule is illegal sure but I mean
things are illegal until people say it's
illegal or until someone can enforce
that and who would enforce that if your
police force say is also inundated with
the people who also want to do the thing
oh wouldn't they wouldn't things just
fall apart basically and we will revert
to back into like tribalism
like that's my main concern here
okay so I mean there are there are no
magic Solutions
um but uh there are Optimal Solutions
and I think you mentioned before what a
me what is a meager police force going
to do in the face of something well it
shouldn't be meager I mean if you sense
that it's meager and meager is relative
to what the threat is then you should
support it some more it's in your
interest to beef up your contributions
to the police perhaps
police also need people right and those
people will inevitably come out of the
community uh and so okay so let's let's
stick with the example of most the
majority of people in your area decide
that okay we're gonna
we're gonna go and shoot the rich and
then we're gonna take their money okay
um now those rich people will not have
representation like those rich people
will not be part of the police force so
chances are the echelons of people you
know
um who will be down for this idea will
also have a strong representation in the
police force so in this sense it is uh
like the the the local place is
infiltrated so they they decide okay you
know what we're just gonna form this mob
and including the some members of the
police force and we're gonna march on
the Villas or something and then we're
gonna take take their stuff who's going
to stop us oh this police force which we
are outnumbered ten to one so then where
do we go from there like the who who
saves the day uh because in my as far as
I see it they they're just gonna like
this would be true mob rule in the sense
that they can just do whatever they want
uh because there is no strong
overarching framework like if my issue
is that if you leave everything down to
Grassroots people Etc well then that's
going to be there's going to be a with
that overarching institutions strong
overarching institutions currently it it
would just result in complete uh chaos
or we'll just refer back to tribalism so
how would that mobile be stopped which
is part police officers part just people
with guns
okay I'm not sure I fully got the
scenario but one thought on all of this
is there is a last line of defense which
is yourself so you have the right to
self-defense you have the and that
includes the right to bear arms sure
sure if there are like 200 people with
guns outside of your home and you're
there with your family so the the mob is
the mob say 500 people gather they're
all like okay you know what we're gonna
we're gonna take everything that they
that the those people over there the
rich people own and many of them are
police officers because this is like a
you know they are they are also part of
that Echelon Society so they march on
the on the on the uh Villas and now
there are 500 people with torches and
guns outside of your home so at that
point your chances of survival would be
rather slim and they would just break in
kill you maybe you would shoot some of
them but they would just roll through
the entire area and so my concern is
like this would be the true mobro if you
don't have any institutions above you
that they were just uh they would just
come and take it like if if there's no
if the law enforcement agency also
depends on the people that directly is
what I'm saying and not some not some
overarching structure of Law and and
government
so how would you solve this problem in
your Grassroots scenario
also I mean also one second I forgot to
add what if people deliberately sabotage
the the the the the the police force
beforehand so if they come together and
they talk okay you know what we're gonna
we're gonna say that we feel so much
safer we're gonna decrease our our or
we're just gonna decrease our
contribution to the police force it
becomes underfunded and then we're gonna
strike so how do you how so how do you
counteract such malicious actors in your
world
or such scheming okay you raised a lot
there I'm not sure I can retain all of
that just ask about feel free to address
whichever you want and you can ask of
course follow-up like uh okay uh so let
me just make okay I'll just make one
point and then you know if it doesn't
address something you can come back okay
um so one thought is if people people
can be are corrupt setting up some
institution some other institution which
it seems like maybe you have in mind
some a super powerful government to
oversee well why aren't people going to
be corrupt in that institution there's
no way you can
um magically you know eliminate
corruption everywhere you just have to
be eternally Vigilant and try to
optimize things so as for some mob that
wants to attack I mean there's also
something like private security if
you're wealthy
um many wealthy people they live in
gated communities which are guarded you
know beyond just the the Baseline police
which everyone has access to they might
hire private security which is going to
stop make it much harder at least for
people to come and just loot their loot
their neighborhood so there are some
other measures that people can take but
you know if the police get so corrupt it
sounds like maybe you're describing a
society at a very uh Advanced stage of
Decay where you know the the police have
been
infiltrated
um by by corrupt people who are
themselves criminals
um when you know the police are supposed
to be stopping criminals well I mean if
Society is decaying to a certain point
like with American Revolution you know
has kind of reboots start over again
maybe
I have a revolution I try to go escape
flee the society if this Society has
gotten so bad that you know life is just
unbearable that's when you try to get
out of the place but I think in a in a
normal functioning not uh stage four
cancer society you know these kinds of
scenarios are are not going to be
happening yeah so I suppose um so what
I'm referring to is a system of checks
and balances so the reason why for
example in the US there are uh just just
uh I'm not an expert on this but I'm
just going to give like a basic example
so like certain arms of the government
like sure everything is corrupt to some
extent obviously but uh not like people
cannot just do whatever they want
because there are sort of checks on that
so they'll eventually come up to a
barrier which can be moved eventually
but like it the whole system is like
it's the checks and balances right that
like no one no one can do everything
because if everyone can do everything
then you'll end up in a situation like
first off at that point your Society
collapses pretty much and then you you
end up after Society collapses you
usually in the chaos afterwards you
don't end up with the Utopia you end up
with a
feudal at best Society where it is
strongest and the most cunning and the
cruelest ETC they Rose to the top
because I mean you know in in a world of
chaos and violence it's generally those
people with interested up and so
but I think I think we're is there
something you wanted to add because
otherwise I think
otherwise I think we can move on to the
coercion aspect of of your society which
might be the interest more interesting
part of the discussion but just to
reiterate my point is that I miss and
favorite respond of course my point uh
or my worry here is that in your Society
uh if it's everything is up to the
people well then you're building on
quicksand because people can be people
are malleable people can be influenced
this way or that way even by militia
sectors or by non-malicious actors and
you can create these like false
realities that for people to inhabit
basically if you if you look at like
Mega Republicans like try talk to one
like they don't live on planet Earth so
with people's large masses of people are
prone to instability and if you just
throw the Reigns between the horses my
point is that you're gonna have things
falling apart real quick
so how I mean I think there has been um
there has been a lot of problems in the
U.S recently you mentioned the magnet
Republicans and I think of the January 6
riots and you know the challenging of
the election results and uh I mean I
think that's that's all very bad and I
oppose that as well as the the BLM riots
uh that were going on uh prior to that I
think both the left and the rights has
serious problems and in some ways
there's not really much of a distinction
and I don't really put myself on that
left right Spectrum if you think of
certainly not if you think of someone
like Trump in the mega Republicans is
right that's that's that's totally
opposed to to what it what I stand for
but I think unfortunately Society is
getting is decaying a lot and it's also
very far from the kind of society we had
back in the 19th century whether it was
much uh a better rule of law and a
tremendous progress uh science we got
rid of slavery slavery was bought
abolished the the fundamental principles
of capitalism which were set out in the
Declaration of Independence
there's men are created equal and have
their rights to life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness uh that became
implemented more and more consistently
over time unfortunately tragically
blacks were not given those rights but
people realized that inherent in those
principles what was that you know we
should free the blacks it's this is not
right so capitalism got rid of that
Injustice it took time for people to
work out consistently more consistently
those those fundamental principles of
how do you exactly hear adhere to the
principles of capitalism but
unfortunately I think in the 20th
century we've departed from that we had
the growth of the states
the the rise of the progressives the
so-called progressives I think it was
actually regressive uh because it was
more coercion which we can talk about
the the rise of the New Deal under
Franklin Roosevelt the so-called Great
Society under Lyndon Johnson government
has massively expanded it's we've
created this huge welfare state I think
crime has risen and it's is now decaying
into riots rioting and smash and grab
loots in stores
um so I think things are getting bad and
I think that's because we've we've
gotten away from the fundamental
principles which made this country great
to begin with and I think we need to get
back to those principles and apply them
even more consistently not not less by
introducing even more government
intervention and coercion I think about
a good point though like this whole Mega
Republican movement Etc like these a
large part I think I think this actually
the current instability regard with
regards to like Mega Republicans like
BLM BLM protests were the largest civil
rights protest in the U.S there were
violent events but by and large they
were just you know of course 99 of
people that were completely peaceful so
that's I wouldn't say that it was I do
differentiate between uh say January 6th
and BLM of course because BLM was a
civil rights protest after you know
black people were extra extrajudicially
executed by police and gen six was uh
pretty much people attempting a coup
because they thought that the Democrats
stole the election so
um there's a there's of course a big
difference there for me and um actually
a good point that you brought up is uh
why our why Society is decaying so to
speak I think a large part of it is
actually social media like if you go to
Facebook and if you go to all these now
Twitter with you know after Elon Musk
took it over
um
like it's a hotbed of conspiracy and and
a radicalization and there's all these
there's a huge pipeline that operates uh
not physically of course but that can
suck people down into essentially being
aims towards the far right it's the
alt-right pipeline uh as they say and
it's just this Vortex of conspiracy
misinformation [ __ ] and this results
in what I what I described uh of people
you know being in these parallel
universes right like if you go to an
like a mega Republican like if like if
you let them talk for five minutes and
describe the world to you you would
think that they're they're living on a
different planet
so
um I think and social media in this
regard I mean if you look at it it's a
company abated and a company fueled
um
Court of public opinion like a sort of
uh Marketplace of ideas more brutal
right because on social media the uh
stuff that is true doesn't get shared
stuff that gets clicked stuff that Peaks
people interest gets
uh gets shares and and likes and
whatever and he and uh a description of
the democratic process in the U.S is far
less click-baity than the the uh the uh
the the Democrats are sacrificing
children and drinking their blood and
under this Washington beats area you
know and that gets 5 million shares and
then there's this whole conspiracy the Q
Anon movement actually grew up from grew
out from social media so I think if
anything in from my perspective that
actually underscores the fundamental
danger of just like unchecked uh
unchecked core of public opinion letting
letting decide things
um but we can actually if you would like
to quickly respond to that you can of
course but we can also move on to uh
coercion
because yeah I would like to respond to
that okay fine so yeah I I think the the
internet has been an amazing uh instance
of progress You know despite the the
rioting and the Looting over the last
few years there have been some bright
spots I think and I think technology the
tech sector is one of those and that's
also the sector which is uh I think very
free of government coercion so through
uh competition uh we've gotten these
great products that have like we're
using right now uh over the Internet so
the whole whole world can watch this and
I think Freedom allows those kinds of
Innovations in that kind of progress and
what we don't want is to have the
government step in and interfere and
slow down that progress or take it over
we don't want the governments uh taking
over our internet and making it like the
DMV in America or the US Postal Service
which notoriously do not provide
do not provide good service I think that
would make things far worse I think you
know as far as conspiracies and so forth
um on the internet sure yeah there's
some of that but you know there's also
ways of um countering that sort of thing
you know there's there's of course likes
and dislikes and there's search there's
algorithms that you know can boost
things or uh unboost things there there
are free market mechanisms that can weed
out bagged actors and you know through
the profit motive and self-interest
people will gravitate towards the things
that have more value over time and
things will be weeded out but I don't
think you want the the I don't want the
government to step in and uh start
introducing coercion I think that will
make things worse a lot better yeah and
I think I think this with this we can
actually turn on to go the coercion
topic because I think the issue like a a
an instance of coercion that is actually
positive or would be positive if for
example um the government enforced
um if the government enforced uh social
media
companies to combat actual
misinformation so that would be a form
of coercion because uh Facebook Twitter
Etc they wouldn't let misinformation
spread freely because I mean this is the
irony this is the irony of uh irony of
social media that uh
misinformation generates more clicks so
it's in the rational self-interest of
the company to at least let if not
promote but let misinformation uh spread
freely I don't think any major social
media Company allow like a promotes
misinformation but they allow it so this
is why this is before even before Elon
Musk about Twitter I think this is from
2011 it came out that Twitter has a
right-wing bias and pretty much Facebook
as well Mark Zuckerberg and the
previously I think leadership of Twitter
met with big right-wing Talking Heads to
discuss how they could properly platform
them Etc
those companies do take down materials
that are against the law but they but
they don't ban say conservatives when
they violate the terms of service like
when lives of tick tock for example
caused a bust that I think Boston
Children's Hospital to be shut down
because of a bomb threat and we're
spreading misinformation that's that
site wasn't wasn't shut down in fact
when Elon Musk leaked those uh screen
caps from leaves of tick tocks backend
page there was even this this little
label of like do not take action uh be
uh before Consulting the higher
leadership so it seems to me that
conservative conservative like these uh
populist sort of misinformation
spreading voices without the positive
coercion of the government of like
coercing these companies to
limit this misinformation so without
this we have these demagogues
flourishing on social media and making a
[ __ ] ton of money for these social media
companies and that's and this seems to
be everyone's rational self-interest but
societies so how how do you so would you
would you argue that corrosion is
negative even even in this context
yeah I would so a few thoughts on this
uh you I think you you mentioned a
right-wing bias at least in in the U.S
or a lot of the circles that I I hear
more about that I travel in
um Twitter and Google and Facebook these
Tech Giants are often said to have a
left-wing bias so maybe it just depends
what source you're looking on but uh I
don't think we want the government
deciding what's appropriate for people
to watch I think individuals should be
making those kinds of decisions we don't
want a government to burn books or to
ban books or have a index prohibitorium
well or something like that in the Latin
that the pope had in the uh where you
know certain Works were prohibited that
you couldn't look at we don't want the
government I I don't want the
government's deciding for me what it's
appropriate for me to to look at I think
the government should allow people to
use their own judgment we don't want to
be governed government sheep sheep
following whatever the government deems
is appropriate for us I mean you know is
that very conducive uh are we just going
to be subject to some bureaucrats
propaganda all the time some state-run
media uh which you know maybe they have
in North Korea or or China where you
know you're not allowed to publish
you're not allowed to criticize the
government if you do you could get
thrown in jail I'd much rather have a a
society where it's left up to
individuals to decide they have the
freedom to decide
uh whether to look at a sword and source
and not just have them spoon fed
whatever some government bureaucrat
thinks it's safe or appropriate for them
but that's that's already happening even
without the government though so when
you go to social media you're being
spoon fed content based on based on uh
based on your previous likes and what's
what also makes money for the company
you're being you're being spoon fed
through the algorithm so the way I see
it it's it of course China of course a
horrible example like no one wants to
live in such a repressive system but on
Facebook and on Twitter not like not
it's not like those companies are like
China but they also uh they also spoon
feed you uh What uh like things the
difference I see is only in their
interest so in the in terms of China for
example they're interested is the
stability of the Chinese government and
the uh squashing of opposition or or or
the minimizing the risk of any
instability with the face with Facebook
and Twitter and similar social media
companies the the
goal is not that the goal is money and
for them like for social media companies
uh
promoting right-wing media and
misinformation simply makes them more
money and of course there's such things
as fiduciary responsibility and legal
gray zones so they they do uh they do
favor uh this way you know right-wing
media Outlets because that makes them
more money I just have this article in
front of me like the audience can see it
they one year ago from the guardian
Twitter admits bias in algorithm for
right-wing politicians and news outlets
home feed promotes right-wing tweets
over those from the left internal
research finds so this was an internal
research at Twitter uh
and um yeah so so let's see so this is
my concern so without uh and this
actually a right-wing misinformation
such writing misinformation can spread
uh this violent missing for me or like a
misinformation that actually
conspirative violence like the lives of
tick tock uh you know doxing doctors and
and spreading misinformation about like
children mutilation clinics and causing
bomb threats or uh producing a chilling
effect across Society through
misinformation uh by for example
spreading Republic in this info about
you know trans people being degenerates
and stuff like that I mean that that is
that actually results in coercion but
like a coercion through the chilling
effect of society because when you
cannot go out uh on the street with a
say a trans badge or people know that
you're trans and you can't go out to the
street because people will beat you up
because they consume their
misinformation I would I would argue
that is coercion and so our system
results in a much worse conversion than
the coercion of the government telling
the company hey at least be equal but
but ideally don't spread misinformation
which is which can be checked by an
independent fact Checker team
so okay so yeah yeah there was there was
a lot there
um you mentioned the guardian which I I
believe is a socialist or nearly uh
leaning in that direction of socialism
so you know uh how much should I being a
capitalist want to trust a source like
that is again I mentioned before like my
perception in a lot of circles I travel
in is that there's a left-wing bias
um not that I'm right or left wing if we
just find you know right as Donald Trump
and left his you know Socialism or
something like that I'm neither of those
um but I just have a different
um perception of what sort of biases
there are climate change is an example
that's come to mind of uh an area where
I think they're they're it's all over
the media that there's um
uh internet Media or other media that
there's some you know climate Doom is
impending and it's about to happen and
this this has been story going on for
decades and decades and I think there's
been a lot of false predictions yet they
continue Alex Epstein uh who's a New
York uh times best-selling author came
out with a book called the moral case
for fossil fuels which I think is
debunked a lot of the the traditional
narrative around climate and energy
issues he recently just last year came
out with a new book called fossil future
um which also takes on the the
traditional narrative he's actually I
think brought a significant number of
people from the left who are pro-reason
and pro science and they think that
following the science means that you
have to buy this uh idea that we have to
restrict fossil fuels or else the planet
is since we go to hell so he challenges
he's deeply immersed in all the facts
and he challenges that narrative
so you don't believe in man made climate
change
I I'm not first of all let me say I'm
not an expert in this field but what
what I've learned the little I have
looked at personally issue someone like
Alex actually Alex Epstein might be a
great person for you to talk to you
about this
um uh but from what I've learned there
has been uh a lot of people try to smear
him as a climate denier or a climate
change denier the issue that's that's a
straw man and it's a red herring the
issue is not has there been climate
change or has there been uh warming
global warming or has there even been
man-made global warming I don't think he
disputes any of those things the issue
is it is whether there's catastrophic uh
Global uh global warming such that we
have to massively restrict fossil fuels
and he's he's done research to show that
life has actually gotten much better
with the increased use of fossil fuels I
mean a lot of people had predicted it
was supposed to get worse the planet was
going to go to hell you know if we if we
didn't restrict our use of fossil fuels
yet over the last few decades we've been
using more fossil fuels and life has
gotten even better yes China and India I
think are examples where people they've
used lots of fossil fuels and massive
numbers of people have come out of
poverty but let's let's let's let's not
complete these two things sure but
fossil fuels are necessary for
developing nations to develop well uh
and I'm in favor of letting say African
nations developing nations build as
reasonably clean and reasonably
affordable uh you know fossil fuel plans
because otherwise we're going to tell
them like they couldn't afford anything
else they cannot climb out of poverty uh
in other ways however
you know we had a record
warm winter like it was uh all previous
heat records have been shadowed in
Europe recently people were walking
around in t-shirts in the middle of
January
um half of the Czech forests died in in
uh due to the heat uh this was last year
uh we're seeing and and the weather is
more important so um of course this is
not the topic of discussion but actually
we can move this back to coercion so
or if if in this scenario if uh so so
this is a case of like implicit like an
indirect coercion so if I do something
which causes another thing say I ignore
climate models and I build a bunch of
fossil plants and that causes global
warning warming which uh which
affects a community negatively say it
makes their areas uninhabitable
desertification Etc then
is it is that would that not be coercion
in a sense that I am impeding those
people from leading their lives because
of my Life Choices this is my this is my
fundamental issue and we can read it
back here that coercion
is sometimes smaller instances of
coercions coercion is necessary to
prevent bigger instance of coercion
because if you don't do the because if
you don't uh use small amounts of
coercion like for example what we
discussed in social media don't post
misinformation don't call Trans people
degenerate then you cannot prevent the
big uh the big coercion which is you
know trans people being shot into
ditches at the edge of town so how do
you what's what's how does your Society
solve these issues though
okay so how do you not get the big
coercion so to speak
yeah well I think the way of thinking
about it like small coercion versus big
coercion I'm not sure that's the right
way to think about it but yeah
is there a difference between coercion
and coercion or is it all the same for
from your perspective
uh let me I can maybe we can get to that
but I had a couple other points on some
other things you said I want to make so
first of all on the on the scientific
details of you know things have been
getting record to record temperatures or
whatever so I'm not the one to debate
those kind of things Alex Epstein knows
I mean that's his bread and butter so if
you want to talk about those kinds of
claims
um I would suggest talking to him also
climate models he often uses this phrase
climate models that can't predict
climate I mean there's it's very easy to
create a computer model to make some
dire prediction and you might get
government funding uh to come up with
that conclusion because they they might
tend to fund that kind of research that
has that desired output
um so I think a lot of the climate
models are bogus uh but but again Alex
is the one to talk to you about that but
as for any legitimate issues that there
actually are with
um sometimes they're called
externalities
um I think what's needed is property
rights so if you clearly this often
comes up like with with uh Rivers what
if you live by a river and and some
someone just dumps their waste into the
river and then it flows down well
privatize the river so you have clearly
defined property rights in the river and
if someone does something that affects
your part of the river or you're part of
the air
um then you can take them to court but
there has to be a reasonable standards
Justified and uh in Prosecuting because
you can't have a civilization where
there's zero
um zero emissions or whatever and we
have to live like cavemen and can't
industrialize at all because there's
going to be some tiny percentage or
particular matter you have to have
reasonable standards and if specifying
exactly what those are can change over
time even someone like a caveman might
despite having clear skies have very
dirty lungs because he has to live
around the campfire all the time and
he's is he's breathing in that smoke and
industrialization you can eventually get
to things like in heating electric
heating which is much cleaner and gets
around those problems I I actually want
to get to uh some of the things that you
brought up is I think pertinent the
river so a good example of uh implicit
coercion would be or indirect coercion
would be if someone dumped if someone
dumped their waste into the river
thereby you know cutting other people's
fresh water supply right
um say that there's an area that like
that river is deep so it feeds into a
water reservoir and that Reservoir
supplies uh the town with drinking water
um so of course if you polluted that
water that would be you would be would
you agree that you would be coercing
like that would be a form of coercion
because you're uh
impede like you're you're limiting
people's access to uh fresh water
so what I mean if you fill in the
details of the case yeah that could I
think that could certainly be a
conversion and people are relying on a
water source and then you basically
poison it yes uh yeah that would be a
form of coercion yes and so if you prime
it but if you privatize the river that
so that would be a good solution to like
privatize it and then you have like very
clear property rights and no one can do
so that's that's a so with that you
establish a framework that's like okay
this is property this is why the
framework is you cannot pollute the
river case closed so that people will
not pollute pending you know uh pending
a a you know law enforcement action so
but the thing is what if the person uh
buying that that's that voter Reservoir
then says okay uh the Three River Motor
Reserve okay I have the rights to it now
uh I'm going to raise the price of Water
by 100 percent
it wouldn't keep within the right to do
so and would it be coercion
I mean if you're on if you're the owner
of a property uh you have you have
certain rights now there might be
contracts so you might contract with a
certain water supplier for a certain
rate and there might be a stipulation in
the contract that you can't just
arbitrarily Jack the price in the middle
of your contract term and you have to
give notice like if I plan to have a
rate increase over a hundred percent you
know I have to have some advanced notice
of that so that I have a chance to react
to it maybe move to a different town
where they're not doing something crazy
like just arbitrarily jacking up their
water prices by 200 500 percent and all
of a sudden you know I can't get any I
can't afford that so I think the free
people through the free market are not
going to want to live they're going to
selfishly and people who want to attract
people to their Community are not going
to have policies that allow them to just
arbitrarily change things around like
that that's I think that's a lot of the
beauty of contracts is they give you a
way to live a long-range kind of life
and not be at the mercy of someone's
whim who just arbitrarily tries to ruin
your life but but and then then we get
into the problem and this is what I want
to take to the discussion the problem of
natural monopolies so there are some
play there are some aspects of Life
which will naturally form of course
monopolies and we see nowadays that if
you look at the if you look at what
brands are owned by what company a few
companies own pretty much everything you
consume like if you go to a grocery
store so these companies can clearly
even if even if the Monopoly is not
natural right it's a candy bar you know
it's not a natural monopoly I mean
everyone can make it still 99 of candy
bars is going to be Nestle
um or something some other like huge
major company
so if there's a monopoly that forms and
say a for reaching year of Monopoly then
that Monopoly is then free to exploit
people and those people so the bigger
the bigger the Monopoly goes the grows
the less people can do against it so and
if at the end The Logical end point to
this is that the Monopoly goes so large
that it controls everyone's lives
in a certain in a certain part of their
life any like say water supply so one
company grows bigger grows bigger bigger
bigger and buys up or like that company
owns the entire water supply system of a
country or of an area uh and
at that point that company once the
contracts keep expiring they can pump up
the prices uh slowly but surely and they
can also under they can also um
uh then then we're going to stop like
they can undercut their competition like
they can stop other businesses to which
they Supply water for free but their
competition for like three times okay a
300 rate so this would this would in my
view be coercion though because that
like uh core is sophisticated from of
coercion because you're prevented from
what you want to do by that company
through these means so and I my issue is
an enlighten me if you have the solution
to this in your system in yours in
because in your system I just don't see
any solutions to this like a company if
it becomes you know too big to fail and
all that
wouldn't it just rule the entire uh that
just like rule the game and do whatever
they want
okay there was a lot there yeah feel
free to feel free to go over yeah so
yeah I have some thoughts on that so one
thought is um you people might be
interested in this book this is called
capitalism the unknown ideal it's a
collection of essays by Iron Rand and
there's a chapter in here uh
specifically talking about monopolies
and a lot of the fallacies that are uh
associated with with thinking about
monopolies so a lot of the points you
addressed are are addressed in that book
but let me say some some things about it
now
um I think it's it's important to
distinguish between a Government
monopoly and a uh a non-government
monopoly I don't know if you would even
want to call it a monopoly there's
certain institutions like the United
States Postal Service which are
government monopolies meaning that no
one is allowed to compete with them so
there's certain Parcels of mail which uh
someone like FedEx or UPS simply cannot
uh deliver they can't deliver certain
kinds of parcels so I think in that I
think service would be much better you
know if someone could you know deliver
the same kind of mail that the United
States Postal Service offers so it's a
little strange to me that
um a lot of people who who make these
arguments against monopolies they're
perfectly okay with monopolies as long
as their coercive Monopoly is run by the
government I mean is is what you want
just uh instead of these so-called
monopolies of the free market people
rising to the top of their
um field through great service that's
why they've become so big because
they've been provided such great service
and instead of letting people rise
through ability that way you just want
to coercively allow someone who's who
maybe is not so able like the United
States Postal Service and have the
government be the only Monopoly you're
okay with that that seems a little
strange to me also historically the the
maybe the the prime example of the evils
of a monopolist is Rockefeller John D
Rockefeller in the oil industry but I
think if you actually looked at his his
story he didn't uh exploits or gouge
people he I think famously he kept his
prices very low he knew that's how he
was able to maintain his his enormous I
think it was over around 90 percent
market share
and he had to keep his prices low in
order to keep that and eventually I
think oil was discovered in Russia and
he lost the market share and he didn't
have as as dominant a role as he did
again Alex Epstein has wrote an entire
article exactly on John D Rockefeller in
the history of Standard Oil in the way
he's been smeared I think by people like
Ida Ida Tarbell I think was the
journalist who famously
um gave this presentation of Rockefeller
which is colored uh many people's
understanding of Rockefeller but I think
if you if you know more about the
history you'll have a much different
perception of Rockefeller and and his
so-called Monopoly so there are some
points on monopolies but I don't want to
go on for too long on this so let me
pause here and throw it back to you sure
so I'd like to dispute the the claim
that a company grows because of a great
product or service that can happen
obviously but uh in general in many
cases even if you have a like a mediocre
average product but cutthroat business
politics can also carry you very far and
this is this is regardless of the
government so the argument's often made
is that oh yes these companies offering
the mediocre servers can rise to the top
because of government meddling and now I
would differentiate a USPS and such
services are different here because
those like post is an essential is an
essential service now these essential
Services I believe should be uh should
be uh in public ownership as in through
the government the indirect so it so
there should be indirect Democratic
control by the people through the
government
um and uh there's of course a
fundamental difference between the USPS
and Amazon for example because Amazon
does does it does what it does because
of profit and the USPS does what it does
because
it it's been tasked with delivering mail
so one is performing a public service
USPS that's the end goal and with Amazon
it's just growing bigger it doesn't
matter through what now their Logistics
operation happens to be their biggest
money making machine currently but
they're also doing you know movies
series whatever like they're they're
branching out so a company's fundamental
purpose is to make money
which uh I think is fundamentally
incompatible with with a coercion-free
society like if a if because uh in a
within a company you know coercion
doesn't
isn't factored in as a as a anywhere
basically the only thing preventing the
only thing preventing say Nestle from uh
giving you you know uh Snickers bars I
don't know if necessary let's let's just
say for now like the only thing that
that currently prevents Nestle from
giving you
Snickers bars with higher lead content
for so that they can make 10 more profit
because it's cheaper or whatever is that
a regulator would clamp down on their
ass I.E they would coerce them into into
not doing that so
um once again we go back we go back to
the or the original fundamental point
that
coercion sort of encourage this smaller
instances is of coercion mitigate the
larger instances of potential coercion
so you know Nestle cannot sell lead
higher lead content sneakers bars for
profit that's a smaller conversion you
know whatever uh which which then
prevents the larger coercion of you
getting lead poisoning and dying or like
or impeding you for most functions of
life so I think I think this is where
we're stuck I think this is the our main
point of main point of contention here
would you agree okay so so just to sum
up yet so small so once again it's a
quick summary because uh because uh
actually we'll have to wrap up the
debate uh in a few minutes because I'll
I'm gonna have Dylan burns on from
Ukraine
um
but so as uh to summarize my uh my
perspective here would be that coercion
is necessary uh and there's a difference
between coercion and coercion and
targeted smaller instances of coercion
such as Governor interculation is
necessary to prevent the bigger
conversion which is companies running a
mock without without any meaningful
control which would then lead to
other larger instances of coercion which
people would feel go ahead I'm sorry I
said a lot of things so you're free to
respond at your at your own pace
okay yeah so I I don't think government
Regulators are angels of course like uh
in that in that uh profit-seeking
businessmen are devils so I I don't
think you know if there's something
corrupt in human nature such that when
people try to live and make money in an
art of profits
um setting up some other people with
coercive power over them to regulate
them I don't think you're gonna escape
the problem if human nature is corrupt
you know setting up some special uh some
privileged body who thinks they know how
to how to uh best on everyone's life
that that's not going to be a solution I
think what you want is to have something
like the profit motive in people who are
snakes and are frauds uh we'll get
rooted out of and that's through the
free market competition process and it's
it doesn't happen magically overnight
but over time there are agencies rating
agencies things like Yelp Better
Business Bureau who who can um make make
judgments that people over time those
rating agencies themselves acquire a a
reliability in the public mind or I mean
that's something that the work to earn
over time and there are mechanisms
Consumer Reports that's another way that
people can look to these third parties
to have some some objectivity in
assessing you know whether this is a
legitimate company how reliable are they
to deal with
but you're not going to make a profit in
the long run you're not going to become
huge and successful as a fraudster you
might get away with it for a while but
you are going to be weeded out if the
free market is going to be allowed to
function now I don't think if you
subsidize if you have government
coercively subsidizing some company no
matter how bad it gets that's not a way
to improve service that's a way to
stagnate and or maybe have things get
worse so you mentioned too big to fail
once or twice and I I entirely oppose
that there shouldn't be a government
bailout of companies who are are running
uh poorly they should be allowed to
collapse that's the beauty of the free
market weed those people out allow the
better actors to to survive and thrive
Don't force people to prop up uh the
these failing uh inadequate companies
with with public money that's unjust and
that's that's immoral and if you if you
do allow those things to fail if you
like a lot of the best to rise to the
top then I think you will weed out Bad
actors people who might try to poison
their food which by the way is a fraud
that's that's not something you need
special regulations for if you're
putting poison in food that's that's a
form of initiating Force it's poison
basically so that's not that's not legit
and you don't need regulations you just
need standard law to uh uh deal with
that sort of case
I understand so I think uh yes so I
think we we culminated on this point so
uh because it might it might be of
course I'm not in favor of like keeping
dysfunctional companies of course alive
like I believe in a free market to some
extent but for example I think essential
essential Services should be kept uh
should be kept under private owner a
public ownership so I think where we
disagree is that I believe that if you
if you have a government-front company
so the USPS that that company in your
view is run by faceless government
bureaucrats who don't don't care how
inefficient things get of course of
course as you said there are no Devils
or Angels but still
um so government bureaucrats who do not
care how inefficient the system is they
just want it done whatever it takes and
this leads to waste this can lead to
waste but what you also have to consider
is these companies are also under under
indirect public control because they are
publicly owned so if people don't like
how USPS run for example well then
that's and there is this this this like
the preparation is disgruntled there is
negative feelings well then
uh the the political capital is created
for someone to capitalize on them this
is also I believe a form of capitalism
political capitalism that uh you know
they can capitalize on uh the fact that
USPS is better they can promise that
they're going to reform it and then
people if they elect that person they
can then rate their job in four years or
in two years however long their term is
those people exercise Democratic control
over USPS now of course and this is this
is I think where we where we should end
feel free you're going to have the
closing word as well
I think that in your world a USB sorry I
would much rather have a USBS run by
some Bureau grants who are then who can
be then shuffled and replaced by uh a
democratically elected politician based
on their promises then to have people
vote on Facebook about how USPS should
function here there whatever because
back during the
2016 election uh to 2020 elections
beforehand
misinformation popped up that that the
Democrats will cheat the election will
steal the election through USPS and the
voting uh the Sorting machines are
rigged and stuff like that and if we
allow that sort of mob mentality to
influence USPS then you know if his
theory and misinformation spreads far
enough then people might just vote to
abolish the USPS and then
congratulations you you might have just
played your likely played into the hands
of some malicious political actor so
a few I said a lot uh feel free to
respond then I think I think we can do
uh sort of shorter closing statements
and uh yeah that's that's the plan
okay so the USPS fundament mentally I
think the the problem with it is that
it's it's Reliance on coercion and I
think it's it's immoral to force people
to uh pay for some service they should
be able to choose whether or not they
support it I shouldn't have to forcibly
have my money taken away and support
this institution just I mean just as
with a bailout I shouldn't have to uh
bail out to any company uh what is it
Chrysler
um back in the was it 70s I mean more
recent cases
um it's wrong to force people to use
their money in certain ways people
should be able to decide on a free
market do I want to support this and you
know if they're if you're running a good
business you should be able to attract
more customers or have more shareholders
who are willing to help help fund your
business but it's wrong to forcibly make
people support your operation now you
mentioned in the political process you
can over time have different laws and I
I do think we should uh legislatively
have ways of uh getting rid of something
like the United Postal Service but I
don't think it should be it should exist
to begin with
um so I think it shouldn't be the sort
of thing that's up for a vote whether uh
I am or anyone is forced to fund some
institution Force should be outlawed at
the legislative level
uh let's see any other
uh points on the USPS uh oh you so
you've mentioned that it's an essential
service I don't see any essential
difference between mail or getting food
I mean is food an essential service we
have grocery stores which I I mean if
anything is essential I I guess I would
say fruit is
um certainly but we don't have uh we
don't have uh Government monopoly on
food I think maybe the Soviet Union had
that with their bread lines that
stretched for hours and hours if you
could get anything by the time you got
to the front of it I don't think putting
the government in charge of food is a
very good idea even though you might say
food is an essential service I think the
issue the essential issue here is
coercion versus freedom I think freedom
and competition is what leads to the the
best service and we don't have that with
USPS we do have it to a much larger
extent with the tech sector and we've
seen amazing progress in the tech sector
as instance by our our video call right
now so I'll end on that point thank you
yeah so I I will also add a few closing
closing ideas of course of course what
the Soviet Union did was a catastrophe
and I would advocate for my my advocacy
would be with regards to food which is
an essential of course it's necessary
for survival would be at the very least
some sort of like Universal basic income
type uh food voucher system like it in
you know in Europe I think this is
actually quite common that you with your
if your work somewhere you also get next
to your salary some kind of little meal
vouchers that you can redeem in stores I
think that would be fair my goal is to
my goal is to keep the keep efficient
systems alive but also preventing those
systems from eating people alive in in
pursuit of profit so I st my I think my
point about National monopolies uh yeah
steel stand and at any rate uh a natural
monopoly can actually lead to coercion
so if you're all the only food producer
well then in the US we have things like
food deserts for example people don't
have access to the proper to proper
nutrition uh just this is based on
Market forces so I think letting the
letting things lose in this case can
lead to dire consequences of course but
also uh squeezing things too hard like
they did in the Soviet Union I think
that also can lead to ruin but I think
the of course the solution is between
the two but on this scale I lean firmly
to the left then it was great talking to
you I think this was I think we could
explore each other's ideas a bit more in
that I wish we had more time but I've
been streaming since nine hours and I
have one more guest
okay so uh I understand yeah yeah but uh
hey uh perhaps we can perhaps you can
continue this discussion at the uh at a
different time and I thank you for
coming out thank you for coming on and
yeah this was a refreshing uh refreshing
uh different part of the stream with you
yeah thanks for having me on I really
appreciate the opportunity and yeah I'd
love to chat again sometime all right so
take care
sure bye-bye
all right so I think that went well uh
of course I'm gonna debate bro but I
also didn't want to uh turn this into
like you know blood Sports and stuff I'm
going to call it Dylan now
um oh wait uh one second actually
time zone difference is
I think I [ __ ] up the time the the
timelines
uh so we're going to do the we're going
to do the Ukraine update with Dylan and
then we're going to um
and of course General discussion like
how is how he's doing Etc if he can make
it now if he cannot make it now then
we're gonna do it some other time and
then I think I'm gonna end the stream at
that point
um people if you have any questions you
want to um
if you want to uh have any questions
left over there I haven't answered Etc
feel free to ask them uh preferably in
supers because I can actually keep track
of them
um
yeah because of [ __ ] YouTube
uh but um yeah otherwise
yeah that's I think that's what we're
gonna do
um we also we have a and I also saved a
few questions from earlier
um
I believe which I'm going to also uh get
to let's see Dylan doesn't respond yet
so I'm going to go through some
questions okay
so
um
let's see these are so these are from
the beginning so Peter Lawler uh thank
you for a donation asked congratulations
well deserved uh what's been a memorable
uh highlight and what's been a memorable
challenging creating content well
highlight has been I mean I think each
video they had I highlight on its own
somehow like I enjoy uh making them in
from from him from a different uh
perspective
um yeah and challenge is actually some
sometimes I just cannot [ __ ] record
sometimes I'm just like I I break down
in like mid-sentence I cannot pronounce
words at that point I just had to take a
break and try again later but I hate
that when that happens sometimes a
script just like comes out of me like it
does like a A4 page I just go like and
it's all recorded sometimes there's like
a sentence that I've been trying to
record properly for like half an hour it
can really vary uh also the Toronto
Transit Channel
asked what kind of tree would you be
well I think I would be a spruce
uh Alex D what's your take on lukashenko
do you follow 2020 protesting batteries
what's your uh your thoughts on his and
Putin's perspective also thanks for your
channel is great thank you and thank you
for the donation uh yeah lukashenko is
I mean he's like his his nickname is is
the Agro fooder you know it's a timpot
dictator uh he's a complete dumbass
irredeemable but he's a he's a useful
put in stooge
um and I think Belarus is here to stay
like in his current for maybe I think
the only way for Belarus to go is to be
more deeply integrated into Russia
unless something catastrophic happens in
Russia which then allows somehow allows
you know Bell Russian opposition to take
control and then break away from from
the Russian sphere of orbit
test I did follow they were of course
terrible from I mean it was great that
people people were protesting but it was
terrible as to how it was cracked down
and um
what's your what are my thoughts on
Putin's perspectives also uh I think
you're interested the same question with
regards to Putin
um yeah Putin is an oligarch dictator uh
obsessed with Ukraine uh not a good meme
um
Yeah so basically uh basically that's
that's uh that's uh very much unepic but
now Putin is getting what he deserves
and Russia is well here's this Russia is
falling apart for it so that's that's
good
one less fascist Empire to worry about
hopefully so we got some new supers I'm
gonna go from bottom to top
uh let's see hmm
[Music]
and when was the oh yeah um
protestifications I've read your comment
already left from the UK your love your
love your videos don't get
infrastructure infrastructure scams and
the end cap series was brilliant thank
you very much and for your donation
Dorsey Stuart Russell 799 Austrian
Australian dollars
um
I think you were commenting on the
debate you said yeah strange for some
strange reason leftists are more
accepting of new ideas strangely yeah I
mean that's how it goes es thank you for
the four Euros donation
do you know Sebastian Kurtz yes the the
the uh disgraced former uh Chancellor of
Austria got bogged down in a corruption
Scandal now he is going to be some kind
of like empty suit soulless consultant
somewhere I don't know uh yeah good
riddance but like Anyway at least it's
not not the FPL Cameron Bartlett thank
you for the five British pounds love
your transportation and it'll help you
love your videos on transportation area
in your opinion which country in Europe
has the best rate infrastructure and
makes them so great I think Switzerland
with the Netherlands is also is also up
there it's well funded well or well
organized high in the high culture of uh
higher organizational culture but I mean
it's like good institutions and money if
you put poor if you pour lots of money
into it into bad institutions you get
hungry if you put very little money into
good institutions then you get I don't
know uh Bizarro World Germany but yeah
institutions plus plus funding I think
uh that's that's uh that's what matters
and also this results in like very good
organization so you know you know what I
mean I don't want to answer too
long-winded North goes with the five US
Dollars thank you very much I heard you
were looking for a Florida a Florida man
yeah I'm here minus the anger
unfortunately well welcome Florida man
do what you do best which is what
Florida men do uh for that Google
Florida man and you know you'll see some
you'll read some interesting news
articles uh thank you for the donation
Minge forever five videos thank you very
much ways to break fdpr position serious
as they pay and if they pay excelled in
incestuous corruption green like super
green like support link guys lost cause
any hope for the progress in Germany so
okay so in Germany so the question is
um
how do you how do we create a good
political con uh you know a good
political Alliance in Germany
um
the the libertarian conservatives in
Germany or the libertarian leading party
is apparently blocking things I'm not
I'm I I have to admit I'm not really
following the germabolics products
closely but I do my best the link here
the left parties the last cause I agree
they're they're they've become garbage
especially after Russian Ukrainian War
um and uh Greens Greens I would I
wouldn't say greens like support greens
don't like support uh they just need
more supports okay that okay that that
might no so they don't lack support uh
they do have support uh but they don't
have enough support so that's my
differentiation it all depends on the
voters basically and
greens should practice better reach out
you know the SD the as they pay the
social Democrats in Germany they should
be less cocked out to
essentially their own and Russian
interests and be and think a bit more of
course this is this is such a such a
kitchen table and Analysis but
um yeah the German conservatives are
getting a bit more reactionary I don't
think there's a way of changing that
just vote for different uh uh parties
not say they will not have they pay not
Lincoln and if you vote for as they pay
greens or something you should be fine
like I think
voters can easily break the FTP position
but of course this is like a party party
versus voter like you know the party
should communicate properly to the voter
and the voters should then go vote so
Teamwork Makes the Dream work but I'm
really not qualified currently to talk
too much about German politics so don't
take what I say too seriously uh take
them as like semi-educated guesses B2
thank you for the five Heroes what do
you think about the use of cars in the
countryside do you think there is an
alternative yeah Countryside depends on
the countryside but generally speaking
if you don't have a car in the
countryside you're [ __ ]
um
uh in the countryside of course I think
cars will be with us for a long time
obviously
um before that there were horses carts
Etc so uh as in court as in as in the
horse guard uh and uh in the countryside
I think individual transportation is
necessary but then again the issue with
cars is not that they exist is that we
use them and mass in densely populated
areas if we got rid of that then I would
be I'll be happy hey uh the not like
there aren't enough people living in a
Countryside to to um
uh a Countryside with proper public
transportation where you only have those
trips left uncovered by public
transportation which cannot be covered
by public transportation or kettle's
reasonable be covered right so if you
know there's a village there's like a
train line or a bus bus line going going
through the village but two kilometers
from the village there are like three
houses out in this out in the sticks or
like 10 kilometers away there's three
houses
you can use your bicycle of a bicycle
with is sometimes a good solution for
the countryside but if you have to carry
stuff there take stuff from one place to
another Etc then you need personal
Transportation so but if it's just that
if it's just that then then we're done
then we're we have revolutionary we have
revolutionized uh transportation
um
yeah so that's my take basically
um
David
thank you very much for the
cop
um
I'm actually interested about this is uh
the Colombian Peso thank you very much
for the Colombian pesos uh any opinion
on conflict between Serbia and Kosovo
yeah Serbia is trying to stir [ __ ] up
with with uh with [ __ ] uh with Kosovo
there's a
you know of course there's there's the
there's the uh there's the the uh
K4 a K4 I think the K4 forces which uh
are there to safeguard peace if Serbia
tries some [ __ ] they're clearly doing it
on the on the on the on the order of
Vladimir Putin obviously because buchin
now is desperate to cause more uh
problems and divisions around Europe so
that Europe becomes distracted you know
they cannot support Ukraine as well Etc
I think
that's what's going on
um
yeah and actually we're gonna have Dylan
burns on and we're gonna I think close
with that but um but keep this if you
have questions keep the Super Chat going
it's I still have the time I'm still
answering your questions
uh so uh where was the yeah
so yeah um if Serbia attempts some
[ __ ] again with Kosovo then I'm in
favor of just like occupying Serbia at
this point because I mean they started
the Yugoslavian War they were like
complete warmongers genocide let's
[ __ ] murder everyone else who isn't
like Serbian Christian whatever and now
they're if they try to bait genocide
again then at this point I don't know at
this point this has to be dealt with
okay also Serbia is kind of a survey is
kind of like Hungary a bit uh as in
vocich the prime minister is kind of
like Urban
and he's also deep into Russia inside
Russia's ass Russian propaganda is
arrived in Serbia so
somebody will have to do something if
serbs start [ __ ] otherwise I'm all for
peaceful existence I just ask Serbia to
not be the aggressor this is the very
low bar that I've said before Serbia uh
Oliver Taylor thank you very much for
the 400 400 Hungarian foreign
public transportation in Budapest has
always been fine there was a there was a
kind of
there was a very sort of deep low point
in 2000 I think six seven eight
um but then ever since then ever since
2010 with the BKK The Budapest Center
for Transportation uh Baka so hungarians
know it it got progressively better uh
that's because uh they put in charge a
guy who was accidentally competent
uh
it was it was accidentally good at his
job and wanted to do stuff well
yeah
um
so that was
uh you know that was good and generally
Budapest public transit is pretty good
damn good all things considered you know
we're talking about a country with like
one third of the GDP of uh of Austria
and you know a Vienna's public transit
is excellent compared to that Budapest
Budapest probably it turns it is pretty
dope right it'll take you everywhere
still so yeah and Karachi is fine I mean
he's much better than tarlo starlouch
was the previous conservative mayor he
was this like Boomer a car brain Etc uh
he you know your usual stuff Connection
in comparison is actually quite
pedestrian friendly and does and does do
measures such as like actually taking
away lanes and converting them into
cycle lanes and stuff like that it's
very good and Budapest is becoming much
more bikeable car infrastructure is
being cut back induced demand is being
cut back there for it's neat
it's very nice actually
um yeah oh one more Super Chat thoughts
on CCP overreach in Europe in
universities my uni had a TN on men
visual led by International students
they were reported by CPP informant and
by them and their families certainly
were threatened by a back home yeah
yeah the Chinese government has these
like unofficial [ __ ] police for
police stations which are technically
just for to help people you know do
their stuff
oh [ __ ] of course China is after
decidance even abroad and this CCP
overreach has to be penalized but if
it's if it's an anonymous informant and
the [ __ ] is happening back home like
they get you know
and they get uh you know they suffer
consequences back home or threatened
then I mean you really cannot do
anything about that from the country
where this happens right it's it's
pretty
yeah
it's not nice
anyway
that's pretty that's pretty unepic one
could say
yeah um otherwise yeah will there be a
VOD of the stream yes the VOD will be up
uh you'll be able to watch it
yeah I'll put it up at some point I
think tomorrow maybe yeah so Dylan I
think is coming up so thank you everyone
for this super chats and the questions
um
Dylan five minutes ago said that he
needs five minutes so hopefully he comes
back
soon uh how is everyone doing
how y'all doing how are you people
is everything okay everything everyone
doing well
hmm
surely as a stream cycle stream I'm
gonna also check some messages
and I have my eyes on the Discord so
that Dylan
verse berbers
burrers
hmm
what city in Germany do you live in I
live in Leipzig
uh and do you ever looked at Vancouver
Canada
um just through maybe not just bikes and
maybe through RM Transit
and yeah
uh one second yes good
okay
I just I just had dinner and I think you
should look at the inside of Dutch
trains because they are really ugly no
I've traveled on Dutch trains I mean
they're they're not beautiful but
they're like functional and they take
you there I mean that's that's all my
it's all my criteria
criteria
oh good morning oh yeah oh the Americans
are now waking up um
well some of them and actually no good
morning okay maybe maybe a late riser
uh
how are we coping with the long stream
um I think I'm coping pretty well I've
been going for 10 hours holy [ __ ] uh
yeah by the way guys Dylan Burns um
Dylan Burns uh is a YouTuber fellow
YouTuber
uh I I'm going to link his channel to
um
the chant he does he is in actually he
actually goes to Ukraine I don't know if
he's in Ukraine already but he actually
does like field on the ground field
reporting in Ukraine so
uh he's doing great job over there and I
congratulate him uh
uh for this
so
the his channel is now in the in the
chat so he's Dylan I I recommend you
subscribe and check out his content he
used to lead the hippity debate panel
but damn uh he's doing some pretty dope
content now he's actually there talking
to ukrainians in the war zone a couple
hundred meters from Russian front lines
it's dope
um Mooring heavy uh thank you for the
Turkish liras have you heard of the
Turkish high speed rail network it's
been getting a lot of funding after 40
years almost no real expenditure and
it's good
like as long as it's as long as it's not
like uh as long as it's not like a a
this [ __ ] uh big uh vanity project by
the dictator you know like that like
we're gonna do High-Speed Rail
at the expense of every everything else
so we're gonna have the nice big shiny
high speed rail but
uh we're also going to
um
you know leave everything to ruin
um right and
[Music]
you talk a little bit a lot about
children hungry have you ever been to
Slovakia yeah I mean I've been just
traveling traveling across so like yeah
I go through Slovakia a lot I mean it's
like
it's like poorer Czech Republic and
richer Hungary so it's it's just you
know and and everyone speaks like you
know weird check there
like
and when you go to this station and it's
like buying a ticket like in Czech he
would say cope at least Tech and in
Slovakia you say could be actually stock
or something like that so you could you
and it's like
uh it's it's uh I try to try to speak
English but like the duck face
uh that's how that's how it feels
uh no turkey has the best public
transport amongst all his neighbors yeah
that's good I mean turkey is a developed
country uh plus you know their neighbors
what like Syria and Syria has no public
transportation I recall
um
I think Dylan is ready
Mr Burns
um yeah and yeah I mean turkey is doing
some pretty wacky [ __ ] now actually I'm
going to put the chat on the screen here
so we can read it together okay Dylan is
ready how many languages do you speak
five I think Hungarian English German
Czech and Japanese uh although I could
say Slovakian but that doesn't you know
it doesn't really it doesn't count you
know whatever so Dylan Burns
calling
Sebastian Jekyll while intellectuals
here in Germany are regurgitating
Putin's propaganda are there any voices
you've recommended as having uh the
director went as having made a positive
impact in this course on the invasion of
Ukraine well I have a voice for you he's
called Dylan Burns Sebastian Jekyll And
thank you for attend your donations here
we have Dylan Burns Dylan can you hear
me and can I hear you hello Adam can you
hear me I can hear you clear and fine me
too hell yeah are you back in Ukraine
yet
no I'm gonna be back in Ukraine in
February I go back in February I'm gonna
try to film with some IED Crews go back
to Harkins try to film soldiers uh film
with with uh cooks and stuff because
Cooks don't get a lot of attention in
this War uh but they're usually the the
favorite guy on the base so I have a lot
of stuff I want to go back and and film
so uh yeah I'm sticking with this war
till the end I'm gonna be going back and
forth until the war's over oh that's
that's good actually you when you're
leading the charge against the last
remaining separatist outposts in
doyesque City then you know just make
sure to live stream it okay I I've
already been told by uh chief commander
of azov that when he's a big fan of you
know Call of Duty World at War yeah the
the final mission where they like they
storm up the uh reichstag and they plant
the flag they've already given me that
role I'm the flag carrier so very
excited about that I mean hey you can go
and crash in the UK for a bit to do the
training and you can join one of the uh
territorial Defense Forces no yeah yeah
me and Boris John Boren Johnson is going
to be my spotter when I'm a sniper
Bojo the old Bojo man he goes crazy over
there man crazy Mr Burns I I believe I
do see three t-72s approaching goal
position what is your responses
oh my goodness dude I I do think out of
all the world leaders that would
actually be crazy enough to do some [ __ ]
like I think it probably would be Bojo
yeah I mean yeah I actually thought that
was one of my big grievances that like
Boris Johnson otherwise I I don't uh
wait people say you're a bit loud it's
I'm gonna decrease your audio a bit
so
um yeah so my my biggest experience with
Bojo was that like he was [ __ ] like I
don't agree with his politics but like I
do agree with his Ukraine response right
and what he did
but like [ __ ] dude while Bojo was like
strolling around in Kiev like Winston
[ __ ] Churchill right what was and
what was uh what's his name uh the other
guy the labor party leader you know uh
care Strummer no no Jeremy Corby Kirsten
kierstormer doesn't exist he's a made-up
person it's the Illumina he's a wax he's
a wax figurine they move around
animatronic wax puppet he doesn't he
never existed
yeah Jeremy corbyn meanwhile was just
like digging around and like making
empty bloody twos oh we we need Pace
like yeah wow we need peace like
thank you Jeremy you've sold [ __ ]
geopolitics congrats and you know what I
when we talk about cancer you know we
need a cure yeah it's like oh yeah
you've really you've contributed to the
conversation thank you we don't we don't
need more more like you know hospital
beds for cancer but we don't need any of
that we just need a cure just a cure
would be good yeah it's so such
reductive simplistic thinking yeah dude
if if you uh you claim to be a doctor
but but it's chemotherapy you're
destroying living cells we want peace in
our body let's end chemotherapy like
yeah [ __ ] you amen amen
the thing that really that really
bothers me is that if you were to ask uh
Jeremy corbyn about like the Palestinian
struggle right and whether they had a
right to fight back and stuff like that
we ask a lot of people about like the
Algerian struggle against like French
colonialism you're not going to hear
much uh from a figure like Jeremy corbyn
saying wow those those Algerian Freedom
Fighters should really just put their
guns down and saw it in peace you're not
going to hear that at all you're going
to hear like well yeah it was a just
struggle against French imperialism they
were 100 in the right you're not gonna
that's what you're gonna hear but if you
apply it to a western Nation or a nation
that is now being considered more
Western like Ukraine now the tables flip
for whatever reason I don't know
particularly why maybe it's because you
know it's just like self-hating a
western like they just they hate
themselves because they're Western I
don't know what it is particularly but
um I feel like if you apply this logic
in any other context they would
obviously see the problem with it yeah I
mean it's I think it's like Western
diabolism that like you know they are
leftists so they're uh opposed there so
they are opposed the the the the west
and that would mean you know uh and and
in this case you know they are allergic
to supporting Western interests even if
it's the right thing like finally we
have to finally we got something right
finally the US is doing something which
is foreign policy which is which is
good like supporting Ukraine and so just
just take the W take it take it take it
shut up take it don't don't ask
questions but no uh and this of course
results in uh well this will result in
uh further on popularity of of the left
which is a shame and I'm just reading by
the way the live UAM app uh five people
killed 27 wounded as a result of a
missile strike in nepro City currently
20 people rescued from the rubble so I
see Russia is continuing with the terror
bombing as usual yeah I I saw the
footage I've seen the photographs the
footage is really horrifying uh it's
like uh it's really like blood curdling
screams of people trying to like escape
from under the rubble it's really really
unbelievably disgusting but then when we
were like okay let's send the Patriot
air defense systems that'll make this
less and less likely and as more air
defense system have entered Ukraine uh
they have been able to stop more and
more of these missiles from getting
through as they've gotten better at
using them and they've had more
accessible to them but for whatever
reason if we give them to Tools in order
to shoot down these missiles which kill
these civilians as the Russians are
openly doing they're openly targeting
civilian infrastructure as they talk
about on Russian State tv that'll be
called an escalation uh I remember there
was a post I responded to today it was
from like I think it was like the
Communist American party like the part
party for socialist Liberation or
something along those lines okay I was
talking about how the tanks that we're
sending is a massive escalation
I I I really don't understand how we're
gonna say any amount of weapons we send
to Ukraine is a massive or horrific
escalation that needs to be avoided when
the largest escalation that has happened
in this entire conflict was the Russian
invasion I there's nothing we could do
that could possibly match that level of
escalation nothing nothing in the world
oh sure I guess I guess they're uh so I
think the camp that the de-escreation
camp is made up of two sub cams I would
say one is people who are generally
genuinely terrified of
of of
essentially nuclear war which it's not
on the table if it were we would know
about it we would see nuclear posturing
Etc plus Putin isn't suicidal but then
again like if he nukes he knew because
like there's nothing you can do about it
the decision will be made in the Kremlin
not not on your desk and um actually the
other the other Camp uh the 31st is a
terrified of nuclear war camp and in my
opinion and the other Camp I think is
those who really wouldn't mind if Russia
[ __ ] over the West in Ukraine and then
just like declared a victory and then
the um and then like they really
wouldn't mind if this fantasy that pujin
gives uh perpetuating this multiple or
multipolar balanced world if this would
be a reality I think
secretly like of course this becomes
more prevalent the more
the more towards the tanky types you
shift
but many of these people concerned
trolling about escalation and peace and
whatever they they just want Russia to
win because it's not the west and the
West is bad therefore it should lose etc
etc
so yeah so I think go ahead when it
comes to the I've talked about this a
lot on my channel when it comes to like
uh the idea of nuclear nuclear weapons
being used I'm sorry I'm very bad at
pronouncing it but when it comes to
those weapons
um I I always tell people to just like
do like a like an exercise in thought
when it comes to this uh like of course
like harp on on the idea that like hey
Vladimir Putin and his government has
never explicitly said they are going to
use these weapons in Ukraine they have
always been extremely vague they always
say something like we reserve the right
to use these weapons in the case that
Russia's territorial sovereignty and
integrity is threat and and they'll and
they'll say that out loud uh but they'll
never be explicit because if they make
an explicit like statement that we will
use it or we are about to use it then
they have to follow it up or they
Whittle down the the power of these
threats and that's what these weapons
are usually used for nuclear weapons
have never been used since the end of
World War II uh so they've mostly been
used as like negotiation tools and tools
for power balancing around the world to
dissuade Invasion and to like scare
other nation-states using them in a
practical capacity is is almost
impossible because if you were to
actually use these weapons you could a
actually end up destroying the world
which the world contains All Nations so
your nation would be included in this so
it doesn't really make much sense for
you to do that
um and also these weapons definitely in
a Ukrainian context would mostly only
benefit Ukraine as a weap I mean Russia
has like a weapon of Terror they would
have to use like 50 to 100 for this to
like these tactical like uh weapons
these legal weapons they would use uh to
really have an impact on the front line
of the war and considering the fact that
the only benefit that Russia would see
from the actual use of these weapons
since uh since they would be using them
in a tactical capacity would be Terror
think of compare that to all the
downsides first off there's a general
genuine risk of of nuclear spillover of
this radiation actually going into
Russia going into other states oh yes
and now of course that could provoke not
only a response from the Russian public
but from other nations that could be
affected environmentally from this like
for example Putin's Ally lukashenko and
Belarus or or Poland and we all know
that the polls would love nothing more
than to get more involved in this
conflict
um then there's the fact that honestly
there's a decent risk that them using
this weapon would just lead to more
support being sent to Ukraine not only
like radiological Aid to take care of
the the massive humanitarian disaster
that would be the use of this weapon but
I I don't think the United States would
respond or any European power would
respond to this by saying wow okay I
guess the Russians win let's reward
nuclear terrorism I think the the West
would probably respond and most likely
the world largely would respond like wow
Russia needs to pay for this or we're
going to be setting the state standard
that you could just engage in nuclear
terrorism after basically floundering in
a war and then the world would just cave
to you because that's just the way it is
we all just need to live in fear of of
world destruction because Putin acted
like a madman so there's a decent chance
it would lead to more weapons being sent
to Ukraine more humanitarian Aid being
sent financial aid and of course
radiological Aid which would only put
Ukraine in a in a better military
position there's also the risk of
further diplomatic isolation the Chinese
and the Indians do not want uh nuclear
weapons to be normalized India doesn't
want the uh Pakistan getting any ideas
about reclaiming Kashmir in a similar
fashion uh the Pakistani government
doesn't want it to be normalized because
they're scared of the Indians using a
nuclear weapon in some capacity uh the
Chinese don't want to give the North
Koreans any ideas because they want to
keep them on a leash and they do not
want that type of a confrontation with
the United States and South Korea
because they don't want military if
North Korea was to they would while it
would be extremely destructive they
would end that Conflict by losing they
couldn't beat the United States they
couldn't really beat South Korea and
that would end with like military bases
on their border and a massive Refugee
crisis for the Chinese uh I could go
through every single country as to why
they don't want the nuclear taboo to go
away but basically every country on the
planet does outside of maybe like North
Korea does not want the nuclear taboo to
go away and so you could probably get
the Chinese and the Indian government to
to agree to a price cap on Russian
energy exports under the scenario when
when currently they wouldn't do that so
you would have further diplomatic
isolation further economic isolation
basically zero or very little military
benefit unless they go literally crazy
with with the number of weapons they use
and this is all assuming that if Putin
was to give the order that the Russian
command would actually follow it as we
know from like uh from releases about
secret Chinese American negotiations the
Chinese government has been trying to
pressure the Russian generals to if the
situation was to happen and the order
was given to just not follow the order
either through just Pro
self-preservation or bribery how exactly
they did it we don't know but I I'm not
exactly sure that if Putin was to give
the order that they would follow through
with it one of the most basic rules of
you know dictatorship is that never give
an order that is likely to not be
followed because if you do and it's not
followed then you're you're holding the
country starts to whittle down as people
realize wow actually this guy doesn't
have as much power as we thought we can
disobey him and so and this is only like
a few of the reasons but the idea that
AAA that the Russians would use the
nuclear weapon in this conflict outside
of literally the the ukrainians have
beaten them so bad that they're on the
march to Moscow I feel the the odds of
this happening are super low and the
people pretending that it's just around
the corner of the world's gonna blow up
their doomsday profiteers we should look
at them in a similar fashion as we look
at the crazy person on the sidewalk with
a sign saying the end is near yeah
basically yeah you pretty much said
everything you there has to be said
about nuclear blackmail and I'm
currently looking at a picture of a
Russian propaganda I'm gonna link it to
you as well it's like Russian propaganda
saying that 15 caliber missiles were
launched towards give
uh key of region there's explosions all
over the place and there's a picture of
like a smoke rising and one of the best
ocean osint accounts deafmont pointed
out that that smoke is actually from a
locomotive like a steam locomotive
because that is that picture was taken
at the station
I believe it's the hard keep stage yeah
so um
stuff like this do not believe uh do not
believe Russian sources of course right
away even if they say you know oh you
know we're we're hammering Ukraine well
no you're not or maybe but not in not
the same way don't worry in the first 48
hours they disabled the entirety of the
Ukrainian Air Force
yeah W since then yeah okay that's did
you know that they destroyed like 300 of
Ukrainian High Mars launchers already
yeah actually they've already destroyed
uh I don't know if you heard this
they've already destroyed all the
armored vehicles that the United States
are sending even though not a single one
has arrived it they've already destroyed
Four Brothers oh yeah yeah yeah the
Bradleys are on the ship on the on the
Atlantic and Russia has already
destroyed four wow it's insane oh hey
and I think maybe they're gonna capture
soldar for the third time today
yeah though I think yeah I think Soledad
is is mostly gone at this point but then
again I've read a very good assessment
from I think Mike Martin he's also a
very good uh source to follow on Twitter
uh that the current phase of the war is
you know Russians are being dragged into
immediate Grinders again and ukrainians
are using uh using uh attritional
techniques again to pull back uh to uh
pull backwards meanwhile treating the
Russians so that Russians culminate and
then we're going to end up in a
situation like we did in hockey when the
ukrainians strike back and then take
back territory from an untreated Russian
uh you know formation but solidar has
been I think solidar they finally like
they they did as you said they announced
that they took solar there like five
times I don't know but now it seems
ukrainians have finally withdrew but
this was a controlled withdrawal after
like Wagner has been fertilizing the
grounds with their corpses for like in a
couple of months so
it's uh you know yeah go ahead the thing
that the the main thing that worries me
about about solidar
um is of course I think like the salt
mines and the fact that that could be
used to not only source soldiers and
weapons and be used as a launching Point
um but also there's the risk of them
using it to encircle back mode some
people talk about oh if you capture this
then back Mode's gonna be in circle but
there is a risk that later on upon
further gains that they could possibly
do this in the future it's a stepping
stone to further their further goal of
capturing the rest of the Don Bass But
the thing the thing that I that I think
is really interesting about this about
solidar is it's a city of a city is
putting it I think heavily already of 10
000 people pre-war like we're talking
like 2020 I think 2020 numbers was like
10 000 people
we've moved this war from the the
Russians thinking they're going to catch
Kiev a city of like three million people
they're gonna think heart Kip they're
gonna take these gigantic cities to like
two weeks of dialogue from the Russian
press about the Glorious battle for the
city of ten thousand people as they send
them into a meat grinder they just don't
have the the supply and manpower to keep
up capturing Village after village town
after town city after city of this size
while taking the casualties that they
currently are if if the situation
changes and they start taking less
casualties then maybe if they start
wasting less equipment in the future
than maybe but I mean the the standard
for the Russian military which was
supposedly the second most powerful army
in the world has fallen greatly when
their their most glorious capture in the
last two to three what four months uh is
a city of ten thousand people that were
not even entirely sure that they've
captured yet because they had to lie
about capturing the first the first time
four days ago yeah yeah I mean what many
people don't uh what many people don't
the note or don't realize is that we can
talk about Russian successes in the dome
best but like I'm looking at solar there
right now solidar is
not that significant like it's it's
fortified what was fortified but now
it's Rubble up here obviously but then
next to it is krasna Hora and there is
bhagmat which are way more uh
significant buckmit is a fortress
currently and Russians are actually
working on to working to encircle
bhagmat which hasn't happened yet so
that is not really a a
significant Target and also Buck mode if
Russians take it over which they might
actually
but then again it would be solidar times
five because it's a much bigger place
there's much more current troops which
which would mean much more Russian dead
soldiers so and by the time you chug
through bakmud from the direction
perspective I mean
feel free to continue you're you're
offensive but with what army you know if
your army is gone or most of your
formations are so exhausted and
decimated at that point which is the
Ukrainian plan not coincidentally to
treat Russians to the point where they
just have to stop after a while and then
ukrainians can Strike Back
The Jewel so to speak of the donbass or
slovenians these two series directions
came a bit close at some point but
couldn't reach and the lemon offensive
cleared them out from the area so uh
current Russian reports of success in
Soledad and the current ongoing
successful Russian offensive is just
propaganda for for domestic audiences I
believe because there's nothing else
happening really
the thing the thing that really uh
interests me is unironically I I think
there's some westerners that eat up
Russian propaganda more than the Russian
male bloggers
um and I and I've seen it multiple times
where for example solidar I saw Russian
military blogger saying basically hey
you know the government's saying we've
captured solar we're not actually 100
sure we've captured all of it I think
they're they're exaggerating and then I
look to like westerners like say the
Glorious Russian Republic has has
captured soldar like four days ago just
like buying the Russian media line on
this even though the Russian government
like two days later actually had to walk
that statement back but has now
announced that they've captured soldar
there there's a there's a huge problem I
think and it's not even only on the
Russian side behind you of people just
like taking the government's word at
face value no further questions you
don't need to post photos or videos or
anything like that when we all know that
if the Russians or the ukrainians or any
side of the military conflict can show
you a video of them uh winning a battle
or capturing something they well and so
if they can't produce that you should be
skeptical of all claims until those
those types of physical evidence
photographic evidence is produced like
we saw during for example the heart give
counteroffensive uh that the ukrainians
launched when we started seeing footage
of Ukrainian soldiers entering kapiansk
at that point it was basically
impossible to deny the success of that
counter-offensive oh yeah yeah I mean
Russian Russian successes uh come after
the fifth announcement maybe but uh but
then you know Ukrainian successes are
usually reported after the fact so this
is the big difference because of
operational security and whatever
whereas you know the Russian leadership
is under tremendous pressure to show
something right to give something uh of
value of something to uh a given name of
a city that they did that they took uh
and we actually have and solidar was one
of the one of these exemplars and we
actually have the updates the daily
update from devmon and he says uh it's
on the screen right now in the Stream
and the buck mode North Area the the
Armed Forces Ukraine reposed attacks in
the area of uh
you know rosalifa like this is the
Northern Area I'm pointing it with my
actually I don't have any cursor so I
will not be pointing uh thing is
Russians try to attack out of solidar
but they got stopped so this once again
will continue uh for weeks now
and according to death on the Russian
progress rate seems to have slowed down
or almost stopped it's unclear to me if
this is due to Ukrainian reinforcement
or Russia losing Steam either way I mean
this is how you stop Russia because the
Russian Doctrine
uh prescribes these like overwhelming
assaults uh to break through Enemy Lines
identify weaknesses and then just like
essentially like a zerg rush a more
sophisticated version but Wagner and
buckmut is doing the actual Zurich Rush
of like yeah just just go go my children
[ __ ] do something take the city if
you turn back if you Retreat you die
because there's like you know
soldiers behind you whose responsibility
is to kill you if you flee so let's go
yeah go ahead I want to give people some
perspective on this because I was
actually in chromatorsk uh which is in
the Don bass it's like the it's like the
big fortress in the dom best would be
the probably the most difficult City for
the Russians to take and I was there
when it was semi surrounded on three
sides this was before the archive
counteroffensive that recaptured izium
and Lyman and kupiansk and so it had the
Russians to the north it had the
Russians to the East and it's somewhat
semi to kind of like the South not as
much but somewhat over in that area as
well uh at least surrounded on two sides
and when I was there we could hear the
artillery there were strikes in the city
and on the city outskirts and all around
and there was real talk while we were
there of okay I guess the Russians are
gonna next try to attack chromators and
I saw of course I can't describe the
city's defenses in too much detail but I
saw people actively building upon the
already existing defenses that the city
had from the last eight years of
fighting during you know the the Dom
bass fighting back and forth that that
has been engaging over the last eight
years and when I was there I I walked
away with the conclusion that the
Russians are not taking the city and
they're just they're they're it's it's
too well defended uh they're they're
taking too little territory they're
taking too many casualties it was like
it was it was almost like I remember
earlier on during March there was a lot
of analysts who came forward like the
Russians are just not taking Kiev and
you almost didn't want to believe it be
I know you wanted to believe it but you
didn't because you you felt like you
were kind of like overdosing on hopium
but that ended up being the case it just
didn't have the means to and I feel a
very similar way about chromatous
obviously though it's not the same size
as Kiev but if it took this much effort
for them to take solidar and chromatorsk
is what a city of like a hundred
thousand people right and and soldar is
a city of ten thousand people is in the
way so you know yeah and there's
multiple other cities and locations in
the way that they're having way too much
trouble with I mean uh obviously the the
the scale of the battle battle and the
type of battle is different but as of
three days ago the battle for Bach moot
the area around bakmut in the city
itself has been going on longer than the
Battle of Stalingrad has been going on
for over five months and obviously has
been more intense recently but I find it
very very hard to believe that they're
going to take chromators very hard to
believe the second Army of the world
everyone I will say though that the that
the um dog shelter that we went to
chroma tours to film was about a month
ago actually bombed by the Russians so
while they might not be able to take the
city they will surely be able to you
know they'll they'll act as a uh you
know as an American ATF agent and kill
as many dogs as they can along the way
yeah basically and what are your plans
once you go back to Ukraine so like what
what will be the first place you'll go
and what will you do
I'm gonna go to Kiev and watch pirated
movies with my friends that's the first
thing of course it sounds good too
that's that's by law I have to do it you
know zelinski said he'd throw me in
prison if I didn't okay um after I do
that and I get and I get wasted
intoxicated with my friends then I'm
going to hopefully be filming with IED
Cruz and talk to them about the risks of
uh uh IED removal and how due to the
large use of cluster Munitions and the
heavy bombardment the Russians have
engaged in
um how difficult how long even after
this war is over they're going to be
dealing with these explosives
um because I I when I was around Kiev
and I was in the like the villages on
the outskirts that were bombed I did
film with a few locals in the key of
outskirts that had their homes bombed
and there was fighting over there but a
lot of mines and bombs were placed
around that area and the Russians don't
share where those bombs are placed and
so every once in a while we would just
hear an explosion and we'd think was
that a rocket was that a shell no it was
just like a deer or a person like just
stepping on a mine that was left behind
and so even in these areas that have
been long liberated from the Russians
there are still like just Munitions that
there's no record of because the
Russians the Russians not only didn't
don't want to share this information
because they don't care but also they're
not really good logistically already so
the idea of of them actually keeping
track of where they've placed all these
these weapons and Munitions uh I I find
to be very doubtful so I'm going to talk
to these people because
um I haven't seen a lot of coverage of
the IED Cruise because they're not
engaged in like hardcore Combat on the
front lines but I think that I think
their story is important so I want to
record with them uh and I have a bunch
of other stuff uh lined up but um a lot
of it's not like enshrined yet so that's
the one big thing I want to do when I
get back
all right well that that sounds good and
I'll I'll be hyped to see new content on
your channel I mean you've recorded a
whole bunch of stuff
and you have yep I got a piece actually
releasing soon about starlink in Ukraine
because I had uh Aid workers actually
filmed their delivery process process of
starlink and we cover Elon musk's peace
proposal and the reaction it got all the
controversies around it it's a it's a
really big piece I'm really excited to
release it as well all right well it
sounds actually yeah it sounds super
good then I and I I will be your late
your last video that I watched about
Ukraine crisis the uh the Chernobyl the
Ukraine's next Journal but the the
inaugador power plant that was super
good and yeah I'll be I I didn't make
more content because I want more okay
thank you I appreciate it and and people
in the chat uh do consider subscribing
to Dylan Burns I'll link his channel in
the uh chat if you want like it really
like good first hand
um good first-hand uh
didn't buns didn't Burns that's what you
are yeah if you want good first-hand
content from the Ukraine front uh thank
you but I I I I don't know if you're
you're winding down on on this
interaction or not but I I do want to
bring up one thing before before I I get
deported here uh I I want to bring up
did you did you see the story that just
dropped about Dimitri mediev you know
the the ex-president of Russia Putin's
right-hand man from The Campaign Trail
to today
um did you see that he said that the
Prime Minister of Japan should kill
himself through ritual seppuku because
he said Russia shouldn't nuke Ukraine
yeah yeah I mean is assigned the role of
the other like resident crazy person uh
yeah yeah he's not to be taken seriously
he's like the crowd Heckler at the WWE
event like whatever but yeah it's it's
interesting in a sense that like you
know when you when you see a chimpanzee
and methamphetamines and you just like
observe it what see what it does etc
yeah and I I'm not going to deport you
but uh though I was I'm going to wind
the stream down because I've been on for
almost 11 hours now
one could say I mean the 11th Hour
um you like streaming this is this is
new for you yeah yeah yeah but uh and my
voice is leaving me soon so anyway but
uh I absolutely wanted to have you on
because I wanted to give get your
perspective and I wanted to shout you
out for the audience
I think you need more subscribers
generally Ah that's so nice of you well
um the YouTube algorithm doesn't think
so but I I appreciate your endorsement
yeah don't worry about it we'll we'll
fix that yet so yeah we gotta call my
CIA context we'll get your your your CI
contact uh oh DM ldm George Russian
we'll sort things out okay amen about
time man about time yeah so thank you
for coming on I'm going to read out a
few donors and then I'm going to end the
stream for today and thank you very much
for coming on uh awesome man next time
let me know when you want to do next
week Ukraine report I'll be down once my
voice recovers
awesome man and you know what even if
you purposely sabotaged me by telling me
2 p.m Eastern Standard Time to show your
anti-American bias I still forgive you
and I appreciate you having me on Adam
well thank you well thank you for your
forgiveness and thank you for being on
man it was a pleasure have a good one
bye-bye bye-bye
so that was a neat conversation I like
Dylan it does great content okay guys
I'm going to if you want any questions
asked now is your opportunity because
once I'm done with the with the super
chats I have like five six uh once I'm
done with the super chats I'm going to
uh uh you know end the stream because I
am
I have approach I'm approaching the
limit of my tremendous power so anyway
but it's nice to have all of you here
the VOD by the way the stream VOD will
be up on the channel you can go to the
main Channel screen and then you scroll
down it's going to be there
so uh some closing donors
uh from generic two Heroes thank you
very much I can stay long congrats for 1
million uh good luck on streaming thank
you very much uh golden uh
goldsteinberg thank you for the five US
Dollars uh yibra I'm blessed here in
Boston uh
and yeah I appreciate the good work you
do it's the HM 59th Regiment of foot all
right hey uh good luck to you out there
and thank you for your donation
uh I appreciate the comment Florian
garam garam mint sorry but I butchered
that for two uh 250 euros
um congrats on one meal much love from
Ghent Belgium uh much love to you to
back
frog frog we did 9.99 thank you very
much infrastructure set up a nuclear
bomb considering their their own
unsuccessful War it's very unlikely they
would set off uh the bomb as it would
make their situation much worse and
would essentially give Ukraine the win
yeah once once Russian nukes then then
the whole world is getting involved and
Russia of course doesn't want that name
thank you for the 1 000 Hungarian
foreign thanks for all the content
because well you're welcome
and thank you for watching
um
the B night three thank you for the five
dollars
um how long do you plan to stream uh
also I've seen on some US mail bloggers
that's been Pro coaching for some reason
they obviously voted the way you
expected yeah that happens you know
but you know what can you do uh how long
do you plan on streaming about this long
I I've run out of donors I think we
covered everything do subscribe to Dylan
Burns and all the and also Alan Fisher
our RM Transit
and not just bikes the guests I had on
today uh I thank you everyone for tuning
in today
and
Jesus Christ I've been streaming for
almost 11 hours so I think I'm I'm good
uh and um yeah thank you very much for
tuning in and you'll find the stream on
my channel page
uh yeah
so bye everyone and have a nice day
slash have a nice
evening
see you around
bye